WE'RE GOING TO CALL OUR
OVERSIGHT HEARING TO ORDER
-- THIS IS A OPPORTUNITY TO
SORT OF BRING US ALL TOGETHER
AROUND A VERY SPECIFIC TOPIC
AND SO I WANNA FIRST -- FIRST
LET ME WELCOME AND THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR COMING BACK TO THE
CAPITAL TO PARTICIPATE AND
THIS OVERSIGHT HEARING INTO
THE AUGUST FOURTEENTH AND
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY ROQUE
ROTATING OUTAGES I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO WELCOME THE CHAIR OF
THE SEMI ACCOUNTABILITY IN
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
TO THIS YEAR WELCOME WELL
BEFORE I MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING I LIKE TO GO
OVER A FEW HOUSE RULES DO THE
CONTINUING STAY AT HOME ORDER
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN HERE IN THE CHAMBER
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCHED AND PARTICIPATED
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASS BE
WARNED PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE AMASSED ONE CAN BE
PROVIDED FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY TODAY IN THE
CHAMBER WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
A MINIMUM CONTINGENT OF STAFF
AND LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE CHAMBER
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE CHAMBER I WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROSOFT MICROPHONE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
CHAMBER ONCE YOU'RE DONE YOU'RE
DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE SURE
TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
AND UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USE TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
CHAMBER FOR THE PUBLIC MAY
SPEAK AT ONE OF OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOCATED
IN THE CAPITAL ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS AND IN OTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR
ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN
WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE CHAMBER AND ALSO
ASK THEM QUESTIONS FOR DIAL
IN WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A REMOTE OR A MODERATOR
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
PUBLIC CAN TESTIFY THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
AREA CODE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON THE TV SCREEN IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN POLICE PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE HEARING BEGINS
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
TO PLACE TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST
AND YOUR SMART DEVICES TO
REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT
IF YOU'RE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY YOUR MAN
ON A LIVE LINE AND WILL NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO EIGHT THREE AND MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ANTICIPATED ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY AND MAY BE
EMAILED TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
NOW AMONG THE MOST CRITICAL
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THIS
COMMITTEE THIS TO CONDUCT
OVERSIGHT OF ENTITIES THAT
ARE WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION
OUR JOB IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ENERGY ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE THE NECESSARY STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK TO PROVIDE RELIABLE
CLEAN AND AFFORDABLE ENERGY
FOR THE CITIZENS OF THE STATE
AND TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR CARRYING OUT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES THE ROTATING
OUTAGES SERVE AS A WARNING SHOT
ACROSS THE BOW THE ELECTRIC
RELIABILITY MUST NOT BE TAKEN
FOR GRANTED OUR INCREASING
RELIANCE ON ELECTRICITY FOR
HOMES BUSINESSES CELLPHONES
VEHICLES AND TO MEET OUR
CRITICAL GREENHOUSE REDUCTION
GOALS MEANS THAT WE MUST
BE VIGILANT IN SAFEGUARDING
THE SECTOR THE GRAVITY OF
TURNING OFF THE POWER IN THE
MIDST OF A WEST WIDE HEAT
STORM GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND
WITH FIRES RAGING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE MADE THE OUTAGES
ALL THE MORE INTOLERABLE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE ALREADY ON EDGE
AND UNDER STRESS BECAUSE OF
THE ECONOMIC VISIT PHYSICAL
HARDSHIPS DURING DURING BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC AND FIRES THE
OUTAGES THAT OCCURRED ON AUGUST
THE FOURTEENTH AND FIFTEENTH
BREACHED OUR CONFIDENCE IN THE
CPUC THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION'S
ABILITY TO CARRY OUT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ENSURE THAT
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES HAVE
RELIABLE ELECTRIC SERVICES THE
PRELIMINARY ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT THERE
WERE SERIES OF PREVENTABLE
MISSTEPS THAT LED TO THE
ROTATING ELECTRICITY OUTAGES
NEARLY A HALF A MILLION HOMES
AND BUSINESSES LOST POWER FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES TO AS LONG
AS TWO AND A HALF HOURS ON
AUGUST FOURTEENTH THE FOLLOWING
DAY THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND BUSINESSES AND
RESIDENTS WERE WITHOUT POWER
FROM EIGHT TO NINETY MINUTES
THE FACT THAT WE WERE NOT
INFORMED UNTIL MINUTES BEFORE
THE BLACKOUT STARTED MAKES THE
OUTAGES ALL THE MORE EGREGIOUS
WHAT'S THE GRAVITY OF THE
SITUATION BECAME APPARENT THE
GOVERNOR EXERCISES WITH ALREADY
AND MARSHAL THE FORCES OF STATE
GOVERNMENT TO SCOUR CALIFORNIA
AND THE WESTERN INTERCONNECTION
FOR NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
PREVENT FURTHER OUTAGES WE
OWE A DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
INDUSTRIAL CUSTOMERS THE
MILITARY PORTS UTILITIES IN
THE WESTERN INTERCONNECTION
AND IMPORTANTLY THE RESIDENTS
AND BUSINESSES THAT CONSERVE
ENERGY AT CRITICAL TIMES
IN SOME CASES PROVIDED
CRITICAL NEEDED GENERATION
WE NOW MUST HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DEFICIENCIES THAT CAUSE THE
AUDITS IT IS CLEAR FROM THE
PRELIMINARY ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS
THAT CENTRAL TO THESE OUTAGES
WAS A LACK OF PLANNING OR
EXECUTION NO ONE GENERATION
SOURCE TRIGGER THE OUTAGES
MATHIS ALSO BE CAUTIOUS AND
NOT JUMPED INTO SOLUTIONS THE
COMMITTEE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO PROCUREMENT IN RESPONSE TO
THOSE OUTAGES REMEDIES MUST
FOCUS SQUARELY ON THE PROBLEMS
AND TARGETED SOLUTIONS LET
ME REITERATE GOVERNOR NEWSOM
STATEMENT FROM A LETTER WRITTEN
TO THE ENERGY ORGANIZATIONS
COLLECTIVELY ENERGY REGULATORS
FAILED TO ANTICIPATE THIS
EVENT AND TO TAKE NECESSARY
ACTIONS TO ENSURE RELIABLE
POWER TO CALIFORNIANS THE
ENERGY PRINCIPLES BEFORE US
TODAY HAVE RIGHTFULLY ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE HARDSHIP
THAT MANY OF THE STATE AND
TOURED WHEN THE BROAD SCALE
ROTATED OUT AS OCCURRED IN MID
AUGUST WE HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR NOT JUST IDENTIFYING
THE SHORTCOMINGS BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO PROPERLY AND
SYSTEMATICALLY TAKE ACTIONS
TO MITIGATE THE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES I'M PUTTING THE ENERGY
ORGANIZATIONS ON NOTICE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS SEEKING
REGULAR UPDATES AND PROGRESS
REPORTS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ACTIONS ADDRESSING THE
DEFICIENCIES IDENTIFIED IN
THE PRELIMINARY ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS AND THE FINAL REPORT
FURTHER WE WILL AT A MINIMUM
HOLDEN HEARING PRIOR TO NEXT
SUMMER INTO SUMMER READING THIS
BEFORE TURNING TO OUR WITNESSES
AND TO AVOID CONFUSION IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT TODAY'S
HEARING IS FOCUSED ON ROTATING
OUTAGES THESE ARE OUTAGES
THAT ARE CONTROLLED TO ROTATE
FROM AREA TO AREA SO NO SINGLE
NEIGHBORHOODS ELECTRICITY IS
DOWN FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD
OF TIME THERE ARE GENERALLY
THREE OTHER TYPES OF OUTAGES
FIRST LOCAL DISTRIBUTION
FAILURES OR OUTAGES THAT MAY
OCCUR AT LOCALIZED LEVEL WHEN
THERE'S EQUIPMENT FAILURE
SECOND PUBLIC SAFETY PUBLIC
POWER SHUT OFFS OR WHAT IS NOW
COMMONLY KNOWN AS P.
S. P. S. S. B. S.
OUTAGES ARE DELIBERATE
BLACKOUTS ENGINEERED BY AN
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY OR
MUNICIPAL UTILITY TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK AS INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AND MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES HARDEN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE THESE PS PS
EVENTS WILL BE SMALLER IN
SIZE AND SHORTER IN LENGTH
FINALLY CASCADIAN UNCONTROLLED
OUTAGES CAN RESULT IN MASSIVE
DISRUPTIONS TO ELECTRICITY
SERVICE FOR EXAMPLE THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE NORTHEASTERN
BLACKOUT WAS TRIGGERED BY A
SERIES OF FAULTS CAUSED BY TREE
BRANCHES TOUCHING POWER LINES
IN OHIO HUMAN ERROR SOFTWARE
ISSUES AND EQUIPMENT FAILURES
LED TO THE MOST WIDESPREAD
BLACKOUT IN NORTH AMERICAN
HISTORY MORE THAN FIFTY MILLION
PEOPLE ACROSS A NORTHEASTERN US
STATES AND PARTS OF CANADA WERE
LEFT WITHOUT POWER FOR AT LEAST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AND MANY OF
THEM WERE IN THE DARK FOR WEEKS
IS IMPORTANT TO STRESS THAT A
RELIABLE POWER SYSTEM UNDERPINS
OUR ECONOMY AND QUALITY OF LIFE
CAREFUL PLANNING TO GUARANTEE
ADEQUATE POWER SUPPLIES
MODELING OF SYSTEMS UNDER
MERIT OF STRESS CONDITIONS
HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT AS CALIFORNIA
MOVES TOWARD SIXTY PERCENT
RENEWABLE ENERGY BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND A HUNDRED PERCENT
GHG FREE BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE AS REQUIRED BY CURRENT
LAW THE ENERGY ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
SEEMINGLY SEAMLESSLY OPERATE
THE GREAT DURING THE AUGUST
AND SEPTEMBER HEAT WAVE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM THE
WITNESSES ABOUT THE ACTIONS
THEY UNDERTAKE THEY UNDERTAKEN
TO ENSURE THAT ROTATING OUTAGES
DO NOT HAPPEN AGAIN WITH THAT
LET ME TURN TO OUR VICE CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON FOR
A FEW MOMENTS OF OPENING COSTS
THANK YOU UP MISTER CHAIR UP
I SPENT THE WEEKEND LOOKING
CAREFULLY AT THE PRELIMINARY
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS AND I MUST
SAY I AM NOT DISAPPOINTED I
FIND THAT IT IS -- ESSENTIALLY
DEFENSIVE -- THERE'S A LOT
OF -- POINTING FINGERS AND
SORT OF A -- BLAME -- EXCUSES
AND SHORT ON SOLUTIONS
WE ARE WE ARE SAYING IN THE
SENSE THAT THIS OUTAGE WAS A
RESULT OF A THIRTY FIVE YEAR
HEAT EVENT WE KNOW THAT THAT
IS NOT ACCURATE TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX WE HAD A SIMILAR EVENT
WITH SIMILAR HEAT THERE WERE NO
BLACKOUTS AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
MIX OF ELECTRONS WERE ON THE
GRID AT THAT TIME THIS REPORT
ALSO HINTS OR MORE DIRECTLY
POINTS AT MARKET FAILURE OF
COURSE IT DID OTHER STATES
AND REGIONS ARE NOT GOING
TO SHIP THEIR ALECTRA WANTS
TO CALIFORNIA TO BAIL US OUT
THEY HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
THEIR PEOPLE THIS REPORT HINTS
AT SOME LIMITED GENERATION
IN THE FUTURE HECK WE NEED
ADDITIONAL GENERATION NOW FOR
THE TIMES WHEN CALIFORNIANS
NEED IT THE MOST I FIND THE
SUGGESTIONS RATHER FLIMSY
IT DOES NOT INCLUDE AN
ADEQUATE ADDITIONAL A PLAN
FOR GENERATION NOW BUT IT IS
FULL OF A LOT OF EUPHEMISMS
EUPHEMISMS LIKE DEMAND RESPONSE
TO ME THAT IS A EUPHEMISM THAT
DESCRIBES VOLUNTARY BROWNOUTS
THE THROTTLING BACK OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY BECAUSE
OF INADEQUATE SUPPLY ANOTHER
EUPHEMISM IS TIME OF USE RATES
TO YOUR FURNACE A EUPHEMISM
FOR PRICING ELECTRONS SO HIGH
THE CALIFORNIANS CANNOT AFFORD
TO USE THEM WHEN THEY NEED
THEM THE MOST ARE WE HEAR
TALK ABOUT MICRO GRIDS WELL
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT ONE
SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC HAS A LARGE
PRESENCE IN MY DISTRICT THEY
JUST RECEIVED A LARGE CONTRACT
TO DEVELOP A MICROGRID FOR
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH HERE
IS THE MIX OF ELECTRONS IN A
QUOTE SUSTAINABLE MICROGRID
THREE HUNDRED KILOWATTS OF
SOLAR TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
KILOWATTS OF BATTERY CAPACITY
AN FIVE HUNDRED KILOWATTS OF
DIESEL LET THAT SINK IN FOR
A MOMENT THE NECESSITY OF
DIESEL TO MAKE A MICROGRID
SYSTEM FUNCTION NOW WE HAVE
TO ADD TO THE DEMAND SIDE
THE POLITICS OF ELECTRICITY
ELECTRIFYING EVERY WHEEL THAT
ROLLS HAS BEEN A SLOGAN AROUND
HERE WE BANNED THE INTERNET AT
THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE
WE ELECTRIFY BUILDINGS WITHOUT
NATURAL GAS ELECTRIFY HOMES
WITHOUT NATURAL GAS AND EVEN
THE THOUGHT OF ELECTRIFYING
RESTAURANTS WITHOUT NATURAL
GAS WE USED TO HAVE A GRID THAT
WAS AFFORDABLE RELIABLE AND
AVAILABLE WHEN CALIFORNIANS
NEEDED IT EVEN IN TIMES OF A
HEAT WAVE LIKE TO GRID IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX TODAY WE HAVE
AGREED THAT IS INCREASINGLY
EXPENSIVE UNRELIABLE AND
UNAVAILABLE WHEN THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA NEEDED THE MOST
WE ARE SUGGESTING SOMEHOW THAT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
FORGO USE OF ELECTRICITY THAT
THREE OR FOUR OR FIVE OR SIX
OR NINE OR TEN O'CLOCK THAT
IS WHEN PEOPLE ARE COMING HOME
FROM WORK WHEN THEY'RE PLANNING
THEIR NEXT DAY AND WHEN THE
PROMISE OF THE CALIFORNIA
GRID HAS BEEN TO THEM
ELECTRICITY WILL BE AVAILABLE
AND AFFORDABLE WHEN YOU NEED
AND HERE IS THE IRONY OF
WHERE WE ARE TODAY CALIFORNIA
HAS CREATED TWO CLASSES OF
ELECTRONS ONE CLASS IS MORAL
AND ANOTHER CLASSES IN MORE
WE ARE THROTTLING DOWN OR
SHUTTING DOWN OR CLOSING THE
KIND OF IMMORAL ELECTRONS THAT
THE STATE HAS CATEGORIZED AND
THE MORAL ELECTRONS HAVE BEEN
LETTING US DOWN AND YET IT
HAS BEEN THOSE VERY IMMORAL
ELECTRONS THAT HAVE BEEN
THE ONES THAT WE HAVE HAD
TO REACH TO IN ORDER TO KEEP
OUR LIGHTS ON WE SHOULD LEARN
THE OBVIOUS LESSONS OF THIS
IRONY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISS THANK YOU MR OF VICE
CHAIR CLEARLY WE HAVE
IMPORTANT GOALS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN
THROUGH THIS PROCESS OF --
MEETING CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
ON ASSUME YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS
I'M SURE WILL BE COVERED IN
SOME TO SOME DEGREE -- FROM
OUR OUR WITNESSES WHO ALL
INTRODUCED AT THIS POINT AND
THEN CERTAINLY MEMBERS ONCE WE
HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY HAVE A
PRESENTATION FROM OUR WITNESSES
THEN WE WILL LOOK TO MEMBERS
TO HAVE -- THEY'RE OFTEN ASK
QUESTIONS SO IF I COULD --
DR WORK TO DO WE'RE TRYING TO
GET MY ATTENTION YES OF THE
LIGHT I DO HAVE AN OPENING
STATEMENT ALL AND IT HAS TO
DO WITH THE RELIABILITY I'M
SORRY DR BURKE IF I COULD I
HAVE I WAS GIVEN A COURTESY
TO THE VICE CHAIR AT THIS
STAGE I WAS GOING TO TURN TO
OUR WITNESSES I WILL TURN TO
YOU FIRST ONCE THEY CONCLUDE
AND THEN IF THAT'S FAIR
WHY HAVEN'T WE DONE SOMETHING
ABOUT LONG TERM STORAGE IN
PARTICULAR WHY HAVEN'T WE DONE
PROP HYDRO WE HAVE NO PLANS
FOR THAT'S A WAY TO GET THROUGH
THIS WE ALSO NEED LONGER TERM
STORAGE FOR SEASONAL STORAGE
HYDROGEN IS PROBABLY THE
BEST ALTERNATIVE THERE REMAIN
THOSE PLANS WE HAVE NO PLANS
OF WHO WILL -- WILL CAPTURE
THAT FOR THE MOMENT BUT I
MAY TURN BACK TO YOU ONCE OR
WITNESSES COMPLETE THEIR --
TESTIMONY AND THEN YOU CAN
-- WE CAN MAYBE GET INTO THAT
AND THEY MAY TOUCH ON IT IN
THEIR PRESENTATION FIRST IT'S
-- MY PLEASURE TO RECOGNIZE
-- MAYOR BILL BOETTCHER
WHO IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION OTHERS INTRODUCE
EVERYONE AND YOU'LL SPEAKER IN
THE ORDER -- THAT I'M CALLING
OUT UNLESS YOU WORK SOMETHING
ELSE OUT -- DAVID HAAS CHARLES
THE CHEER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION C.
BURKE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR ELLETT MANSER THE NEW
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
WE WELCOME YOU -- MISS MANSER
WHO'S BEEN THE CEO OF THE
HI SO SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THIS MONTH -- HE WAS PRESENT
PRESENT PREVIOUSLY WAS
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE BONNEVILLE
POWER ADMINISTRATION BASED
IN PORTLAND OREGON -- THE
RELIABLE RELIABLE EFFICIENT
INTEGRATION OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
RESOURCES AND NEW TECHNOLOGY
WAS A CENTRAL FOCUS OF --
DURING FOCUS DURING ELLIOTT'S
-- TIME AT BPA AS SUCH IT'S A
PLEASURE TO WELCOME YOU BACK
TO YOUR NATIVE STATE AND SO
WILL TURN TO YOU -- THROUGH
THIS PRESENTATION SO WE'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO STARTING OFF
WITH -- PRESIDENT BATCH WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR HOLDEN AND VICE
CHAIR PATTERSON AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO JOIN YOU TODAY TO ADDRESS
THE HISTORIC HEAT WAVE AND THE
ROTATING OUTAGES EXPERIENCED
BY MANY CALIFORNIANS ON AUGUST
FOURTEENTH AND FIFTEENTH AS
WE AFFIRM TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
IN OUR LETTER DELIVERING OUR
INITIAL ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS
REPORT THE POWER OUTAGES
EXPERIENCED BY CALIFORNIANS
THAT WEEK WERE UNACCEPTABLE
AND UNBEFITTING OF A STATE
AND THE PEOPLE WE SERVE AND WE
CAN AND WE WILL TAKE ACTIONS
TO ENSURE THEY DO NOT OCCUR
AGAIN BEFORE WE GET INTO THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE REPORT I DO WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO DISCUSS THE
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS THAT
LED TO UP TO THE PERIOD IN
QUESTION WHAT WE EXPERIENCED
WAS A SEVERE ONE IN THIRTY
FIVE YEARS HEAT STORM THAT
NOT ONLY IMPACTED CALIFORNIA
BUT THE ENTIRE WESTERN UNITED
STATES TEMPERATURES WERE TEN
TO TWENTY DEGREES ABOVE NORMAL
DURING THIS PERIOD CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCED FOUR OUT OF FIVE
OF THE HOTTEST AUGUST DAYS
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
AUGUST FIFTEENTH WAS INDEED THE
HOTTEST AND AUGUST FOURTEENTH
WAS THE THIRD HOTTEST DEATH
VALLEY NOTABLY REACHED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY DEGREES
DURING THIS PERIOD OF TIME
WE ALSO HAD A SEIZURE OF DRY
LIGHTNING STORMS WHICH SPARKED
THOUSANDS OF FIRES INCLUDING
THE LARGEST WILDFIRES IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY THIS WASN
INDEED AN EXTREME WEATHER
EVENT IT IS MADE CLEAR CLIMATE
CHANGE IS RIGHT IN FRONT OF US
AND IT IS HERE NOW FORTUNATELY
FOR THE COUNTRY INDEED THE
WORLD CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
WORKING TO COUNTER ACT CLIMATE
CHANGE FOR THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS OUR STATE HAS INVESTED
IN RESEARCH AND HAS CHARTED
THE PATH GROUNDED IN SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGICAL FEASIBILITY
WE DO HAVE SOLUTIONS WE MUST
NOW ACCELERATE THE PACE OF
THEIR IMPLEMENTATION TO BETTER
MATCH THAT OF OUR CHANGING
ENVIRONMENTS WE REMAIN ON THE
RIGHT PATH AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO ENHANCE OUR FOCUS ON
RELIABILITY AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT OUR
DIRECTION OUR AGENCIES REMAIN
UNWAVERINGLY IN UNWAVERING
IN OUR COMMITMENT TO CLEAN
ENERGY AND TO OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND NOTHING IN OUR ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS LEADS US TO
SECOND GUESS A CLEAN RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE ENERGY FUTURE
I WOULD LIKE TO NOW GIVE YOU A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF EACH OF OUR
AGENCIES ROLES IN MAINTAINING
RELIABILITY WITHIN THE STATE
AND THEN TURN OF MY COLLEAGUES
CHAIR HARSH SHIELD MR BURKE AND
MR MEN'S -- AND WE K.
SO THIS WOULD BE SLIGHT TO THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR CAL AYE SO CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
CPUC AND THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION C.
E. C. H. PLAY AN INTEGRAL
AND INTERRELATED ROLE
IN MAINTAINING ELECTRIC
RELIABILITY IN CALIFORNIA
THE CDC CREATES THE FORECASTS
IT IS A STATE AGENCY THAT
PREPARES AND ADOPTS A LONG
TERM ELECTRICITY DEMAND
FORECASTS FOR THE STATE AND
THAT ARE THE FOUNDATION FOR
OUR RELIABILITY PLANNING
SPECIFICALLY THESE DEMAND
FORECASTS ARE UTILIZED IN THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROGRAM AND
THESE DEMAND FORECASTS ARE
CONDUCTED FOR AVERAGE WEATHER
YEARS ALSO KNOWN AS ONE IN
TEN PEAK DEMAND FORECAST THE
CPUC SETS THE PROCUREMENT IT
IS A STATE AGENCY THAT SETS
THE RELIABILITY REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE ELECTRIC INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES THE COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS AND THE
ENERGY SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CAL AYSO
MARKET TO ENSURE THERE IS
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO MEET
THE FORECASTED DEMAND THESE
ENTITIES REPRESENT ABOUT EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE ENERGY DEMAND
IN THE STATE AND ABOUT NINETY
ONE PERCENT OF THE DEMAND IN
THE KALISTO SYSTEM NON CPUC
JURISDICTIONAL ENTITIES SET
THEIR OWN RESOURCE ADEQUACY
RULES OR DEFAULT TO THE CALLOUS
TO REQUIREMENTS FOR A BIT MORE
INFORMATION ON A RELIABILITY
REQUIREMENTS THEY ARE SET
BASED ON THE PEAK DEMAND IN THE
CEC'S DEMAND FORECAST PLUS A
PLANNING RESERVE MARGIN OF AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN PERCENT TO
ACCOUNT FOR UNPLANNED OUTAGES
AND HIGHER THAN AVERAGE DEMAND
THE CALISTO IS THE GRID
OPERATOR IT IS A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COMPANY THAT OPERATES
THE TRANSMISSION SYSTEM AND
THE WHOLESALE ENERGY MARKETS
TO MAINTAIN THE RELIABILITY
OF THE GRID IN REAL TIME
THE RESOURCES LOAN SERVICING
ENTITIES OWNED OR CONTRACTED
WITH TO MEET THEIR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY CURRENT REQUIREMENTS
ARE SHOWN TO CAL AYE SO EVERY
MONTH FROM THERE THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROCESS SHIFTS FROM
THE PLANNING SPACE TO THE
CALLUSES ENERGY MARKET AND GRID
OPERATION ALL RESOURCE ATTICUS
ALL RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROGRAM
RESOURCES ARE REQUIRED TO BID
INTO THE ENERGY MARKETS UNDER
RULES ESTABLISHED BY CAL I SENT
THE KALISTO OPERATES ENERGY
MARKETS FOR ENTITIES WITH
IN ITS SYSTEM AND ACROSS THE
WIDER WESTERN FOOTPRINT VIA THE
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET KALISTO
ALSO OPERATES A DAY AHEAD
MARKET FOLLOWED BY RESIDUAL
UNIT COMMITMENT PROCESS AND
A REAL TIME MARKET MOVING
NOW TO -- THE ROOT CAUSES AND
THAT WOULD BE SLIDE THREE THE
PRIMARY REPORT FINDS THAT THERE
WERE THREE OVER ARCHING ROOT
CAUSES OF THE ROTATING OUTAGES
AND STRESSED GRID CONDITIONS
DURING THE AUGUST HEAT STORM
FIRST THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
HEAD OF THAT WHICH I'VE
DISCUSSED OUR CURRENT PROCESSES
ARE BASED ON PLANNING FOR THE
AVERAGE WEATHER YEARS WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTION TO
ACCOUNT FOR A RELATIVELY HIGHER
TEMPERATURES BUT NOTHING LIKE
THIS TO STAINED EXTREME WESTERN
STATE HEAT STORM WE EXPERIENCED
THIS WAS INDEED A ONE AND
THIRTY FIVE YEAR OF THAT IN
PART BECAUSE OF THE SUSTAINED
DAY DAYS THAT EXPERIENCED
THE THE HIGH TEMPERATURES
WE ARE EVOLVING OUR PLANNING
SO CALIFORNIA IS PREPARED
FOR THESE TYPES OF EVENTS
SECOND ARE PLANNING TARGETS
HAVE NOT KEPT PACE TO PROCURE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES THAT CAN
BE RELIED UPON TO MEET DEMAND
IN THE EARLY EVENING HOURS
SO THE SUPPLY AND THE DEMAND
WAS EVEN TIGHTER IN THE EARLY
EVENING WHEN AIR CONDITIONER
DEMAND REMAINED HIGH BUT THE
SELLER WAS TAPERING OFF FAST
WITH THE TRANSITION TO A CLEAN
ENERGY MIX WE HAVE MADE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR PLANNING
PROCESS BUT NOT ENOUGH TO
FULLY ACCOUNT FOR MAKING ENOUGH
RESOURCES AVAILABLE DURING
THAT NET EVENING PEAK DURING AN
EXTREME AND SUSTAINED HE EVENT
PRESENT AT HER IF I COULD I'M
SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU BUT I
I THINK IF THERE SEEMS TO BE
DIFFICULTY IN HEARING YOU FOR
SOME WHO ARE NOT US BUT WHO
ARE WATCHING AND SO IF MAYBE
YOU CAN TRY TO GET A LITTLE
CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE AND
SEE IF THAT CAN OKAY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE I'M SORRY THANK YOU
OKAY FINALLY SOME DAY AHEAD
MARKET PRACTICES MASS THE
FULL LEVEL OF DEMAND LEADING
TO A HIGHER AMOUNT OF EXPORTS
HI AT CAL AYSO CAN ADDRESS
THESE IN MORE DETAIL LATER
IN THE PRESENTATION BUT
THERE WERE SOME CONCERNS
WITH UNDER SCHEDULING IN
THE DAY AHEAD MARKET MASKED
BY CONVERGENT BIDDING
-- WITH THAT OF THE OVERVIEW
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE
TO NOW TURN TO -- CHAIR HAWK
SHIELD FOR AND THE NEXT --
POINT THANK YOU FOR THE BETTER
AND AND THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
HOLDEN VICE CHAIR PATTERSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- LET
ME FIRST JUST REITERATE WHAT
HAPPENED ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH
AND FIFTEENTH IS UNACCEPTABLE
TO ME PERSONALLY TO ALL OF US
OF THE ENERGY AGENCIES TO THE
GOVERNOR YOU KNOW TO YOU AND
TO THE PUBLIC WE OWN THAT AND
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY DEDICATED TO
GETTING IT RIGHT AND I THINK
THE BIG PICTURE MESSAGE HERE
IS THAT THIS IS A SOLVABLE
PROBLEM BUT LET ME SHOW YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH NOW TO VICE CHAIR
OF PATTERSON'S POINT THE STORM
WE JUST HAD A DIFFERENT VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE ONE THAT
HAPPENED FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
AND AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THIS
CHART THIS IS THE TEMPERATURE
CURVES FOR THE LAST THIRTY
FIVE YEARS IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
NOT JUST THAT THE TEMPERATURES
WERE HIGHER BUT THAT THEY THEY
WERE EXTENDED OVER A FIVE DAY
PERIOD AND THAT'S NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THE ENTIRE
WEST WHICH IS PART OF THE
REASON WHY IMPORTS WERE CUT
IN HALF I WOULD JUST REMIND
EVERYBODY THE HIGHEST RELIABLY
RECORDED TEMPERATURE IN WORLD
HISTORY HAPPENED IN AUGUST
DURING THIS HEAT STORM IN DEATH
VALLEY HUNDRED THIRTY DEGREES
AND SO THIS IS THE NEW WORLD
THAT WORK IN AND WE HAVE TO
CALIBRATE TO IT BUT JUST TO TO
LEVEL SET -- WE HAVE A SENSE
OF WHAT THE DYNAMICS WHERE
LET ME GO BACK TO PRESENT
BOETTCHER CORRECT NO I DON'T
-- TO STEVE YES OKAY NOW WE
WILL GO ON THE NEXT SLIDE
WHICH IS SLIDE -- FIVE WE'LL
TURN NOW TO MISTER BURRAGE
MISTER CHAIR -- I HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS BEFORE I GET INTO --
THE PRESENTATION IF I MIGHT
-- TO YOU AND -- VICE CHAIR
PATTERSON -- WE JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO COME BEFORE YOU PRESENT
TODAY -- AS NOTED MY NAME IS
OKAY YES IF YOU COULD ADJUST
THE MICROPHONE SO THAT YOU'RE
SPEAKING DIRECTLY INTO THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL PLEASE
CONTINUE GOT IT THANK YOU SO
-- AS NOTED THE CALIFORNIA IS
WELL FIRST ALSO LET ME KNOW
THAT -- I HAD AND NOW IT'S MY
RETIREMENT IN FEBRUARY SO --
MY RETIREMENT IN THIS EVENT ARE
UNRELATED -- MY SUCCESSOR IS
TO MY RIGHT -- AND I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE IN HIM TO LEAD THE
WAY FOR AS NOTED THE CALIFORNIA
ISO IS A NOT FOR PROFIT PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATION CHARGED
WITH MANAGING THE FLOW OF
ELECTRONS AGAINST THE HIGH
VOLTAGE POWER LINES OF MAKE UP
EIGHTY PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
AND A SMALL PART IN THE VADAS
GRID WALL THE UTILITY STILL
OWN THE TRANSMISSION ASSETS
THE ISO OPTIMIZES SYSTEM
-- TO BALANCE SUPPLY DEMAND
THE OUTAGES THAT OCCURRED
IN AUGUST AND THE SUBSEQUENT
CHALLENGES PREVENT ADDITIONAL
LOAD SHEDDING ORDERS TOOK
PLACE UNDER EXTREME HEAT
CONDITIONS FELT ACROSS THE WEST
INCREASING DEMAND WAS LARGELY
ATTRIBUTED TO HEAT PATTERNS OR
CLOSER TO ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
WEATHER CURRENTS THIS PLACE A
STRAIN ON ENERGY CONSUMPTION
LARGELY DUE TO INCREASED AIR
CONDITIONING USE ACROSS THE
STATE GET THE QUESTION IS
NOT HOW UNUSUAL WHERE THESE
EVENTS IN THE PAST TEN YEARS
BUT HOW UNUSUAL THEY WILL LOOK
TEN YEARS FROM NOW WHILE WE
CANNOT PREDICT THE EXACT WAYS
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL IMPACT OUR
ENERGY NEEDS WE AT LEAST HAVE
SOLID INDICATORS SUGGESTING
THE PATH FORWARD AND THESE
INDICATORS DEMONSTRATE A FEW
LESSONS RENEWABLES WERE NOT THE
PROBLEM OUR GOALS OF REDUCING
GHG CAN BE MET BUT REQUIRES
PLANNING AROUND CHALLENGES AND
RESPECTING THAT THESE RESOURCES
ARE MORE VOLATILE VOLATILE
THAN OTHERS DOESN'T MAKE THEM
BAD IT JUST MEANS THAT WE HAVE
TO PLAN AROUND THOSE FACTORS
WE NEED ENERGY RESOURCES WITH
FLEXIBLE CHARACTERISTICS TO
ADDRESS THE NET DEMAND PEAK
WHICH OCCURS LATER IN THE DAY
AND I WOULD ALSO SUGGEST THAT
WE NEED EXPANDED PARTNERSHIPS
AND COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
STATES WHERE POSSIBLE AND
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED BUT UNTIL
THEN WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE TO COMPETE WITH THEM
FOR RESOURCES I BELIEVE THE
CHALLENGES THESE PAST FEW
MONTHS ARE OF NORMAL BUT NOT A
FLUKE THE LESSONS LEARNED AND
DISCUSS TODAY CAN LEAD TO A
DECARBONISE GRID THAT MAINTAINS
RELIABILITY CALIFORNIANS
HAVE COME TO EXPECT IN THE
PAST TWO DECADES THE ISO IS
COMMITTED TO ENHANCING OUR
MARKET PRACTICES WE'VE NOTED
MAY HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THIS TO
ENSURE THEY ACCURATELY REFLECT
THE ACTUAL BALANCE OF SUPPLY
AND DEMAND DURING STRESSED
OPERATING CONDITIONS I WANT TO
THANK THE AFTER THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED
TODAY I ALSO WANNA NOTE THAT
WITH ME IS MARKED ROTH LEADER
UP IN THE GALLERY HIS V.
P. OF MARK POLICY PERFORMANCE
HE'LL BE ABLE ANSWER MORE
DETAILED QUESTIONS IF I CAN
THEN GO TO THE SLIDE THE SLIDE
FOR YOU WHICH IS ON PAGE FIVE
IT SHOWS THE CONDITIONS THAT
EXISTED -- ON THE FOURTEENTH
AND FIFTEENTH AND THE LITTLE
TWO LINES THE BLUE LINE RECORD
REPRESENTS ACTUAL DEMAND
THE YELLOW OR ORANGE LINE
REPRESENTS WHAT WE CALLED NET
DEMAND THAT IS DEMAND ON THE
SYSTEM AFTER YOU EXTRACT WIND
AND SOLAR PRODUCTION FROM
THE SYSTEM AND WHAT THAT DOES
IS IT GIVES US A VERY GOOD
POINT OF HOW MUCH HAS TO BE
SUPPORTED BY NON RENEWABLE
RESOURCES OR A PARTICULAR NON
SOLAR RESOURCES IN THE EVENING
HOURS WE HAD STATES THREE
EMERGENCIES WHICH MANDATES ON
BOTH OF THOSE DAYS WHICH MEANT
THAT ARE OPERATING RESERVES
WERE LESS THAN NECESSARY TO
MEET SYSTEM RELIABILITY NEEDS
THE GRAY LINES INDICATE THE
TIME AT WHICH WE WERE IN STAGE
THREE EMERGENCY CONDITIONS I
WAS ON THE CONTROL ROOM FLOOR
ON THE FOURTEENTH AND ON THE
FIFTEENTH AND HAVE FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT OCCURRED
ON THOSE DAYS BOTH OF THE
THE LOAD SHED EVENTS OCCURRED
DURING NET PEAK EVENING HOURS
NOT DURING THE PEAK OF THE DAY
THIS IS A POINT THAT I THINK
ISN'T VERY IMPORTANT FOR US
THAT ARE SITTING BACK HERE TO
GRAPPLE WITH AS WE PLAN FOR THE
EVENING HOURS AFTER THE SOLAR
HAS SET AN THE DISTRIBUTED
ROOFTOP -- RESOURCES ARE
GONE IS OUR CHALLENGE IF I
CAN MOVE TO THE NEXT SLIDE
WE NOTED -- AS WE DID AN
ANALYSIS AND AND NOTED IN THE
REPORT THAT UNDER SCHEDULING
IN THE DAY AHEAD MARKET
SIGNIFICANTLY EXACERBATED THIS
ISSUE WE FOUND IF YOU LOOK
AT THAT SLIDE YOU CAN SEE THE
GRAY LINE IS THE LOW THAT WAS
SCHEDULED WHEREAS THE ORANGE
LINE WAS THE ACTUAL DEMAND
-- WE ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING
INTO THE SITUATION WHY THE
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES ARE
UNDER SCHEDULING IN THE MARKET
AND TAKES STEPS COLLECTIVELY
ACROSS OUR THREE ORGANIZATIONS
TO ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM THIS
CONTRIBUTED TO AN EX TO EXPORTS
COME OUT OF OUR MARKET BECAUSE
THE MARKET INDICATED THAT THE
LOAD THAT CLEARED IS A GRAY
LINE AND THE DIFFERENCE IS
-- AVAILABLE TO EXPORT AND
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT
EXPORTS IN MORE -- ELABORATE
TERMS AS WE MOVE ON BUT I WANT
TO MAKE AN IMPORTANT POINT
ABOUT EXPORTS BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE ASKED ABOUT THAT WATER
WE EXPORTING WELL FIRST OF ALL
CALIFORNIA IS A NET IMPORTS
STATE IN GENERAL WE IMPORT
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
OUR POWER THE EXPORTS WERE
LARGELY -- OR ARE A VERY HIGH
PERCENTAGE WERE NON RESOURCE
ADEQUACY RESOURCES THESE ARE
PLANTS GENERATORS THEY'RE NOT
UNDER ANY CONTRACT NOR ARE
THEY UNDER ANY OBLIGATION TO
SERVE LOADING CALIFORNIA AND
IN A FREE MARKET THEY CAN SELL
THEIR ELECTRONS TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
OF RESOURCES ARE REQUIRED TO
BEEN INDOOR MARKET AND THEY
LARGELY DID AND THEY HELPED US
MEET THAT NOW WIN YOUR IN A NET
IMPORTER POSITION -- I THINK IT
WOULD BE A VERY BAD PRACTICE TO
CONSIDER CUTTING THESE EXPORTS
AS A REGULAR SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM I'LL LEAVE IT THERE BUT
I WILL COME BACK TO THAT I WILL
THEN TURN -- -- IS A BETTER
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO START
THE LAST SLIDE IS THAT NOT
CORRECT YES SIR THAT'S RIGHT
AND THE LAST SLIDE IS THE
RECOMMENDED ACTIONS THAT WE
WILL ALL BE TAKING SO TURN TO
SLIDE SEVEN AND WE WILL EACH
SPEAK TO SOME OF THESE BULLET
POINTS FIRST AND FOREMOST THE
THREE OF US WILL COORDINATE TO
ENSURE THE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
OF RESOURCES THAT THE CPC
HAS ALREADY DIRECTED TO BE
PROCURED ARE IN DEVELOPMENT
AND WILL BE ONLINE NEXT SUMMER
THE CPUC ALSO PLANS TO OPEN
AN EXPEDITED RULEMAKING TO
ADDRESS RELIABILITY FOR SUMMER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE ARE
IDENTIFYING VARIOUS ACTIONS
THAT WILL IMPROVE RELIABILITY
IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE RECOGNIZING THAT WHILE WE
DO HAVE NEW RESOURCES COMING
ON LINE DURING THAT PERIOD WE
MAY STILL NEED TO DEAL WITH
POTENTIAL SHORTFALL WE WILL
BE LOOKING AT DEMAND RESPONSE
OTHER LOAD SHIFTING OPTIONS AND
OTHER RELIABILITY STEPS WE CAN
TAKE RECOGNIZING THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO ORDER NEW
SUPPLY SIDE RESOURCES BETWEEN
NOW AND THIS COMING SUMMER IN
ADDITION THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PROCEEDING AT THE BBC WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
TO THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PROGRAM IN THE TRACK THREE
PROCEEDING WHICH IS ALREADY
UNDERWAY WE EXPECT TO HAVE THAT
DECISION READY FOR ADOPTION NO
LATER THAN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FOR IMPLEMENTATION
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
RESOURCE ADEQUACY YEAR LASTLY
WE ARE TAKING ACTION IN THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN THE I.
R. P. PROCEEDING TO ENSURE THAT
ALL LOAD SERVING ENTITIES ARE
ON TRACK TO PROCURE THEIR SHARE
OF REPLACEMENT POWER FOR THE
RETIREMENT OF DIAVEL CANYON
GENERATING STATION IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE IN THE I. R. P.
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO WE REQUESTED
THE LOAD SEVEN SERVING ENTITIES
TO REPORT ON THEIR DIET ABELL
REPLACEMENT CARMEN IN THE I.
R. PEAS THEY FILED WITH
US ON SEPTEMBER ONE WE ARE
ANALYZING THIS ADMISSION
AND WE ANTICIPATE MARC MERO
PROCUREMENT AND WILL ISSUE AN
ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT ORDER
IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THAT THESE RESOURCES
COME ONLINE AND THAT THEY
NEED THE RELIABILITY NEEDS
FOR THE DIABLO RETIREMENT
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THE
LONGER TERM PROCUREMENT
DECISION IN THE I. R. P.
THAT WE ANTICIPATE CONSIDERING
BY LATE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
NOW I'LL TURN TO CHAIR HI
SHIELD FOR THE NEXT BULLET
POINT YEAH JUST TO ADD TO TO
PRESENT ADEQUATE THERE WILL BE
A TEN FOLD INCREASE IN ENERGY
STORAGE THE PC'S ARE GOING
TO BE FOR CARRYING THE NEXT
YEAR WHICH IS -- A SIGNIFICANT
STEP AND IN ADDITION TO THAT
-- WE'RE GONNA AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WE HAVE SEVENTY
NINE JURISDICTIONAL POWER
PLANTS REPRESENTING TWENTY
EIGHT GIGAWATTS AND THERE
ARE SOME OF FISHING SEE
IMPROVEMENTS TO BE FOUND FROM
THE EXISTING FLEET PARTICULARLY
WITH IMPROVING CHILLED WATER
SYSTEMS -- THAT'LL GET MORE
JUICE OUT OF -- THE EXISTING
FLEET WITH RESPECT TO -- THE
THE FORECAST ONE THING WE'RE
DOING SO WE HAVE A TEAM OF
ABOUT THIRTY PEOPLE ECONOMIST
AT ASSERTIONS ENGINEERS THAT
-- PER THE DIRECTION OF THE
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
PRODUCES THIS DEMAND FORECAST
EVERY TWO YEARS AND THEN AN
INTERIM UPDATE EVERY YEAR SO
THAT'S COMING OUT IN JANUARY
IN ADDITION THIS YEAR FOR
THE FIRST TIME WE'RE GONNA
BE DOING A SUMMER ASSESSMENT
WHICH IS LOOKING AT ALL OF THE
HOURS AND REALLY COMPARING THE
SUPPLY STACK TO THOSE NEEDS IN
A VERY VERY GRANULAR WAY AND
SO I'VE ASKED CIVIL GUNNEDAH
OUR DEPUTY IN CHARGE OF OUR
ENERGY ASSESSMENTS DIVISION
WHO'S GONNA BE COURTING
THAT TO JOIN ME TODAY HE'S
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ON THAT AS WE GET INTO THAT
SEGMENT OF THE THE DISCUSSION
GO BACK TO STEVE I THINK BACK
TO KALISTO YEAH THIS IS --
SINCE -- SINCE I'M STEPPING
DOWN MY SUCCESSOR IS HEREBY
THESE ARE FUTURE LOOKING
ACTIONS -- -- WILL TURN IT
OVER TO -- MISTER MAYNES ARE
THANK YOU STEVE INSURE HOLDEN
VICE CHAIR PATTERSON MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY AND TO ENTER INTO
THIS MYSELF AND TO SPEAK TO THE
PRICE SO ACTIONS GOING FORWARD
IS A NATIVE OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND A GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY
I'M I'M HONORED AND EXCITED
TO HAVE RETURNED CALIFORNIA
DURING SUCH A PIVOTAL AND
IMPORTANT TIME FOR OUR STATE
AS I STEP INTO MY NEW ROLE AS
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE PRICE
SO I'M COMMITTED TO ENSURING
THAT THE PRICE OF PROVIDES
TIMELY ANALYTICALLY RIGOROUS
TRANSPARENT AND INTELLECTUALLY
HONEST INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
IT WILL TAKE TO BE CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN ENERGY OBJECTIVES IN
A RELIABLE AND EFFICIENT
MANNER THE PRELIMINARY
ANALYSIS PROVIDES AN INITIAL
SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS FOCUS
ON ADDRESSING THE PLANNING
PROCUREMENT AND MARKET TO
SIGN ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED AS CAUSAL FACTORS
IN THE AUGUST FOURTEENTH TO
FIFTEENTH ROLLING BLACKOUTS
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH MY PARTNERS AT
THE CPUC NCC TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE'S RESOURCE ADEQUACY
FRAMEWORK RESULTS IN SUFFICIENT
CAPACITY AND CAPABILITY TO
MAINTAIN RELIABILITY DURING
OUR TRANSITION TO A CLEAN
RESOURCE MIX FOR CALIFORNIA
AND THE WEST WITH THE REST OF
THE WEST UNITED STATES RESOURCE
ADEQUACY IS JOB NUMBER ONE WE
WILL ALSO WORK TO ENSURE THE
COMMUNICATION AND COORDINATION
PROTOCOLS ARE AS EFFECTIVE
AS POSSIBLE PARTICULARLY WHEN
ANTICIPATING HE HOT WEATHER
AND STRESSED RATE CONDITIONS
CLEARLY WE MUST ACT WITH GREAT
URGENCY AND FOCUS SO AS TO
AVOID A REPEAT AT THIS SUMMER'S
EVENTS NEXT YEAR AND BEYOND
AS WE HEARD FROM GOVERNOR
NEWSOM I KNOW YOU EXPECT
NOTHING LESS FROM US BASED
ON THE PRELIMINARY ANALYSIS
THE CASE WAS IDENTIFIED A
SET OF IMPROVEMENTS TO ITS
MARKET PRACTICES IN THE NEAR
TERM TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE ACTUAL
BALANCE OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND
DURING STRESSED OPERATING
CONDITIONS FOR EXAMPLE WE
INTEND TO CLOSELY EVALUATE
UNDER SCHEDULING LOAD IN THE
DAY AHEAD MARKET WE'RE GOING
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO DEVELOP AN INSTITUTE A
PROCEDURE THAT ADEQUATELY
COMMUNICATES THE NEED TO
ACCURATELY SCHEDULE LOAD IN THE
DAY AHEAD MARKET THIS WILL BE
DONE BY FIRST OF ALL CONTINUING
OUR NEW PRACTICE OF NOTIFYING
THE MARKET OF THE DEGREE OF
UNDERSCORE THE LOAD BASED
ON THE PRIOR STAYS RESULTS
IF LOTUS UNDER SCHEDULED
AND REQUESTING THE LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES SCHEDULING
COORDINATORS PROPERLY SCHEDULE
THEIR ANTICIPATED LOAD IN THE
DAY AHEAD MARKET WE WILL ALSO
INCREASE OUR REACH TO LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES TO DISCUSS AND
RESOLVE ANY ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR ABILITY TO ACCURATELY
SCHEDULE THE AMOUNT OF LOAD IN
THE DAY AHEAD MARKET CONSISTENT
WITH SYSTEM CONDITIONS WE WILL
ENSURE THAT MARKET PROCESS HE'S
APPROPRIATELY PRIORITIZE LOAD
SERVICE AND EXPORTS THROUGH A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WILL PURSUE
ENHANCEMENTS TO KISER RESOURCE
ADEQUACY MARKET RULES TO ENSURE
THE PLANNED OUTAGES DO NOT
CREATE UNNECESSARY RELIABILITY
RISK AND THAT PERFORMANCE
PENALTIES ARE SUFFICIENT TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE SIMILARLY
WILL DEVELOP A PROCESS TO
EVALUATE MONTHLY RESOURCE
ADEQUACY SUPPLY PLANS AND WILL
CONDUCT BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT
IF THE PLANS ARE INSUFFICIENT
IN COORDINATION WITH THE CPUC
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO CLARIFY AND
REFINE THE RESOURCE ADDICTS
ACCOUNTING RULES AS THEY APPLY
TO HYDRO RESOURCES DEMAND
RESPONSE RESOURCES RENEWABLES
USE LIMITED RESOURCES AND
IMPORTS AS WE TAKE ON THESE
INITIAL ACTIONS AND COMPLETE
THE ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS I'M
ALSO COMMITTED TO SOLICITING
INPUT FROM THE WIDE ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN OUR SECTOR
IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR SHORT TERM
SOLUTIONS AND HELP US FORMULATE
A LONGER TERM STRATEGY FOR
THE RELIABLE DECARBONISATION
OF OUR ELECTRICITY GRID ALONG
WITH SUPPLY SIDE SOLUTIONS IS
ALSO ESSENTIAL THAT WE LOOK FOR
WAYS TO EFFICIENTLY INTEGRATE
EMERGING STORAGE DEMAND
RESPONSE IN DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES INTO OUR OPERATING
ENVIRONMENT THERE ARE MANY
ISSUES THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED
SUCH THAT SUCH RESOURCES
CAN BE EFFICIENTLY CITED
DISPATCHED AND COMPENSATED
TO SUPPORT RESOURCE ADEQUACY
AND RELIABILITY IN RECENT
YEARS WE'VE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION AND
DECLINING COSTS OF STORAGE
RENEWABLE RESOURCES BUT THERE
REMAINS A GREAT DEAL OF WORK
TO DO ON THE PATH TO RELIABLY
JEFF DECARBONISATION OF OUR
GREAT THIS WORK SPANS ISSUES
INCLUDING RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PLANNING PROCUREMENT RATE
DESIGN MARKET DESIGN AND
OPERATIONS AND COORDINATION
BETWEEN LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM OPERATORS
TECHNOLOGY SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND THE I SO I AM ENTHUSIASTIC
AND OPTIMISTIC ABOUT OUR
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY WORKABLE
SOLUTIONS TO THESE IMPORTANT
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU IN AN OPEN AND
COLLABORATIVE MANNER THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF IN TESTIFIED
THIS MORNING AND I KNOW ALL
OF US IN THE COMING HERE THIS
MORNING THE FORTY ANSWERING
QUESTIONS OURSELVES WITH ART
STARTING WITH SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS THANK YOU AGAIN
I CAN CLOSE THE PRESENTATIONS
YES SIR YES SIR OKAY WE ARE
AT THAT -- WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU FOR YOUR -- YOUR
YOUR HONESTY AND -- ACCEPTING
THE RESPONSIBILITY I KNOW THAT
FOR ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS IN
THOSE MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT HERE
THEIR CONSTITUENTS THE PEOPLE
AROUND THE STATE -- -- THIS
THAT WAS A REALLY TOUGH AT A
TIME CLEARLY TO GO THROUGH AND
YOU KNOW I MUST SAY THAT THE
CONSERVATION EFFORT ON BEHALF
OF THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA PLAYED A MAJOR
ROLE IN KEEPING US FROM FOR OF
DRIFTING OFF INTO THE ABYSS --
BUT -- WE'RE NOW CONTINUE TO
GET OUR ARMS AROUND WE COULD
LOOK AT THIS AND MAYBE B.
AS A THINKER ALLUDING TO BE
INSTRUCTIVE FOR HOW WE GO
FORWARD AND HOW WE ARE IN
A MUCH BETTER POSITION TO
FORECAST SOME OF THE ELEMENTS
OF WHAT WE HAD TO DEAL WITH
THIS YEAR EARLIER HOPEFULLY
GOING INTO THE FUTURE PANDEMIC
IS NOT PART OF OUR FUTURE --
MUCH LONGER AND THAT CERTAINLY
HAD OF ITS ROLE TO PLAY --
BUT -- WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
NOT ONLY BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENED BUT ALSO THE
THING PROSPECTIVELY OF HOW WE
CAN BE IN A STRONGER PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATIONS DR CORK I HAD
INDICATED I WOULD TURN TO YOU
TO LATER FOR QUESTIONS AND IF
MEMBERS HAVE COURSES THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO POSE AT THIS
TIME THIS WOULD BE THE TIME
DUCTWORK HELLO TO ALL THIS
YEAH THE WELL THE VICE CHAIR
MADE NO OPENING STATEMENT THAT
IMPLIES THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
SOLVE OUR PROBLEM WAS TO GIVE
UP ONE OUR GOAL OF ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT RENEWABLE ENERGY
AND THAT'S JUST NOT THE CASE
WE HAVE TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
WITH STORAGE WE'VE GOT PLENTY
OF SUNSHINE PLENTY OF WIND
WE CAN BUILD MORE IT'S NOT
THAT EXPENSIVE BUT WE NEED
TO STORE AND IT PORTAL NOT
BECAUSE DID YOU SEE THAT
ARE ONE TO TWO PERCENT THAT
WE CONTRIBUTE TO THE GLOBAL
PROBLEM OF GREENHOUSE GASES
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO SHOW THE REST OF THE WORLD
THE REST OF THE UNITED STATES
STATE BY STATE THIS CAN BE
DONE AND WE CAN BE DONE AT A
REASONABLE PRICE THAT WE CAN
GET AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS NOW
THAT THIS IS STORAGE ALL BREAK
FOUR HOURS MAYBE EIGHT HOURS
BUT THE SELF DISCHARGE THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOOD FOR THE
LONGER TERM FOR THE LONGER TERM
WE'RE GONNA NEED FOR SORT OF A
FEW DAYS YOU CAN DO THAT WITH
I'M STORAGE OF THE NUMBER --
WONDER WHEN YOU'VE GOT ACCESS
ENERGY AND HAVING TO COME DOWN
FOR HYDROPOWER BUT THAT'S A
GOOD FOR A DAY OR TWO BUT IT'S
THESE BATTERIES CAN THE NEXT
SITUATION IS WHAT DO WE DO
OUR FOR THE LONGER TERM FOR
SEASONAL STORAGE N. M.
HYDRO IS GOING TO GET TO THEIR
I'VE LOOKED AT THE VARIOUS
ALTERNATIVES I THINK THE WHITE
ONE IS HYDROGEN OTHERS TO LOOK
AT THIS THE POINT IS WE HAVE
NO PLANS AT ALL AND WHATEVER
THIS IS IT'S GOING TO TAKE
YEARS TO FIRST OF ALL DEVELOP
THE TECHNOLOGY FOR EXAMPLE
HOW DO YOU IT EXPENSIVELY --
GENERATED THE STORAGE HI AND
HYDROGEN'S PAYS BY SPLITTING
THE WATER ADAMS AND THEN HOW
DO YOU STORE IT HOW DO YOU GET
IT FROM ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER
WORDS NEEDED THAT'S TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT DEVELOPMENT WORK AND NOT
A WHOLE LOT OF IMPLEMENTATION
WE THOUGHT ABOUT THE FIRST
HYDRO BILLS ALL MAKE SURE
THAT THESE NUMBERS RIGHT IN
JULY TWENTY FIFTEEN THE ISL IN
A LETTER TO THE C.
P. U. C. REQUESTED THE AGENCY
THAT THE CURRENT PUMPED
HYDRO ENERGY STORAGE TO
MEET ANTICIPATED RELIABILITY
AND RENEWABLE INTEGRATION
CHALLENGES SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CPUC MODELING HAS
CONSISTENTLY SHOWN THE NEW FOR
BETWEEN THE TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR THOUSAND THAT THE WATER
WORKFORCE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
OF LONG DURATION STORAGE PUMPED
ENERGY STORAGE BY TWENTY THIRD
WELL WE'RE ALREADY NOT GOING TO
MAKE THAT DEADLINE BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T STARTED IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY THE CPUC FOUNDED IN
FIRTH MUCH OF SIXTEEN HUNDRED
MADE A LOT OF LONG DURATION
PUMP STORAGE BY TWENTY TWENTY
SIX IT'S OVER A DECADE TO DO
THIS GOTTA START VERY SOON
ONE DIRECTION STORAGE IS
REQUIRED AS NATURAL GAS IS
RETIRED TO MEET OUR GREENHOUSE
BILL REDUCTION CHARGES AND
MAINTAIN RELIABILITY THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN OF
THE CPUC JURISDICTIONAL LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES SUBMITTED
HIS SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
DO NOT INCLUDE PLANS TO CARE
LONG DURATION STORAGE TWENTY
TWENTY SIX IN TWENTY TWELVE
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD WELL I DON'T HAVE
A POLICY TO ELIMINATE WENT TO
COOLEY METHODS THAT ISSUES OF
COASTAL WATERS TO COOL NATURAL
GAS AND NUCLEAR PLANTS WHICH
IMPACTED NINETEEN COASTAL POWER
PLANTS AT LEAST TEN OF THEM
HAVE BEEN RETIRED IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY BECAUSE OF WHAT
WE HAVE JUST GONE THROUGH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD EXTENDED THE RETIREMENT
OF BASEBALL'S THE PLANTS ONE
TO THREE YEARS AT THE REQUEST
OF STATE AGENCIES DUE TO
RELIABILITY CONCERNS THE POINT
IS WE'RE NOT EVEN PLANNING TO
DO WHAT WE NEED TO DO WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO DEVELOP THAT
LONG TERM STORAGE AND DEPLOY IT
AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE A DECADE
OR MORE TO DO MORE PUMPED
HYDRO THIS HAS TO START NOW
PRESIDENT BASHER MAYBE YOU
MIGHT WANT TO -- IT WAS A
STATEMENT BUT THERE'S QUESTIONS
AND BETTER THAN THE STATEMENT
THAT I THINK ARE IMPORTANT
TO TO PROBABLY GET SOME OF
YOUR THOUGHTS ON -- IN YOUR
PRESENTATION YOU TALKED ABOUT
ACCELERATING PROJECTS -- I
KNOW THE LONG -- DURATION
STORAGE IS PART OF THE CPU IT
CQC'S MIX OF PROJECTS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TALK ABOUT HOW
ALL OF THIS COMES TOGETHER
AND WHAT THE ACCELERATION
I I WILL DEFINITELY -- TAKE
A SWING AT IT AND I ALSO
HAVE AN EXPERT WITH ME PETE
SCHOLARS THE DIRECTOR OF
EFFICIENCY ELECTRIFICATION AND
PROCUREMENT AT THE P.
YOU SEE SO -- I DID MENTION
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER THAT
WE ARE ON WE HAVE UNDERWAY NOW
AN EXPEDITED RULEMAKING AND
TO ADDRESS THE RELIABILITY FOR
SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THAT IS UNDER WAY AND IT WILL
MAKE MANY OTHER CONSIDERATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN TALKED ABOUT ON
IN TERMS OF -- -- PUMP STORAGE
AND GEOTHERMAL GEOTHERMAL THOSE
RESOURCES ABSOLUTELY SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED WHEN DETERMINING
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE MANNER
OF ACHIEVING OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS GOALS AND ALSO ENSURING
RELIABILITY AND THEY'RE ALREADY
INCLUDED IN THE INTEGRATED
PLANNING RESOURCE MODELS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE PART OF
THE MIX OF THE RESOURCE IS
CONSIDERED IN THOSE MODELS --
THE CURRENT OPTIMAL PORTFOLIO
IDENTIFY SOME OF THE ADDITIONAL
LONG DURATION STORAGE OR PUMP
STORAGE -- WROTE RESOURCES
REQUIRED -- AS WELL SO HE
IS THERE'S ANYTHING THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON HE IS
UP IN THE GALLERY THAT -- I
PERHAPS WAS SHORT HANDED OUT
WITH THANK YOU FOR THE BETTER
-- YOU'LL HAVE TO SPEAK UP BE
YEAH I THINK IT'S CORRECT THAT
-- LONGER IF THIS WAS JUST
A SECOND I'VE HAD I'VE HEARD
SOUND LOUDER SO I'M NOT SURE
IF IT'S CHALLENGES ALL YOU
MAKE SURE SO IT IS THIS BETTER
WE CAN HEAR YOU FINE HERE
I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING
I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A WAY TO
THAT IS GOING TO GET
JUST BECAUSE LOUDEST PROSPECT
OKAY -- SO IT IS -- AFTER A
GOOD LONG DURATION STORAGE
HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCESS IN THIS LAST CYCLE
AND -- THERE YOU KNOW WORK
IS UNDERWAY TO DETERMINE HOW
MUCH AND WHAT FORMS WITH WITH
BEST A FIT INTO THE PORTFOLIOS
THERE IS A SIMPLE QUESTION THAT
WE'RE WRESTLING WITH WHICH IS
WHO IS GOING TO PROCURE IT --
AS A RESULT OF THE -- CUSTOMER
CHOICE INITIATIVES IN THE STATE
THE OF INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
ARE SERVING LESS AND LESS OF
THEIR LOAN YEAH THESE TEND TO
BE A LONG PLANNING HIGH COST
PROJECTS AND ARE -- DECEMBER
DECISION THAT REQUIRED THE NEW
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
OF RESOURCES TO COME ONLINE
FOR LIABILITY PURPOSES IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT THE COMMISSION
HAS DIRECTED ENTITIES
OTHER THAN THE I.
O. USED TO ACTUALLY GO OUT
OF THE CURE AND SO THAT IS
OUR OUR FIRST -- DIRECTIVE
IN THAT REGARD AND CLEARLY
TO GET THIS LONG DURATION
STORAGE THE COMMISSION NEEDS TO
DETERMINE EXACTLY HOW IT WILL
BE DIRECTING AND WHO WILL BE
DIRECTING TO -- INVEST IN THOSE
LONGER LOOK THOSE HIGH COST --
LONG LEAD TIME PROJECTS MISTER
CHAIR I BELIEVE THAT CHAIR
HOPE SHE'LL WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ADD TO THE -- THE RESPONSE
YEAH JUST TO ADD TO THAT --
SO WE FIND ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
OF CLEAN ENERGY RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING A STORAGE
PORTFOLIO REFUNDED ABOUT FORTY
ENERGY STORAGE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
NUMBER ACTUALLY ON MILITARY
BASES AND CAMPUSES WITH ALL
DIFFERENT CHEMISTRIES YOU KNOW
VANADIUM IRON CHROMIUM AS WELL
AS LITHIUM ION LITHIUM ION HAS
BEEN TO THE WORK FORCE AND THE
GOOD NEWS THERE IS THAT THE
COST OF LIVING MINUS COME DOWN
ABOUT NINETY PERCENT IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS AND THERE IS A
PATHWAY FOR PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL
CONTINUED REDUCTIONS IN IN COST
THERE BUT THERE IS ALSO SOME
VERY PROMISING DEVELOPMENTS FOR
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF IN COURT AROUND SEASONAL
STORAGE -- ONE OF WHICH WE
JUST FUNDED LAST YEAR AND SO
-- THAT IS A SECTOR THAT'S
EMERGING AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THOUGH IT'S A MISTAKE TO VIEW
STORAGE IS THE SILVER BULLET
IT'S REALLY A SILVER BUCKSHOT
SOLUTION STORAGE IS ONE OF THE
PIECES THE OTHERS ARE DIVERSITY
OF CLEAN ENERGY RESOURCES AND
THAT INCLUDES YOUR GEOTHERMAL
EVEN EVENTUALLY DOING WHAT
THEY'VE DONE THESE COST OF
OFFSHORE WIND MUCH IMPROVEMENT
WE CAN MAKE AROUND -- DEMAND
RESPONSE AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ELECTRIC VEHICLES HAVE BEEN
BOUGHT IN CALIFORNIA AND DOING
INTELLIGENT CHARGING PROTOCOLS
-- AND AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
STEPS SO THERE ISN'T ONE SILVER
BULLET HERE IT'S MANY STEPS BUT
STORAGE IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE
THEREFORE ONE OF THE DOCTORS
ALL BELIEVE THE CURRENT
HYDROPOWER -- STORAGE WHEN
I SEE THE R. F. P.
GOING NOW TOTAL THAT IT'S JUST
FOR AND FOR LONG TERM STORAGE
FOR SEASONAL STORAGE YOU CAN'T
DEAL WITH BATTERIES THERE ISN'T
ENOUGH LITHIUM AND COBALT TO
DO IT BY ABOUT A FACTOR OF A
HUNDRED SO YOU JUST CAN'T DO
IT WITH BATTERIES WE'VE GOT
TO DESIGN SOMETHING FOR YOU
CAN STORE ENERGY FOR WEEKS AT
A TIME THE VARIETY OF THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED I
WANT TO SEE YOUR PLANS FOR
DOING IT AND I WANNA SEE
YOU START DEVELOPING IT NOW
I THINK I HEARD THE -- THE
WITNESSES DESCRIBE IT AS OF
NOT ONE SINGLE SILVER BULLET
BUT THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
OPTIONS AND THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING I DON'T INDIVIDUAL
DOCTOR -- CORPORATE AND YEAH
I WOULD BECAUSE I'M JUST GONNA
MAKE A VERY QUICK STATEMENT
AND THEN TRANSITION TO DOCTOR
EGGMAN BUT WHAT I HEARD WAS
THAT THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
WAYS TO KIND OF GET TO WHERE
WE NEED TO BE A LONG DURATION
PUMP STORAGE COULD PROBABLY
PART OF THAT SOLUTION DR
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION TODAY -- AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
A A DIFFICULT TOPIC IN A IN
A IN A MASSIVE PUZZLE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IN THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
AND CLEANEST WAY POSSIBLE I
WILL ALSO SAY SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTS SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
IN THE DELTA AREA AND THE HEAT
THAT WE EXPERIENCE -- IN THE
MIDST OF A PANDEMIC IN THE
MIDST OF WILDFIRES TO HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT TURNING OFF YOUR
POWER CREATED ANXIETY LIKE
I HAVE NOT EXPERIENCED IN MY
COMMUNITY FOUR IN IN MY IN MY
LIFETIME ASSEMBLY WHO CHAIRS
THE AGRICULTURE COMMISSION TO
THE COMMITTEE ON THE COST OF
A POWER THE COST OF OF WHAT
IT TAKES TO SHUT DOWN IS --
IT WILL TAKE IT WILL TAKE A
LONG TIME TO RECOVER FROM SO
I WENT ONLINE SO MY COMMENTS
WITH THE -- MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
CORK -- THAT WE NEED LONG TERM
STORAGE I HAD A I HAD A -- A
BILL LAST YEAR THAT I THINK
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO REVISIT
THAT AND WE NEED TO DO IT WE
CAN'T JUST KEEP TALKING ABOUT
IT IT'S GOT TO BE PLANNED IT'S
GOT TO BE WE NEED TO HAVE A
GOAL OUT THERE AND THIRTY WHEN
I HEAR YOU TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
GONNA MAKE IT NEXT YEAR I THINK
ABOUT AS I AM APPROACHING AGE
OF RETIREMENT RIGHT SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RETIREMENT BUT
WE'RE JUST PLANNING YEAR BY
YEAR WE'VE GOT TO DO BETTER
TO GET THERE IF WE JUST ARE
PLANNING ON FOR NEXT YEAR WE
CAN'T GET THERE SO I THINK
THE LONG TERM PLANS NEED TO
BE IMPLEMENTED PLANNED AND
IMPLEMENTED AND SEE THE R.
PEAS GO OUT ON THE ISSUE OF MY
MORAL OR IMMORAL -- ELECTRONS
I FOUND THAT FASCINATING OF
THE AS AS AS A GOOD CATHOLIC I
ALSO BELIEVE IN IN FORGIVENESS
AND AND DEGREES OF OF WHAT WE
CAN DO -- SO I'D ALSO LIKE TO
SEE IS EXPAND OFFSHORE WIND
I LIKE TO SEE US DO MORE WITH
WITH BIOMASS AND I NEED YOU
TO TELL US WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
THINGS HAPPEN SO WE CAN HAVE
A CONSISTENT BASELOAD BOTH
IN THE FOREST FIRES AND I WE
LOST A PLACE WITH A LITTLE
OFF THE GRID AND HAD TO RELY
ON THE SOLAR NEVER WORKED I
COULD NEVER GET MY MY PROPANE
REFRIGERATOR MY SOLAR POWER
ALL TO WORK AT THE SAME TIME
BUT NOW WOULD BURN TO THE
GROUND SO IT'S A REALLY A NEW
ISSUE -- BUT I CAN TELL YOU
GOING UP THERE AND THE IMPACT
THAT I STILL HAVE A MY LOANS
FROM THE SMOKE THAT CAME DOWN
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY TO SIT
IN THE VALLEY IS UNACCEPTABLE
RIGHT AND THE AMOUNT OF OF
OF THE REASON WE NEED TO TAKE
OUT OF OUR FORCED THE AMOUNT
OF WASTE THAT IS GENERATED BY
OUR AG THAT WE NEED THEY NEED
TO BE TO PRUNE WE NEED TO TAKE
CARE OF THINGS AND WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING WITH ALL OF THAT
AND THE CLEANER ENERGY WE CAN
MAKE SOME OF THAT AGAIN MANAGE
OUR BASE I THINK IT'S JUST A
SMARTER WAY TO GO WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TURN OUR
BACK ON OUR FLOORS AND OUR
HAGMAN'S NEED TO BE ABLE TO
USE THEM IN A COLLABORATIVE
WAY TO INCREASE OUR ABILITY TO
MAINTAIN CAPACITY IS INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING FOR THOSE OF US
WHO LIVE IN THE VALLEY WHO
HAVE EXTREME HEAT AND EXTREME
POVERTY THEY HAVE TO EXPLAIN
TO PEOPLE WHY THEY HAVE TO TURN
THEIR POWER AND SO I WILL BUY
ABOVE EXPRESSED SOME OF THE
URGENCY THAT WE ALL FEEL TO
ADDRESS THIS THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE GET MORE AT HOME ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND AND REALLY LOOK AT
EVERY SYSTEM ON THE TABLE TO
BE ABLE TO MANAGE IT IN A LONG
TERM FOR A LONG TERM GOAL BUT
IN SHORT TERM STEPS THAT WE CAN
ALL SEE AND CHECK OFF A YEAR
BY YEAR ARE WE NEEDING THOSE
TO BE ABLE TO GET THE ULTIMATE
TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT AND KEEP LOTS OF
MR KING MISS RAYOS GARCIA
MISTER
THANK YOU MR LOTS OF THANK
YOU TO ALL THE LEADERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR AND REALLY
BEING HERE TODAY -- HAVEN'T
HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
JUST LIKE MY COLLEAGUES --
ONE PARTICULAR AREA OBVIOUSLY
IS TO SURE THAT WE ARE DOING
-- PROPER PROCUREMENT AND --
DOING THE PROPER REGULATION
REGARDING OUR ENERGY PROCESS
AND IN PARTICULAR TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE EXPEDITING THE
PROCUREMENT BUT ALSO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
AS WELL AS BATTERY STORAGE --
OBVIOUSLY YOUR AGENCIES ARE NOT
THOUGHT OF AS NIMBLE WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED THIS ENERGY WE
NEEDED THIS ENERGY YESTERDAY
AND QUITE OFTEN FRANKLY AT THE
SAME THAT WE HAVE A -- -- A
PROCESS FOR A MANAGER TO SOME
OF THE MISNOMER WE WE HAVE
A NINETEENTH CENTURY ENERGY
SYSTEM WHERE YOU GENERATE
ENERGY AND YOU HAVE TO USE IT
IMMEDIATELY WE DON'T REALLY
MANAGER WE WE GENERATED AND
WE USE IT AND WE HOPE TO YOU
KNOW WE NEED IT WE HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO BUY IT FROM SOMEWHERE
THAT'S BEING GENERATED SO IF
YOU COULD REALLY SPEAK TO HOW
YOUR AGENCIES ARE UPDATING
YOUR SPECIFIC PROCESSES SO
THAT IT DOESN'T TAKE YEARS AND
YEARS TO -- PURCHASE DEVELOP
NEW ENERGY AND I WOULD LIKE IN
PARTICULAR TO HAVE HIGH SO --
TALK ABOUT HOW YOU ARE BETTER
MANAGING THE ENERGY BECAUSE I
THINK THIS WORD MANAGING OF THE
ENERGY SYSTEM IS SORT OF A MY
PASSWORD BUT A MISNOMER I CAN
SPEAK A BIT TO THE PLANNING --
MR TANG -- WE WE DO HAVE LONGER
TERM PLANNING WE PLAN THE YEAR
AHEAD THREE YEARS AND FIVE
YEARS -- ARE ARE PLANNING CYCLE
ALONG WITH THE FORECASTING
AND OTHER INFORMATION THAT WE
ALL SHARE TOGETHER AND I WILL
LET CHAIRMAN HOPE SHE'LL SPEAK
TO THE FORECASTING -- AS WELL
AND AS I MENTIONED WE DO HAVE
UNDERWENT EXPEDITED -- I OUR
RULEMAKING PROCEEDING THAT
WILL INDEED LOOK AT SOME OF
THE RESOURCES FOR THIS COMING
YEAR SO THERE'S A SHORT TERM
AND AND A LONG TERM EFFORT IT'S
ALWAYS UNDER WAY AT THE PC I
WILL SAY THAT SINCE I'VE BEEN
AT THE PC MISTER CHANG THIS
LAST YEAR -- I HAVE BEEN --
I HAVE BEEN AMAZED AT HOW
QUICKLY AND MORE NIMBLE NOTHING
NICHOLAS BUT MORE NIMBLE THE
AND PC HAS BECOME JUST AS
AN EXAMPLE WE WERE ABLE TO
START INCOMPLETE THE PGA ANY
BANKRUPTCY RULE MAKING IN EIGHT
MONTHS AT THE SAME TIME THAT WE
WERE DOING OUR A AND I. R.
P. WORK ALL THE WHILE WE WERE
ALSO DOING THE T.
MOBILE AND MERGER WE FINISHED
AND DURING THAT SAME SIX MONTH
OR EIGHT NINE MONTH PERIOD
THE -- MICROGRID PHASE TWO
RULEMAKING I STARTED THE TELCO
-- PHASE ONE AND PHASE TWO
PROCEEDINGS THAT GO TO THE
TELCO EFFORTS UNDER P. S. P.
S. SO IT IS TRUE WE HAVE SOME
PRETTY ARCHAIC PROCESSES AT THE
PC BUT WE'VE BEEN MOVING IN A
MUCH MORE SWIFT I THINK LESS
BUREAUCRATIC MANNER IT LEAST
IN MY TWELVE MONTHS OF BEING ON
THE ON THE COMMISSION -- DAVID
WOULD YOU I CAN'T SEE WHO WANTS
TO SPEAK OKAY STEVE I CAN'T
SEE YOU I'M SORRY -- WELL I'LL
GO AHEAD AND TRY TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THESE THINGS -- THANK
YOU AND MISTER TANK -- YOU
KNOW LET ME JUST BE A LITTLE
BIT EXPENSIVE ANSWERING THIS
WE WE DEFINITELY FIRST OF ALL
I WANT EVERYBODY TO ESTABLISH
THAT WE REGULARLY OPERATE THE
GRID AT OVER FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE LOAD SERVED BY -- BASICALLY
SOLAR AND WIND REGULARLY WERE
RECOGNIZED AROUND THE WORLD AS
THAT AND WE'VE HAD ABOUT EIGHTY
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS COME TO THE I SO
TO SEE HOW WE'RE DOING IT AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING RECOGNIZED AS
HAVING A MARKET THAT IS VERY
FORWARD LEANING TO AND I CAN
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF THAT WE
ALLOW AS AN EXAMPLE DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES OR ANY
DISTRIBUTED ASSET TO COME INTO
OUR MARKETS AS AN AGGREGATION
THAT CAPABILITY IS THERE WE'RE
ALSO LEARNING HOW TO OPERATE
THE GRID AS AN EXAMPLE A A VERY
LARGE BATTERY OVER TWO HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS CALLED THE GATEWAY
BATTERY -- CAME ONLINE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS AND HOW YOU
CHARGE AND DISCHARGE AT BATTERY
THE SOMETHING WE'RE LEARNING
ABOUT AS AN EXAMPLE IF IT'S A
TWO HUNDRED MEGAWATT BATTERY
IT CAN CHARGE TWO HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS IT CAN DISCHARGED TO
AN AMERICAN WHAT'S IN IT CAN
TURN ON A DIME WHICH IS A FOUR
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS SWING WHEN
YOU HAVE TEN THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
OF STORAGE ON THE SYSTEM YOU
HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
THAT SWING SO WE'RE LEARNING
ON HOW TO INTEGRATE THOSE
THINGS IN OUR MARKET SO WE ARE
-- ADAPTING TO THIS NEW -- TO
THIS NEW REALITY ALSO NOTE THAT
WE'VE HAD A COUPLE OF TIMES
WERE RESEARCH OVER SEVENTY
PERCENT OF THE LOAD -- WITH
RENEWABLES SO I THINK THE STATE
IS MAKING VERY GOOD PROGRESS
YOU KNOW I I MEAN I COULDN'T
AGREE MORE I THINK WE HAVE A
VERY AGGRESSIVE GOALS AND I
THINK THAT THE FOUR OF YOU --
YEAH SURE OUR SENSE OF URGENCY
AND OUR DESIRE TO REALLY MOVE
IN THIS DIRECTION I THINK MY
CONCERN ISN'T ISN'T EVEN THAT
THE LEADERSHIP FOR THE THREE OF
YOU AS YOU MOVE FORWARD REALLY
-- YOUR NEXT LEVEL DOWN AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN REALLY
MOVE YOUR INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES
I MEAN JUST FOR EXAMPLE THE
TYPE OF THE PRODUCT THAT I
MEAN DEMAND RESPONSE WE HAVE
SO MUCH TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
IN THE ENERGY AREA JUST IN THE
STATE ALONE DEMAND RESPONSE
IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THAT --
BUT IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE WE
ARE ADEQUATELY EMBRACING --
THAT WE NEED I THINK THAT IS I
THINK WHERE WE'RE FEELING THE
CONCERN BECAUSE YOU YOU HEARD
IT FROM THE GOVERNOR I KNOW
YOU HEARD IT DIRECTLY FROM THE
GOVERNOR YOU HEARD IT FROM US
BUT WE WE HEARD IT WE REALLY
HEARD FROM MY CONSTITUENTS
AND -- THIS TYPE OF -- ENERGY
SHORTFALL IS JUST SORT OF
INEXCUSABLE ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THAT WE ON A REGULAR BASIS OVER
PROCURE ABOUT MY UNDERSTAND
ABOUT FIFTEEN PERCENT OF THE
ENERGY THAT WE NEED WHICH IS
YOU KNOW WHICH INCREASES RATES
WHICH INCREASES COSTS SO IT
SEEMS ODD THAT AT THE TIME THAT
EVEN THOUGH WE REGULARLY OVER
FOR SURE ABOUT FIFTEEN PERCENT
OF THE ENERGY THAT WE NEED
THAT WE STILL WERE NOT ABLE TO
MEET OUR ENERGY NEEDS ON THE
FOURTEENTH AND FIFTEENTH OF
AUGUST SUGGEST I THINK GOING
BACK TO MY QUESTION WHY DIDN'T
HEAR IS I HEARD SORT OF HIGH
LEVEL HEY WE'RE WE'RE DOING
BETTER BUT I'D LIKE TO KNOW
SPECIFIC MORE MORE SPECIFICALLY
WHAT YOUR AGENCIES ARE DOING
TO SPEED UP THE ABILITY TO GET
RENEWABLE ENERGY ONLINE AND
ALSO TO MAKE IT MORE RELIABLE
SO WE TALKED ABOUT I THINK SURE
HOPE SHE'LL TALK ABOUT ENERGY
STORAGE IS BEING OBVIOUSLY
ONLY ONE OF MANY THINGS YOU
HAVE BATTERY STORAGE YOU HAVE
ELECTRIC CARS YOU HAVE YOU
HAVE FOR DEMAND RESPONSE ALL
THESE ARE VERY STRATEGIES
BUT WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE DOING ON
HOW TO INTEGRATE EACH OF THESE
STRATEGIES MORE QUICKLY BECAUSE
JUST FROM OUR I'LL JUST TELL
YOU FROM OUR VANTAGE POINT
IT SEEMS TO MOVE AT A FAIRLY
GLACIAL THANKS ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE SPEED OF OUR STATE AND
HOW FAST THINGS ARE CHANGING
I CAN SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
NEAR TERM THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING AS I SAID WE WE ARE
HAVING AN EXPEDITED RULEMAKING
PROCESS THAT WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE OUTLINED
TODAY -- WE DO NEED TO LOOK
AT DEMAND RESPONSE AND AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE BRINGING
TECHNOLOGIES TO IT AS WELL AS
ON FLEX ALERT FRANKLY OF FIVE
FLEX ALERT IS ANOTHER -- LOVERS
THAT WE PULLED SUCCESSFULLY
DURING THE FOURTEENTH AND THE
FIFTEENTH AND AGAIN IN EARLY
SEPTEMBER HEAT WAVE -- AND WE
WE HAVE ALL AGREED ON THAT FLEX
ALERT NEEDS TO BE MODERNIZED
PEOPLE BE ABLE WE NEED TO HAVE
AN APP TYPE OF PROCESS WHERE
CUSTOMERS CAN -- BE ENGAGED
IN THE FLEX IN A MUCH MORE
TECHNOLOGICAL MANNER THAT WE
ARE NOW DOING IT HASN'T REALLY
BEEN LOOKED AT FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS SO WE HAVE TO DO THAT --
IMMEDIATELY SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT IN THE SHORT TERM THE IN
-- THE THE THINGS THAT WILL BE
BOTTOM LINE -- HAVE BEEN TALKED
ABOUT BUT I CAN GIVE YOU SOME
NUMBERS THE ENERGY STORAGE WE
WILL HAVE ONE THOUSAND FOUR
SIXTY ONE MEGAWATTS BROUGHT
ON BY NEXT SUMMER IN ENERGY
STORAGE AND SOLAR PLUS STORAGE
WILL HAVE SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX MEGAWATTS ON BOARD ONLINE
SKEWS ME SELLER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY EIGHT MEGAWATTS WIN
A HUNDRED ELEVEN AND OTHER
WHICH IS MOSTLY GEOTHERMAL
BE ABOUT TWELVE MEGAWATTS FOR
ALMOST TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS THAT WILL BE ONLINE
BY EIGHT ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND THAT'S IN THE IN THE
SHORT TERM -- AREA THAT WE
WILL BE BRINGING ON I THINK
MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE
SOME OTHER POINTS TO MAKE
YEAH I GUESS I COULD JUST ADD
TO THAT MEAN ONE SECTOR AS
WELL AS IMPLEMENTING IS THE
BUILDING SECTOR SO THROUGH
OUR CODES AND STANDARDS FOR
NEW CONSTRUCTION WE'RE HELPING
ENSURE THAT THE BUILDINGS CAN
BE INTELLIGENT AS THEY INTERACT
LOAD MANAGEMENT STANDARDS WHICH
IS BASICALLY PLATFORM IT'S
GONNA REQUIRE THE UTILITIES
TO -- TO BE ABLE TO INTEGRATE
-- THESE ARE TECHNOLOGIES
THAT THESE FEATURES THAT ARE
GOING TO ALLOW A FOR -- SMART
TECHNOLOGY TO HELP ADJUST AND
MODULATE DEMANDED REAL TIME
-- I WANTED TO JUST RESPOND
TO ONE HIGHER LEVEL THEME
THAT I'M HEARING AND SOME OF
THE COMMENTS TODAY WHICH IS
THE NOTION THAT SOMEHOW THE
CARBONIZATION IS NOT COMPATIBLE
WITH RELIABILITY ONE INTERESTED
REALLY ADDRESS THAT DIRECTLY
BECAUSE IF YOU ASK THE QUESTION
WHAT ARE THE TOP THREATS TO
GRID RELIABILITY THE CITY
CALIFORNIA LAST TWENTY YEARS
RIGHT AND LOOK AT HOW THAT
STACKS UP AGAINST CLEAN ENERGY
RIGHT SO YOU HAVE THE ENERGY
CRISIS THE TWO THOUSAND ONE
WHICH WAS MARKET MANIPULATION
CAUSED BY COMPANIES LIKE ENRON
IF THIRTY EIGHT STATES THREE
EMERGENCIES IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
AGAIN CLEARLY PERFORM RELIABLY
THAT -- SONGS GOING DOWN SANOFI
PLAYSTATION TWENTY TWELVE OF
RENEWABLES CONTINUE TO POOR
PERFORMER LIVELY DURING THAT
THE METCALF SUBSTATION ATTACK
THE TERRORIST ATTACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN SILICON VALLEY AGAIN
RENEWABLES PERFORMER LIVELY
AND LISA CANYON TWENTY FIFTEEN
-- SAME THING AND OF COURSE
THE PS PS EVENTS THAT WE'VE
HAD SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
THROUGHOUT ALL THESE RENEWABLES
HAVE CONTINUED TO PERFORM
RELIABLY AND YOU KNOW LOOKING
AT THE SUITE OF TECHNOLOGY
I'VE BEEN REALLY FORTUNATE
JOB I INNER INTERFACE ALL THE
TIME WITH INNOVATORS AROUND
THE STATE LOOKING AT THE SUITE
OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT'S COMING
-- IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS IS
ACTUALLY REALLY INSPIRING THERE
ARE A LOT OF SOLUTIONS -- SOME
OF WHICH ARE HERE RIGHT NOW
ONE THING THAT WE FUNDED --
WAS ONLY CONNECT THE COMPANY
FUNDED -- WITH MONEY COLLECTED
BY THE PC THE GIVEN OUT TO
RAPID PROGRAM THEY SAVE YOU
KNOW GIGAWATT HOUR OF POWER
THEY HAVE A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND -- YOU KNOW CUSTOMERS
AROUND THE STATE PEOPLE TURN
OFF JUST THESE THESE WHEN YOU
HAVE A BLACK OFTEN IT'S JUST
VERY VERY FINITE AMOUNT OF
TIME WITH THE GREATEST SUPER
STRESSED SO ALL OF THOSE
THOUSAND POINTS OF LIGHT --
RATHER THOUSAND PUTS PEOPLE
TURN OUT THE LIGHTS -- CAN
HELP AND DOES HELP AND WE'RE
GETTING A LOT SMARTER ABOUT
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I THINK THE
OLD VISION THE OLD PHILOSOPHY
WAS DEMAND IS THE STATIC BEING
THAT'S UNCHANGED INTERCEPTED ME
GENERATION THAT PROVIDER IS TO
MEET THAT DEMAND AND AND REALLY
WHAT WE'RE FINDING THERE'S
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT DEMAND
THAT CAN BE MOVED IF YOU'RE
AND THAT INCLUDES PRE COOLEY
OF BUILDINGS AND CHARGING OF
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUS FLEETS
AND ALL THIS STUFF SO I THINK
WE THIS IS A SOLVABLE PROBLEM
WE HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
TOOLS UNDER DEVELOPMENT
TO HELP US GET THERE
HELLO COMPLETED IT'S CLEAR THAT
ACTUALLY DECARBONISATION IN
THE NEW ENERGY -- CONTINUE TO
WORK THAT THAT WAS COMPLETELY
RELIABLE THERE THERE WERE NO
-- YOU KNOW WE PREDICTED HOW
MUCH THEY WOULD GENERATE HOW
MUCH ENERGY WOULD GENERATE THE
ENERGY WAS GENERATED -- I THINK
THE KEY THAT YOU HIGHLIGHT IT
IS WE NEED TO BETTER MANAGE
THE DEMAND SIDE THAT'S WHY I
THINK DEMAND RESPONSES SO IS
SO CRITICAL I DO I DO THINK
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT THAT WE
BETTER -- BETTER LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN MAKE THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
SIDE MUCH MORE RELIABLE WELL
I THINK THERE ARE DIFFERENT
TOOLS THAT WE COULD USE TO
MAKE A MORE RELIABLE AND I
DON'T THINK WE'VE EVEN BEGUN
TO REALLY -- UTILIZE THOSE
TOOLS YOU YOU MENTIONED --
-- CONNECTORS ONE PARTICULAR
-- DEMAND RESPONSE STRATEGY
I THINK I THINK YOU HAVE A
COMPANY WHICH IS INCENTIVIZING
CUSTOMERS NOT TELLING CUSTOMERS
BUT THERE IS INVITING CUSTOMERS
TO USE LESS ENERGY SO CUSTOMERS
HAVE THAT CHOICE AND IT WORKS
THEN THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY
THAT THE STATE IS EQUIVALENT
TO OUR FIVE FORGOT HOW MANY
POWER PLANTS SO AGAIN THIS
IS A GROUP OF THE SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND HOMES THANK YOU
TURN OFF I THINK IT'S I THINK
IT'S A REALLY POOR TO PUT THAT
IN CONTEXT AND THAT THAT'S A
SOFTWARE THAT CAN BE DEPLOYED
VERY VERY QUICKLY AND AGAIN
IT'S AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO
PEOPLE SIGN ON VOLUNTARILY I
THINK AGAIN AGAIN I THINK IT'S
JUST IMPERATIVE THAT WE SPEED
UP OUR SYSTEMS TO BE ABLE TO
APPROVED THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
QUICKER TO BE ABLE TO INTEGRATE
THEM INTO OUR SYSTEMS QUICKER
-- I THINK THAT WE STILL TAKE
I KNOW IT'S IT'S A IT'S AN
ONGOING PROCESS BUT I THINK WE
STILL TAKE WAY TOO LONG TO MOVE
INTO -- INSURING THAT WE HAVE
-- YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE PROVING
ALL DISCOVER NEW BLENDER G.
AS WELL AS A NEW TECHNOLOGY
BUT WITHOUT FAITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING THERE
MR IF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU ALL OF YOUR FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS BUT JUST IT ALONG
THE LINES OF STORAGE I DID WANT
TO ASK A QUESTION AND FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO BEGIN BY ALIGNING
MY COMMENTS WITH THE DOCTOR
QUIRK I THINK THAT HIS THE
HIS COMMENTS ALWAYS EXPRESSED
EXACTLY HOW WE'RE FEELING WE'RE
JUST WE FEEL THAT THERE ISN'T
A SENSE OF URGENCY AS THERE
SHOULD BE AND THIS ISN'T THE
FIRST TIME WE'VE SENATE WHICH
SAID THIS A NUMBER OF TIMES
WE'VE HAD NUMBER OF HEARINGS
WHAT WE KEEP SAYING THE SAME
THING THE -- MISTER TEAM TALKED
ABOUT IT AS WELL DR EGGMAN JUST
TALKED ABOUT IT WE HAVE TO HAVE
A SENSE OF URGENCY OTHERWISE WE
WILL HAVE A HEARING NEXT YEAR
WILL BE SAYING THE SAME THING
AND WE WILL HEAR THAT WE'RE
MOVING ALONG WE'RE MOVING ALONG
COUNTESS ANISE PARTNERS WE
WANT TO SEE YOU SUCCEED BECAUSE
WHEN YOU SUCCEED THEN THE REST
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE GOING
TO BE SERVED PROPERLY NOW ON
THE ISSUE OF STORAGE I THE
FORMER CHAIRMAN JOHN WILLING
HOME WROTE THE CALIFORNIA
HAS MORE THAN FIFTY I'M SORRY
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY MEGAWATTS
OF BEHIND THE METER BATTERY
CAPACITY THE COULD HAVE BEEN
CALLED UPON TO REDUCE LOADED
BUT ONLY ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
TEN MEGAWATTS WERE USED THE
NEW YORK TIMES WROTE ABOUT THIS
AS WELL WROTE WE WERE ALREADY
ABLE TO REDUCE THE SEVERITY OF
BLACKOUTS AND MY FIRST QUESTION
IS WHY WASN'T THIS FULL BETTER
BATTERY CAPACITY UTILIZED
-- STEVE DO YOU WANNA TRY AND
WELL THE BEST I CAN ANSWER
THAT IS -- THE BATTERIES --
DO PRESENT THEMSELVES IN OUR
MARKET AND EVERYTHING THAT WAS
OFFERED AND WAS DISPATCHABLE
WAS USED -- SO OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S SOMETHING STILL OUT
THERE THAT'S NOT BEING OFFERED
INTO THE MARKET AND WE WILL
TAKE THAT IS -- SOMETHING
TO LOOK INTO BUT YOU'RE NOT
HEARING THIS FOR THE FIRST TIME
I MEAN YOU ARE AWARE THAT THIS
CRITICISM HAD BEEN LEVELLED
WELL I MEAN THIS IS YOU KNOW
THIS WHOLE INCIDENT HAS BEEN
VIEWED FROM ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT LENSES -- I WILL SAY
THIS THAT I DO THINK CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE THE MOST INNOVATIVE
-- STATE THE -- THAT THERE IS
AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO UNLOCK
ALL THESE RESOURCES AND WE
WILL ALL HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER
TO DO THAT I CAN TELL YOU THE
I SO DOES NOT DO PROCUREMENT
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT WE OPERATE THE GRID AND
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE GIVEN
TO US WE TRY TO OPTIMIZE AMONG
OPERATE THEM AS BEST WE CAN WE
DO HAVE STORAGE INDOOR MARKETS
-- MOST OF THE STORAGE I
BELIEVE THAT THE MISTER WHELAN
OFFICE REFERRING TO IS BEHIND
THE METER -- THERE AT HOMES
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
DIRECTLY IT HAS TO COME THROUGH
AN INTERMEDIARY OF SOME SIDE OF
SOME TIED WHICH GENERALLY MEANS
THERE HAS TO BE A PROCUREMENT
PROGRAM TO GO PROCURE IT TO BE
ABLE TO OFFER INTO OUR MARKET
SO -- WE WILL I KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT -- BADGERING HER
TEAM ARE -- URGENTLY LOOKING
AT ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENTS AND
THAT INDEED COULD BE PART OF
IT AND IF I MIGHT -- YOU ALIGN
YOURSELF WITH DOCTOR KORB WHO
ARE KNOWN FOR MANY YEARS AND
-- YOU KNOW I RESPECT HIS HIS
INSIGHTS ON THESE THINGS I
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT STORAGE
IS GOING TO BE A CRITICAL
ELEMENTS OF THE SOLUTION IT
IS NOT THE SILVERBOLT FOR
EVERYTHING THOUGH BECAUSE IT
ITSELF DOESN'T GENERATE ANY
POWER AND FURTHERMORE YOU HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL HOW YOU USE IT
OTHERWISE YOU'RE JUST CHARGING
IT WITH NON YEAH WITH GHG
EMITTING RESOURCES SO THAT HAS
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION BUT
IN THE STORE JUST GOING TO HAVE
TO BE ACROSS ALTERATIONS IS
DOCTOR COURT DISORDERLY ON --
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS WORK
FOR OUR LITHIUM ION BATTERIES
WILL NOT SOLVE THIS LONG TERM
MEMBER I CAN -- TRYING TO
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION AS WELL
-- ARE YOU I I AGREE -- WITH
WHAT STEVE JUST SAID HOWEVER
AS AS -- THE CHAIRMAN HARSH
SHIELD SAID THERE GOT TO BE
ON MANY THINGS IN OUR TOOLBOX
AND WE HAVE TO UTILIZE ALL OF
THEM AND WE WE DO HAVE A SENSE
OF URGENCY WE HAVE TOLD -- THE
GOVERNOR AND TODAY EXPRESSING
OURSELVES TO YOU ALL WE CANNOT
HAVE A SITUATION AGAIN FACED
US IN AUGUST AND FACES IN
SEPTEMBER THANKFULLY WE DID NOT
HAVE TO HAVE ANY BLACKOUTS IN
SEPTEMBER I'M IN TERMS OF THE
PROCUREMENT I'M GOING TO TURN
TO PETE SCALA WHO IN A FROM THE
UC TO ADDRESS -- MORE DEEPLY
YOUR CONCERNS MEMBERS PETER
YOU UP THERE YES I AM SO I I
DID WANT TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
MORE TO THIS QUESTION OF HOW
THE METER STORAGE OR BEHIND THE
METER HYBRID SOLAR AND STORAGE
PARTICIPATING IN THE MARKET
AND AND -- THERE WAS A QUESTION
IN THE WHITE PAPER -- THIS
MORNING ABOUT -- WORKSHOP IT
WAS CANCELED SEVERAL TIMES THAT
WHICH PERHAPS DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT WAS A SENSE OF URGENCY --
THAT WORKSHOP SO SO -- IN THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROCEEDING
-- -- MOST RECENT DECISION
TEED UP AND DIRECTED THE SAME
THREE AGENCIES TO HOLD A JOINT
WORKSHOP TO EXPLORE WHAT THE
BARRIERS OPPORTUNITIES AND
BARRIERS ARE FOR THAT RESOURCE
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE THE SAME
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS SAID
PRINCIPALS WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
RESPONDING TO AN DEVELOPING THE
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS -- WE'RE
THE ONES TO BE ORGANIZING AND
PRESENTING IN THOSE WORKSHOPS
SO SO FIRST IT WAS CANCELED
DISTINCT GIVE US TIME TO START
DEVELOPING THIS REPORT AND
THEN UNFORTUNATELY THE SECOND
WORKSHOP DATE WAS SCHEDULED
FOR THE DAY OF THE RELEASE OF
THE ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS SO WE
ARE ACTIVELY WORKING ON SETTING
UP FINDING A TIME THAT WORKS
FOR ALL OF THE PRINCIPALS
WHO HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST
IN BEING INVOLVED IN HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION -- IN THAT
WORKSHOP SO I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT WE HEAR YOU AND WE DO
INDEED INTEND TO SET SOMETHING
UP IN THE IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE THAT THOSE RESOURCES
CAN CURRENTLY PARTICIPATE IN AS
DEMAND RESPONSE SO -- YOU KNOW
THEY THEY CAN -- REDUCE LOADING
THE CREDIT FOR REDUCING LOAD UP
TO THE AMOUNT OF THE PROPERTY
THE METER THEY'RE LOCATED AT
THE QUESTION IS HOW TO GO ABOUT
ALLOWING THEM TO TO PRODUCE
AND AND EXPORT MORE THAN THAT
-- THEIR SITE LOAD AND GET
CREDIT FOR THAT PARTICULARLY
DURING HIGH DEMAND THIS
THANK YOU
ANOTHER QUESTION IS THAT
IN RESPONSE TO THE ISSUES
THAT OCCURRED CAL AYE
SO SO THEY WILL PURSUE
MARKET ROOM ENHANCEMENTS
THROUGH ITS STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS COULD YOU DESCRIBE
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
BUT THIS IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE AND PLEASE TELL US
WHO THE STAKEHOLDERS ARE
SURE -- I'LL TAKE THAT THE
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS SO
WE HAVE A A TERRIFIED THAT WE
FILE WITH THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION THAT
-- HAS -- OVERSIGHT OF US AND
THE STAKEHOLDERS WHEN WE HAVE
A STAKEHOLDER SO IT IS TO
LOOK AT DIFFERENT PRACTICES
THAT WILL BE IN THAT TERROR
IN THIS CASE WE'RE GONNA
BE LOOKING AT SCHEDULING
PRACTICES AS AN EXAMPLE THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE WILL HAVE
AN OPEN STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
ANYONE CAN PARTICIPATE IN THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS GENERALLY
WHO DOES PARTICIPATE OR LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES THE PEOPLE --
CCA'S -- THE UTILITIES -- ALSO
POWER GENERATORS -- DEVELOPERS
ALL ALL WALKS CAN COME INTO
OUR STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WHAT
WE WILL DO IS WE WILL PRESENT
SO THAT WE WANT TO LOOK AT
THIS AND THEN WE WILL BEGIN
TO HAVE A SERIES OF MEETINGS
TO SEE AS AN EXAMPLE HOW WOULD
LIKE TO CHANGE THE -- THE
PROCESS FOR SCHEDULING AS AN
EXAMPLE LET'S SAY WE APPLY A
PENALTY TO THAT NOW THAT HAS
TO GET FILE THAT FOR AND FOR
CAST TO APPROVE THAT THAT'S
IN SUMMARY THAT'S HOW THAT
WORKS BUT IT IT INCLUDES IT'S
AN OPEN TRANSPARENT PROCESS
THANK YOU FOR THAT I APPRECIATE
THAT AND ONE LAST QUESTION
I HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
BUT I'LL JUST ASK ONE MORE
QUESTION BUT MANY MY COLLEAGUES
SEVENTY QUESTIONS -- WE ARE
HEARING FOR MANY OF OF WORK OUR
PEOPLE FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
IN OUR RESPECTIVE AREAS AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT IT
TAKES THREE TO SIX MONTHS FOR
THEIR SOLAR PANEL AND BATTERY
SYSTEMS TO GET APPROVED TO
TURN ON THEIR SYSTEMS THESE
SYSTEMS REDUCE LOAD ON THE
GRID TO PROVIDE RESILIENCE TO
PEOPLE'S HOMES WHAT CAN YOU DO
TO CUT DOWN THIS WAITING PERIOD
AND ACCELERATE DEPLOYMENT
CAN THINK THAT'S FOR ME -- I
THINK YOU'RE GOOD ADDRESSING
THE INTERCONNECTION -- --
DIFFICULTIES YEAH AT THE
DISTRIBUTION LEVEL I THINK
-- AND -- THAT HAS BEEN A
DIFFICULTY IN AND I -- WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO SOLVE --
THAT THE INTERCONNECTIONS
ARE SPED UP AGAIN I WANT TO
TURN TO PETE IF YOU HAVE SOME
SPECIFICS IN ANY OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS TO TO WORK THE
INTERCONNECTION -- TIME FRAMES
SO UNFORTUNATELY I THAT IS
NOT MY SIDE OF THE SHOP AND
ENERGY DIVISION SO I THINK WE
CAN PROVIDE INFORMATION BUT
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ON HIM
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED TO MY OFF ABSOLUTELY
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU I LOOK
FORWARD TO RECEIVING ONE
OF MY FELLOW COMMISSIONERS
ON HAVE HAS THAT PROCEEDING
AND I WILL GET THE SPECIFICS
GARCIA
THANK YOUNG AND ACTUALLY START
OFF WITH A COMMON LEAST WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT A ONE AND
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OCCURRENCE
WITH THIS HEAT WAVE IT'S
ABOUT OCTOBER STARTING ANOTHER
HEAT WAVE TODAY -- WE MAKE
THESE STATEMENTS ARE ONE IN
THIRTY FIVE YEARS BASED ON
PACIFISTIC BUT I FIND THAT TO
BE A RELIABLE GIVEN THAT EVERY
YEAR WE'RE MAKING NEW RECORDS
BREAKING NEW RECORDS OUT THERE
AND SO ARE WE PLANNING BEYOND
THIS ONE IN A THIRTY FIVE YEAR
-- MODEL AND HUNTING FOR A LOT
OF THE UNKNOWN OUT THERE THE
REALITY IS THAT IT'S HARD TO
PROJECT AS ITS NEW EVERY YEAR
AND SO OKAY YEAH START WITH
THAT ON THE FIRST QUESTION
RIGHT I'LL I'LL START UP AND
THEN I'LL TURN TO EARN CHAIR
HARSH SHIELD WE IN IN MY
REMARKS IN OURS THIS MORNING
WE REALIZE THAT -- SOME OF
THESE OCCURRENCES OF HEAT
WAVES AS I SAID YEAH AND THE
IT'S ABSOLUTELY SCREAMING THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS UPON US AND
OUR PLANNING PROCESSES AND ARE
FORECASTING PROCESSES MUST NEED
THAT AND -- SO WE ARE INDEED
LOOKING AT AT CHANGING AND THE
NEXT SO THAT WE HAVE A PLANNING
PROCESS THAT MEETS SOME OF
THESE OCCURRENCES AND WE HAVE
TO DO IT IN AN AFFORDABLE AND
A NUMBER RELIABLE MANNER IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE HOW WE ON
SCHEDULE HOW WE PROCURE -- --
FOR THESE INSTANCES THAT ARE
COMING ON ON TO US ALL THAT
MUCH MORE QUICKLY YEAH IF I
COULD ACTUALLY JUST AS SPECIFIC
GOING TO WHO PERFORMS THAT
DEMAND FORECASTS ARE TALKING
ABOUT TO SPEAK TO THIS SERVER
MORNING CHAT HOLDEN -- BY SHARE
AND CAN YOU SPEAK UP SEVENTH A
HARD TO HEAR YEAH M.
GOOD MORNING -- BUDGET HOLDEN
FIVE I SURE PATTERSON AND THE
REST OF THE MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION -- I'M SEVEN
DAVID THE ENERGY COMMISSION
SO OUR TEAM OF ABOUT THIRTY
STAFF MEMBERS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DEVELOPING THE FORECAST
A SET OF FORECASTS THAT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION ADOPTS SO
AS A PART OF THE FORECASTING
PROCESS -- WE AT DUBLIN A
NEW COMPLETELY -- REVISED
FORECAST AB TWO YEARS AS A
WE TAKE NEW ASSUMPTIONS SO
WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ECONOMIC
AND DEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS THAT
ARE CHANGING FROM REPUTABLE
SOURCES -- SUCH AS A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- WHICH EXCLUDES
RANCH -- WEATHER DATA AND SO
ON AND WE DOUBLED EVERY TWO
YEARS AND IN THE INTERVENING
YEARS WE DO AN UPDATE THAT
BECAUSE -- THERE'S A LOT OF
CHANGES ON THE DEMAND SIDE
WITH MORE AND MORE PT GROWING
MORE MORE ACTIVE VEHICLES
GOING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY BEEN
DOING A NEW FORECAST EVERY
YEAR SO JUST GONNA MAKE SURE
WE SET UP THE PROCESS -- YES
EARLIER -- PRESIDENT DODGER
SPOKE WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DEVELOPING A SET OF FORECAST
AND THAT FLEW IN TO HAVE AN
IDEA OF PLANNING PROCESS SIX
SO WHAT WE DO CURRENTLY THOUGH
THAT IS NOT JUST ONE FORECAST
-- WE DOUBLE UP AND BOTH A ONE
INTO FORECAST A ONE IN FIVE ONE
IN TEN AND A ONE IN TWENTY SO
WE WE PUT THOSE FORECAST OUT
FOR AT VEGAS PLANNING PROCESS
SEES AND SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROCESS AT
CPAC -- WE USE THE ONE INTO
FORECAST SO THE FORECAST
AVAILABLE IT'S ABOUT HOW WE
USE THEM AND WE HAD WE WANT
TO USE THEM SO SPECIFICALLY IN
TERMS OF WHETHER WE'RE TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT AS SOME OF THE --
CHANGING COMPETITORS TO H.
AS THE WEATHER YES WE DO THAT
-- SIR SO THERE'S TWO PARTS
OF FORECASTING ONE IS THE LONG
TERM WHICH IS THE TEN YEAR
WHERE WE ACTUALLY -- DOUBLE
THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY THAT'S
USED EACH YEAR SO THAT'S A
LONG TERM PROCESS AND THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY GOING INTO -- THE
TRANSMISSION PLANNING PROCESS
AND WE ALSO DOUBLE UP IN EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE SO BASICALLY
AN HOURLY FORECAST OVER THE TEN
YEARS WHICH GOES INTO THE I.
R. P. PROCESS ANDERSON AT
THE SPECIFICALLY WHEN WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY IS CALLED THE
THEATER HAD PEAK FORECAST SO
THAT THAT PARTICULAR ONE WE DO
CONSIDER -- THE DECENT WEATHER
WE DO WE DO CAN CONSIDER
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF FORECAST
THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE
THANK YOU I MEAN AND I'LL BE
A LITTLE CRITICAL WE HAVE THE
SYSTEMS BUT THEY STILL BUILD US
UP FOR TWO DAYS IN A ROW AND SO
I HOPE THAT THAT WE TAKE THIS
AS A LEARNING LESSON THAT YOU
KNOW WELL I I KNOW IT'S HARD
TO PREDICT HOW THE SEND MAIL
TO THAT WAS HARD TO PREDICT THE
PANDEMIC THIS CALL THE OTHER
ONE AROUND THE CORNER SO WE
HAVE TO BE AT THINK -- MICHAEL
OF THAT -- MY NEXT COMMENT
IN QUESTION IS AROUND EQUITY
SPECIFICALLY -- MY COLLEAGUE
WITH EMPHASIS WILL STEP OUT OF
THE ROOM BUT HE TALKED ABOUT
ASKING CONSUMERS TO USE LESS
THAN ON THE MEN'S SIDE AND I
FIND THAT REALLY PROBLEMATIC
IN THE DISTRICT WHERE I KNOW
MY CONSUMERS ARE ALREADY USING
A LOT LESS ON A REGULAR BASIS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
USE MORE THAN WE DO NOT HAVE
AIR CONDITIONING -- OUT THERE
AND SO I FIND I FIND THAT TO
BE A LITTLE PROBLEMATIC WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- ABOUT
EQUITY OUT THERE WHO'S WEARING
THE BROWN AT THE END OF THE DAY
THESE COMMUNITIES I WOULD WE
HAVE THE CITY THIS MOMENTS OUT
THERE WHERE IF I DON'T HAVE A
WORKING REFRIGERATOR DEFINITELY
LAS IMPACTS ME THAT MUCH MORE
IT IS SO MUCH HARDER FOR ME TO
REPLACE IT OUT THERE AND SO I
JUST WANTED TO BE MINDFUL AND
LYFT DO WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
USE LEFT AND THERE'S A LOT
OF FOLKS WE COULD DEFINITELY
USE LESS I THINK WE NEED TO
BE REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT THE
STATEMENT ON WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EQUITY OUT THERE IN THIS
THING I THINK THEY'RE THINKING
OR TALKING ABOUT INVESTING
IN WHETHER IT'S HYDRO STORAGE
OR BIOMASS WHO'S GOING TO BE
PAYING FOR THAT WE HAVE TO
I'LL USE THAT HAVE LISTEN THIS
CUSTOMERS AND BUT WE STILL HAVE
HAD SYSTEMS WILL RELY ON THEM
FOR THESE BIG INVESTMENTS ON
AND SO HOW ARE WE CREATING A
SYSTEM THAT'S MORE EQUITABLE
ALL ALONG THE WAY I LIVE IN A
DISTRICT WHERE MOST OF MY BOOKS
ARE PLUGGED INTO THE I.
O. USE AND NOT THAT ALL THESE
OTHER ALTERNATIVES AND WE
END UP WEARING THE BRIGHT THE
BRIGHT WHEN THE COSTS ARE FAR
ENOUGH OUT THERE BOARD SOME
OF THE LEAST BENEFICIARY FOLKS
OUT THERE -- AND SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE BEING
MINDFUL AND EQUITABLE THAT
DISCUSSIONS MIGHT DECISIONS
AS YOU GUYS ARE PLANNING I
HAD TO THIS IS A COMMENT MY
LAST QUESTION THOUGH IS ABOUT
THE FIFTEEN PERCENT THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE HAVING FOR
OUR SERVICE WE USUALLY HAVE
A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN THAT
ACTUALLY CLOSER TO TEN PERCENT
I IT WE WOULD HAVE TO FIFTEEN
PERCENT WE HAVE AVERTED --
THE STUDENTS TO THESE TWO DAYS
WELL WE DID HAVE -- FIFTEEN
PERCENT -- RESERVE BUT STEVE
DO YOU WANNA DIRECTLY AFFECTED
SO THE FORECAST ON THOSE DATES
ON THEIR TUITION WAS FORTY
FORTY FIVE GIGAWATTS ACTUAL
LOAD WAS FORTY SEVEN SO IF
YOU HAVE THE FULL FIFTEEN
PERCENT WE WE WOULD HAVE IN
THERE WERE SOME OBVIOUSLY
SOME EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES
BUT I IF I COULD -- WITH YOUR
PERMISSION JUST -- RESPOND TO
WHEN YOUR EARLIER POINTS WAS UP
HERE RIGHT WELL I JUST WANTED
TO DIRECTLY ADDRESS BECAUSE
EQUITY IS THE FRONT DOOR TO
OUR STATE'S CLIMATE POLICY
AND EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING I
MENTIONED A NUMBER OF THESE
ENERGY STORAGE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS SIXTY FIVE PERCENT OF
OUR DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS FOR
THESE NEW CLEAN TECHNOLOGIES
IS ARE IN DISADVANTAGED LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES EVERY SINGLE
PROGRAM WE'RE DOING IN THIS NEW
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM -- THAT
WAS -- HAD CENTER STERN LET ME
KNOW THAT'S EXCLUSIVE GROUP FOR
LOW INCOME THIS IS BEEN A BIG
FOCUS FOR ALL OF US -- AND I
DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE I THINK
THAT'S A NEW DEVELOPMENT THE
LAST FEW YEARS ARE VERY WELCOME
ONE I THINK IT'S A MODEL FOR
THE FOR THE COUNTRY AND THEN
JUST TO THE THE FIRST BORN YOU
MAKING ABOUT YOU KNOW THE WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW WE DO
THE FORECAST IN AND THIS THIS
WHOLE PLANNING US IT'S REALLY
BALANCING RELIABILITY WITH THE
RATES SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A
ONE TO ONE INTO PLANNING RIGHT
THAT'S THERE'S A FIFTY PERCENT
CHANCE THAT THE ACTUAL DEMAND
IS GOING TO BE A OF -- WITH
THE FORECAST IF YOU GO TO ONE
IN FIVE IT'S A TWENTY PERCENT
CHANCE IT'LL BE ABOUT ONE IN
TEN OF THE TEN PERCENT IS YOU
GET MORE AND MORE SAFETY MARGIN
THAT ALSO ADDS MORE COST AND
SO THE GOAL I THINK FOR ALL OF
US COLLECTIVELY IS TO PROCURE
ENOUGH SO WE CAN HAVE A HUNDRED
PERCENT CONFIDENCE IN THE
RELIABILITY OF THE GRID BUT NOT
MORE THAN THAT SO WE CONTAIN
COSTS AND THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE DOWNSIZING ACTOR I THINK
YOU KNOW WE WE CAN WE HAVE TO
YOU BETTER THAN I MEAN YOUR
POINT AND ALL OF YOUR POINT
IS WELL TAKEN -- AND NOBODY
REALLY PAYS ANY ATTENTION
TO THE STUFF UNTIL WE HAVE A
FAILURE LIKE WE DID IN AUGUST
FIRST TIME IN TWENTY YEARS AND
AND WE HAVE WE GOT TO DO BETTER
SO I I JUST POINT OF WHICH
ARE HERE YOU AND AND THANK YOU
FOR MAKING THAT OBSERVATION
YEAH I ALSO IT IF I MIGHT
ABOUT THE FIFTY PERCENT PLAYING
RESERVE -- -- -- ONE MAKE
SURE BODIES ON THE SAME PAGE
SO THERE IS A FIFTEEN PERCENT
PLANNING RESERVE MARGIN BUT
WERE REQUIRED TO KEEP SIX
PERCENT RESERVES SO YOU CAN
DEDUCT THAT YOU GET TO NINE
THEN YOU HAVE OUTAGES ON THE
SYSTEM -- WHICH IS ANOTHER
FEW PERCENTAGE POINTS SO WHEN
YOU HAVE A DEVIATION OFF OF
THE FORECAST THE LONGER TERM
FORECAST USING A ONE INTO YOUR
YOU'RE GONNA YOU'RE RUNNING WAY
TOO CLOSE TO THE MARGIN SO --
I THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE INCREASE THE MARGINS THAT
WE HAVE I CAN GIVE YOU ANOTHER
EXAMPLE I MEAN WE KNOW THE WIND
WILL MOVE A THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
IN AN HOUR UP AND DOWN THAT'S
THE PHYSICS OF IT WE NEED TO
KNOW THAT THAT'S HOW IT'S GONNA
WORK SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO X.
DANGER MARGINS FOR SHOCK
ABSORBER EVENTS WHETHER THEY BE
HEAT OR -- YOU KNOW RENEWABLE
MOVEMENTS -- SO -- THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROGRAM I ALSO WANNA
NOTE LOOKS AT THE PEAK OF THE
DAY THE PEAK OF THE DAY YOU
CAN SOLVE THAT BY PUTTING MORE
OF SOLAR AS AN EXAMPLE BUT
IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM
AT SEVEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT --
WHICH IS WHAT I THINK RESOURCE
ADEQUACY NEEDS TO REALLY LOOK
AT IS THOSE PEAK HOURS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE OUR BLACKOUTS
WERE AND WHEN WE HAVE THE TIGHT
CONDITIONS ON THE SUBSEQUENT
DAYS THAT'S WHERE THE RISK WAS
TOO AND WE ASKED PEOPLE YOU
MAY RECALL TO CONSERVE FROM
THREE TO NINE STROLLER THAT
SORT OF FIVE TO NINE WIN WE
HAVE HEAVY AIR CONDITIONING
LOAD STILL ON THE SYSTEM AND
THE SOLAR IS GONE AND I ALSO
WANNA NOTE THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
BEHIND THE METER SOLAR AS WELL
SO WHEN THAT SOLAR GOES THAT
LOAD COMES BACK ON THE SYSTEM
AND SO YOU CAN SEE THE SWING SO
I DO THINK -- AND I I KNOW THAT
MY MY COLLEAGUES UP HERE AGREED
WE'LL HAVE TO RESOURCE ADEQUACY
AND MY SUCCESSOR HAS INDICATED
THAT IT'S A SIZE HIS HIGHEST
PRIORITY TO YOU KNOW SORT
THROUGH THESE ROUTE REACHED
RESOURCE ADEQUACY ISSUES AND
-- I KNOW THE MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE UC AND CC RECOGNIZE
IT TOO SO WE GOT IF THERE'S
MULTIPLE THINGS THAT NEED
TO GO ON HERE I THINK THAT'S
PART OF IT AND I THINK AS --
PRESENT MATTER INDICATED THERE
HAS TO BE SOME PROCUREMENT
AND IT HAS TO BE BE QUICK AND
WE ARE INDEED IN OUR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROCEEDING LOOKING
AT THE MARGIN AND SEEING IF
THE FIFTEEN PERCENT IN LIGHT
OF WHAT -- WAS JUST STATED IS
IS AND AND THE CHANGING THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING AND THE NEW
SOME OF THE NEW FORECASTING
THAT WE'RE GETTING WE HAVE TO
MAKE THIS BALLOTS AND WE DO
HAVE TO DO IT NOW AND WE ARE
THANK YOU AND -- THAT'S WHAT
I WAS TRYING TO GET IT AS
WELL AS OUR PLANE HAD ANYTHING
THAT'S ON THE SHORT TERM SIDE
OF THINGS AS A WILL BE COULD
DO NOW FOR A WHILE RETURNING
TO BALANCE OUT -- UNFOCUSED I
I I JUST WANNA SAY I'VE BEEN
HERE FOR EIGHT YEARS I HAVE
SEEN THIS DO MORE MORE ON
EQUITY BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT I FIND IT INADEQUATE AND
WE HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH ALONG
THE WAY INCISE WE AS WE ARE
DOING THIS WORK I TO SO THAT
THAT'S TOP OF MIND FOR ALL
OF US AND HOW WE COULD DO IT
BETTER WE'VE DONE THINGS LIKE
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR
CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS LOCAL
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
I FIND THAT TO BE INADEQUATE
WHEN WE BURN NINETY PERCENT
OF THE OF THE BURDEN RIGHT SO
-- I I I DO RECOGNIZE THE WORK
WE'VE DONE BUT I'M ALWAYS IN
A STATE WITH THE NEXT UP AND
HOW DO WE DO BETTER AND SO
WE'RE IN A CRISIS AND A CRISIS
MAKES IT REALLY HARD FOR US
TO THINK ABOUT THAT INNOVATION
OF HOW DO WE DO BETTER FOR
THESE COMMUNITY THINKING
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY
THAT THE CRISIS CREATES FOR
CHANGES IN CHANGE IN A MUCH
MORE EQUITABLE WAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU CEMEX
THANK YOU I'M YOU GET TO THIS
STAGE IN THE COMMITTEE NEEDS
START TO REPEAT WHAT EVERYBODY
ELSE HAS HAS SAID -- BUT I
JUST WANTED TO START OFF BY
THANKING THE CHAIRMAN FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AT TODAY
BECAUSE YOU CAN TELL AMONG ALL
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THIS
IS BEEN SOMETHING THAT IS THAT
TOP OF MIND AND WE ALL OF OUR
PASSION ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE WE ADDRESS THAT I WAS ALSO
FASCINATED BY THIS IDEA OF A
MORAL ELECTRON -- -- -- YOU
KNOW EARLIER IN THE DISCUSSION
-- SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE JUST BEEN
SIX YEARS NOW YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD A LITTLE BIT OF EVOLUTION
-- OVER -- THESE THESE SIX
YEARS -- WHEN I CAME IN TO THE
LEGISLATURE I'M NOT SURE THAT
I WOULD HAVE -- PRINTOUTS THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL TOOK ME
A COUPLE YEARS -- AND I WOULD
SAY -- AND I SAID THEN CLIMATE
CHANGE IS REAL I'LL TELL YOU
TODAY -- I FIND THAT STATEMENT
TO BE RIDICULOUS -- THE REASON
I FIND THAT STATEMENT TO BE
RIDICULOUS IS IT PRESUMES
THAT THERE'S STILL ANY DOUBT
THERE ISN'T ANY DOUBT ABOUT
IT IN MY COMMUNITY I REPRESENT
THE COACHELLA VALLEY -- THERE
ARE DAYS THIS YEAR OR THE
RECORD HAD BEEN A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE DAYS OF TRIPLE
DIGIT TEMPERATURES WE'VE BLOWN
PAST THAT HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
DAYS WERE NORTH OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY DAYS NOW WE AND WE
MIGHT END UP WITH A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DAYS AND TWENTY TWENTY
WILL READ HAD TRIPLE DIGIT --
TEMPERATURES AND SO WHEN WE
START TO TALK ABOUT A MORAL
IMPERATIVE THERE IS A MORAL
IMPERATIVE TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE KNOWING THAT WE -- HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY AS A CITIZEN
CALIFORNIA GLOBAL CITIZENS TO
ADDRESS THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
THIS GOVERNMENT -- HAS MADE
THAT A TOP PRIORITY THAT IS
NOT NEGOTIABLE ANY LONGER AT
THE SAME TIME WE HAVE A MORAL
IMPERATIVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ENERGY SECURITY AND
I KNOW WE'VE ALL ADDRESS THAT
AS WELL IT IS UNACCEPTABLE
TO LIVE IN PALM DESERT WHERE
IT'S A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
DEGREES AND GET A NOTICE THAT
YOUR POWER IS GOING TO BE OUT
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT EVEN
WHEN IT COULD BE EIGHT O'CLOCK
AT NIGHT IT COULD STILL BE A
HUNDRED AND FIVE OR A HUNDRED
TEN TO TEN DEGREES AND YOU HAVE
SENIOR CITIZENS THAT ARE HOME
IN THAT KIND OF TEMPERATURE
WITH NO ELECTRICITY AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY BACK UP THAT IS
ALSO A MORAL IMPERATIVE THAT
WE HAVE GOT TO TO ADDRESS SO
AGAIN I'VE I VERY MUCH ENJOY
HAVE ENJOYED THIS CONVERSATION
I THINK WE ARE ALL ON THE SAME
THE SAME PAGE WHAT I HAVEN'T
YET HEARD BUT I HAVEN'T YET
HEARD OF MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE I'M
NOT SMART ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT I HAVEN'T YET HEARD IS
WHAT'S THE ANSWER TO THIS CAN
CAN ALL OF YOU GUARANTEE US
THAT NEXT YEAR THIS ISN'T GOING
TO HAPPEN CAN YOU GUARANTEE US
THAT FIVE YEARS FROM NOW THAT
THIS ISN'T GOING TO HAPPEN
AND THAT'S I HAVEN'T YET HEARD
ANSWER FOR THAT AND THEN I ALSO
WANT TO BRING IT BACK ON US AS
A LEGISLATOR THE LEGISLATURE
IS DO YOU NEED MORE TOOLS FROM
US TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
THESE TO MORAL IMPERATIVES
TO JUST BEING CONFLICT OR TO
COLLIDE WE NEED THEM TO RESOLVE
ONE ANOTHER AND SO WOULD LOVE
TO BE ABLE THAT UNDERSTANDS
OR SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO
AND ALSO THE QUESTION OF --
CAN YOU GUARANTEE THAT IN THE
FUTURE THIS ISN'T GONNA HAPPEN
AGAIN -- FROM THE MANY THINGS
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
MORNING I WOULD SAY WERE ALL
AN ABSOLUTELY DO OUR DAMNDEST
TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN THE MANY THINGS THAT
I'VE TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS OF
AN EXPEDITED -- PROCESS AT THE
PC SOME OF THE CHANGES WERE
PLANNING TO DO MAKE IN TERMS
OF OF -- FORECASTING THAT WILL
CHANGE SOME OF THE PROCUREMENT
THAT WE ORDER AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I SAW HAS TALKED
ABOUT IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE
MARKET -- REVIEW THAT THEY THEY
ARE GOING TO BE UNDERTAKING --
NONE OF US NONE OF US WANTS TO
GO THROUGH THIS EVER AGAIN AND
WE DO FULLY AGREE WITH YOU WE
HAVE PEOPLE WITH MEDICAL NEEDS
WE HAVE THIS SENIOR CITIZENS WE
HAVE -- PEOPLE IN IN LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT CANNOT ABSORB AND TAKE
-- DEALING WITH A POWER OUTAGE
EVEN IF IT'S A ROLLING ONE
SO WE WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
URGENCY WE DO FEEL THE URGENCY
WE'RE PULLING ON EVERY LEVER
WE HAVE I I CAN'T SAY THAT I
WILL PLEDGE TO YOU I GUARANTEE
THIS WILL NOT HAPPEN AGAIN
I'M GONNA DO MY DAMNDEST TO
MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN AND SO ON SO EVERY ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES AT THE CPUC
YEAH I WOULD ADD TO THAT THANK
YOU SEVEN AND I THINK IT'S A
VERY VERY ELOQUENT -- WAITED
CAPTURE THOSE TWIN MORAL
IMPERATIVES AND I WOULD ADD A
THIRD AS WELL AS OUR STATE --
SUFFERS FROM -- THE RECESSION
AND REBUILDING THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY INSIDE CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS IS HUGE THE NUMBER
ONE MANUFACTURING FACILITY
IN THE STATE IS ELECTRIC CAR
COMPANY IT'S MOST VALUABLE
CAR COMING DOWN THE WORLD
THERE'S A HUGE UPSIDE AS WE
PUSH FORWARD ON THIS OUR STATE
ATTRACTS FIFTY THREE PERCENT
OF CLEANTECH VENTURE CAPITAL
FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY COME
HERE -- SUPPORTING ALL THESE
TOOLS -- LIKE -- VERY BILL
SAID YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA FIGHT
LIKE HELL TO ENSURE RELIABLE
THAT'S OUR NUMBER ONE GOAL FOR
ALL OF US PARTLY BECAUSE NOT
ONLY IS THE NEED TO SUPPORT
FOR HEALTH AS YOU YOU MENTIONED
AND OTHERS -- IT ALSO -- ALL
OF THE THESE KIND OF SOLUTIONS
-- IT'LL SO MANY OF THEM ARE
FLOWING THROUGH THE ELECTRIC
GRID RIGHT NOW AND I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT WE'VE MADE INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS SIXTY THREE PERCENT
CARBON FREE ELECTRICITY ON THE
GRID TODAY AND RETAIL SALES
WHICH IS YOU KNOW GO BACK
IN FIVE TEN YEARS AGO PEOPLE
THOUGHT THAT WAS MYTHOLOGY
AND WE'RE DOING IT AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE GROWING THAT
EVERY YEAR -- SO THIS IS GOING
TO BE YOU KNOW OUR NUMBER ONE
FOCUS AND AND -- I JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
I JUST LIKE TO ADD ELEMENTS
OF JUST ADD ONE THOUGHT I I
I AGREE I I I APPRECIATE YOUR
FORMULATION THE QUESTION AND
JUST ONE OBSERVATION I THINK
IT'S AS WE AS WE'VE EMBARKED
IN CALIFORNIA ON SUCH AN
ACTIVE TRANSITION TO CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE WE NEED TO BE
TALKING OPENLY AND HONESTLY
AND TRANSPARENTLY ABOUT OURS
OUR POWER SYSTEM MORE REGULARLY
MORE FREQUENTLY NOT JUST
WHEN THINGS GO BAD WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT NOT ONLY DO WE
-- AT THE I. S. O.
N. AT THE C. P. C. N. C. C.
HAVE PROFOUND RESPONSIBILITIES
TO HELP NAVIGATE THIS
TRANSITION BUT EVERY CITIZEN
OF CALIFORNIA WILL PLAY A
ROLE IN THIS TRANSITION AND
AN INCREASING AWARENESS OF
THE ROLE OF OTHER ELECTRICITY
DEMAND WHAT INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMERS WHAT INDIVIDUAL
TECHNOLOGIES THE BATTERY IN
YOUR BASEMENT THE RENEWABLE
BUT SOLAR PANELS ON YOUR ROOF
ALL OF THESE RESOURCES CAN PLAY
A ROLE IN THE SOLUTION AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET INTEGRATED INTO THE GREAT
AS EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE AND
AND UNDERSTAND THOSE CHOICES
SO I I AND I WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE OPENLY AND REGULARLY
SO THAT WE CAN REPORT ON THE
PROGRESS IN THE AREAS WHERE
WE ARE ACCELERATING INTO
CONTINUE TO VERY TRANSPARENTLY
IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE WE HAVE
UP TILL CHALLENGES WHERE WE
ALL REALLY NEED TO LEAN IN
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT
AND AND YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS THOSE MORAL IMPERATIVES
AND AND LOOK FOR DEBT FOR
THE DIALOGUE -- IN THE MONTHS
AND YEARS AHEAD THANK YOU
SURE PETRIE-NORRIS
HI THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND SO I CHAIRED THE
ASSEMBLY'S ACCOUNTABILITY IN
A MINUTE TO REVIEW COMMITTEE I
DON'T SERVE ON THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
FOR INVITING ME TO JOIN YOU
AND THIS IS NOT A YOU KNOW AN
AREA OF DEEP POLICY EXPERTISE
FOR ME THIS I KNOW I CAN
APPROACH THIS HEARING IN THIS
CONVERSATION I THINK IT'S
KIND OF A NORMAL CALIFORNIA
AND I'LL SAY IT MOST OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS THEY DON'T SPEND
VERY MUCH TIME THINKING ABOUT
STATE GOVERNMENT RIGHT THEY ARE
TOO BUSY FIGURE OUT HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLE HOW THEY'RE GOING TO GET
TO WORK YOU KNOW HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO PAY THEIR BILLS I'M
BUT THEY CERTAINLY EXPECT US
TO KEEP THEIR LIGHTS ON SO JUST
PICKING UP ON THE THREAD FIVE
OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER MAYES
HAS RAISED I WAS LIKE MY HEART
KIND OF STOPPED WHEN HE SAID
CAN YOU ASSURE US THIS ISN'T
GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT SUMMER AND
NOBODY SAID YES EVERYONE SAID
WE'RE GOING TO WORK LIKE HELL
WE'RE GONNA DO OUR BEST AND
LIKE WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO
MAKE THAT ANSWER YES BECAUSE
THIS IS TWENTY TWENTY THIS
IS CALIFORNIA WHERE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE
ARE NO I CAPITAL OF TECHNOLOGY
AND INNOVATION IF WE CAN'T
SAY IF WE CAN UNEQUIVOCALLY
SAY YES WE'RE KEEPING YOUR
LIGHTS ON NEXT SUMMER I MEAN
I'M PRETTY FOR FIVE YEARS
SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
MAKE THAT UNDER PERCENT YES
WELL LET ME LET ME LET ME
TAKE ANOTHER SWING AND TRYING
CORRECT MYSELF BECAUSE WHAT
I I SAID AS I AM OF FREIGHT
I TO TAKE AN ABSOLUTE PLEDGE
WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT WE WOULD
HAVE THE KIND OF DAYS IN AUGUST
THAT WE JUST TEN OF THE MANY
THINGS THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT WE ALL HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR WE ARE DOING ALL OF THEM I
DO THINK THAT WILL ABSOLUTELY
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON NEXT SUMMER
OKAY THAT'S THAT'S GOOD THAT'S
REASSURING I'M BACK TO ANYTHING
SAID THAT THE THREAD IT'S KIND
OF OLD IT WASN'T A THREAT IT
WAS KIND OF THAT THE CORE OF
THE TESTIMONY BECAUSE OF THE
CORE OF THE ANALYSIS HAS TALKED
ABOUT THIS AS A ONE IN THIRTY
FIVE YEAR HE DIFFERENT RIGHT
I'M BUT EVEN IN THE MIDST OF
THAT PEAK DEMAND WAS BELOW WHAT
WE SAW IN TWO THOUSAND SIX SO
I'M GIVEN THE REASSURANCES THAT
THAT YOU'VE MADE THAT IT WASN'T
BECAUSE OF RENEWABLES WHAT
YOU KNOW WHAT ISN'T WORKING AS
WELL AS IT DID IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX THAT'S MY QUESTION --
I CAN I CAN TAKE US ARE YOU
READY FOR THAT ANSWERED YOU
HAVE THAT YES OKAY I CAN TAKE
-- TAKE A CRACK AT THAT -- THE
SYSTEM WAS VERY DIFFERENT IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX THAN IT IS
TODAY -- OBVIOUSLY THE RULES
ARE DIFFERENT BUT THERE IS FAR
MORE CAPACITY ON THE SYSTEM
THEN AND FURTHERMORE WE HAD --
AS I INDICATED EARLIER WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
OF ROOFTOP SOLAR NOW SO IF YOU
WERE TO COMPARE THE LOAD IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX WHICH WAS FIFTY
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ROUGHLY -- WITH WHAT WE HAD
RECENTLY YOU HAVE TO NORMALIZE
IT WOULD BE A FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF LOAD
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX SO IF
YOU KIND OF COMPARE APPLES AND
APPLES IT WAS IT'S A COMPARABLE
LOADED -- THAT WE HAD -- THIS
YEAR AS IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
AND WHEN YOU WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
-- ONE IN THIRTY FIVE WE DO
THINK IT'S A ONE THIRTY FIVE WE
JUST THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
MORE ONE AND THIRTY FIVES AND
I THINK THAT'S GOT TO BE PART
OF THE PLANNING GOING FORWARD
THAT THIS THIS HE NEEDS AND
THIS CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
YOU KNOW IS UPON US AND IT'S
NOT GONNA BE WON IN THIRTY
FIVE ANYMORE IT COULD BE THE
ONE IN FIVE NOW IT COULD BE A
ONE AND TWO NOW -- AND I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PLAN
FOR THAT AND I THINK THAT'S
HOW WE GET CLOSE TO MAKING
SURE WE CAN ASSURE RELIABILITY
OKAY SIR AB BUT WHAT WHAT
CHANGED IN CAN OF THE
MANAGEMENT PROCESS SEES VERSUS
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX IN TERMS
OF THE FACT WE WERE ABLE TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND WE WE WEREN'T
IN AUGUST ACTUALLY THERE WERE
THERE WERE TWO THINGS I WOULD
POINT TO THAT WE HAD DIFFERENT
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX AND WE
HAVE NOW ONE AS I INDICATED
WE HAD FAR MORE PASS ME ON THE
SYSTEM WE HAD -- THE SENATE NO
FREE NUCLEAR PLANT WHICH IS IN
TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS RIGHT
THERE -- THEN AND WE HAD --
PROBABLY SEVERAL THOUSAND NOT
PROBABLY WE DID HAVE SEVERAL
THOUSAND MORE MEGAWATTS OF
GAS PLANTS THAN -- THAN WE
DO NOW SO THE RISK PASSED THE
DIFFERENCE THE SECOND ELEMENT
IS -- THIS AN ELEMENT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT CALIFORNIA
HEAVILY RELIES ON IMPORTS INTO
THE STATE TO MEET ITS NEEDS
AND IT'S BEEN CLEAR TO US THAT
THAT -- RELIANCE ON IMPORTS IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO RETHINK
BECAUSE THE OTHER AREAS ARE
FACED WITH THE SAME CHALLENGES
THAT WE ARE HERE BOTH IN TERMS
OF LOAD -- AND OTHER CHANGES
TO THEIR SYSTEM SO THE THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF RESOURCE
RETIREMENTS ACROSS THE WEST WE
IMPORTED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT FIGURES
BUT IF I HAD TO TAKE A STAB
AT IT WE IMPORTED ON THE ORDER
OF TWELVE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
OF POWER -- OVER THIS HEAT
WAVE WE ARE THE THE TOP WE HAD
WAS ABOUT SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATT SO ABOUT HALF OF
WHAT WE HAD TO BE IMPORTED SO
BETWEEN CAPACITY ON THE SYSTEM
AND IMPORTS -- THAT COUNTS FOR
A LOT OF THE DIFFERENCE GOT
IT OKAY AND THEN LAST QUESTION
SUIT CAN YOU JUST WALK US
THROUGH YOUR ATKINS ESCALATION
PROCESS SEES SO -- YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS WHO RAISES THE
ALARM AND SAYS MY GOSH WHAT
WERE ABOUT TO BE OUT OF POWER
BECAUSE I THINK ONE THING THAT
WAS VERY SURPRISING IS IT FELT
LIKE WE WERE ALL REALLY TAKEN
BY SURPRISE BY THIS IT WAS
I THINK IS THE CHAIR SAID WE
RECEIVED A KIND OF A TWELVE
HOURS NOTICE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT SO CAN YOU TALK US THROUGH
WHAT ARE KIND OF THE EARLY
WARNING SYSTEMS AND ESCALATION
PROCEDURES FIVE WHEN THE SORT
OF THING OCCURS ALL BUT I'LL
TAKE THAT TOO AND -- AS AN
INSTITUTION -- WILL OWN THAT
THAT WE SHOULD OF RAISE THE
ALARM -- -- FASTER BUT -- ALL
JUST HAVE TO GIVE YOU SOME OF
MY OWN PERSONAL OBSERVATIONS
ON THIS WE ARE OFFERING VERY
CLOSE TO THE EDGE AND I THINK
WE HAVE A CONTROL ROOM -- WHERE
THE OPERATORS OPERATE THE GRID
AND I'VE BEEN DOWN THERE ON
A NUMBER OF CASES AND TIMES
WHERE THEY SAID IT'S GOING TO
BE TIGHT OVER THE PEAK OF HAD
A CONVERSATION WITH THOSE GREAT
OPERATORS FIFTY TIMES IT'S
GONNA BE TIGHT OVER THE P.
WE KNEW GOING ON THE FOURTEENTH
THAT WAS GOING TO BE TIGHT
WHAT WE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND AND
WE UNDERESTIMATED IS HOW MUCH
THE PARTICULARLY THE IMPORTANCE
WORDS AVAILABLE BECAUSE THE
HEAT WAVE WE HAD WAS A WEST
WIDE HEAT WAVE IT WAS BRUTAL
EVERYWHERE IN THE WEST SO WE
UNDERESTIMATED THE THE LIMITED
ACCESS OF IMPORTS THAT WE HAD
AND -- WE WILL BE -- VIGILANT
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT ISN'T
THE SITUATION AND I THINK WE
CORRECTED OURSELVES OVER LABOR
DAY WEEKEND WE WE TOLD PEOPLE
VERY EARLY THAT THE CONDITIONS
ARE GONNA BE TIGHT I WILL NOTE
THAT WE DID -- ISSUE A FLEXIBLE
OR ON THURSDAY THE THIRTEENTH
AND RESTRICTED MAINTENANCE
-- ORDER ON THE TWELFTH GOING
INTO THAT NOW THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOU KNOW THE POPULACE OF
THE STATE KNOWS THAT THERE'S
A RESTRICTED MAINTENANCE THEY
SHOULD KNOW THERE'S A FLEX
ALERT HERE TO AFTER UP TO A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THERE WAS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT -- ADVERTISING
CAMPAIGN TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
ABOUT FLEX ALERTS AND HOW THEY
WORKED AND THAT FELL BY THE
WAYSIDE IN ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS IS
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY CITIZEN
IN THE STATE IS A WHERE WHEN WE
HAVE TIGHT CONDITION SO WE'VE
WE'VE GOT TO RETHINK HOW THE
SPLIT SOLAR PROCESS WORKS AND
IT'S A LEARNING FOR US AND I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT IT WILL BE
TOP OF MIND GOT AN ACCESS ONE
MORE QUESTION BECAUSE THE AND
SOME ARTICLES THAT I'VE READ
THERE HAVE BEEN FIVE OBSERVERS
INCLUDING I THINK A FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE P. C.
HO SPECULATED THAT WE HAVE SOME
OF THE SAME MARKET MANIPULATION
OF POTENTIALLY HAPPENING AS WE
DID IN THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS
-- ENERGY CRISIS DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE YOU THINK THAT'S PART
OF THE ISSUE BUT CAN YOU JUST
SPEAK TO SPEAK TO THAT CONCERN
I CAN ALSO DO THAT WE HAVE
SEEN NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER
OF MANIPULATION DURING THESE
PERIODS -- AND I KNOW THAT
A FORMER UC -- PRESIDENT
SPECULATE ON THAT WITH FRANKLY
NO BASIS AND I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE WHERE THE BASIS CAME
FROM -- BOTH OR WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT AN INDEPENDENT --
DEPARTMENT OF MARKET MONITORING
THEY LOOKED INTO THIS THEY
AGREE WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING
NOW THAT DOESN'T MEAN -- WE'RE
GONNA PUT OUR GUARDS DOWN
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT AND
WE DO NOT SEE ANYTHING AND
FURTHERMORE THE OUTAGE RATES
ON THOSE DAYS OF -- GENERATORS
WAS PROBABLY BELOW NORMAL
SO WE DIDN'T SEE WITHHOLDING
OR OTHER MANIPULATION SO --
THAT'S THAT'S RESPONSE TO
THE GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER QUITE CUNNINGHAM
FEMINIST BURKE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AMANDA I WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR BEING
HERE I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST
ACTUALLY OUR SITUATION WITH
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY GRID
IT'S A LOT WORSE AND WE'RE
CONTEMPLATING TODAY WE ARE
SEEING THE RETIREMENT ASSETS
WHETHER THEY BE NATURAL GAS OR
THE IMPENDING DECOMMISSIONING
OF THE DIABLO CANYON NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT JAPANESE TO BE
IN MY DISTRICT WHICH PRODUCES
NINE PERCENT ROUGHLY THE
STATE'S ENERGY CARBON FREE IN
MY OPINION THAT'S A FOOLISH
DECISION BUT IT'S BEEN MADE
AND WE'RE ADAPTING TO IT THE
QUESTION IS ARE WE PLANNING
FOR IT I THINK THE ANSWER'S
NO WE HAVE NO PLAN REALLY
WE'VE WRITTEN IN THE LAWS THAT
WE HAVE TO ACHIEVE GOALS --
DECARBONIZING OUR ELECTRICITY
GRIDS ABSOLUTELY THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE ENVIRONMENT FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE FOR CONSTITUENTS
BUT YOU NEED A PLAN TO TO TO
EXECUTE THAT YOU NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO REPLACE THE RETIRED
ASSETS REPLACE DOUBLE CANYON'S
POWER THE FUTURE IS ALSO GONNA
INVOLVE A LOT MORE DEMAND ON
OUR ELECTRICITY GRID WE'RE
BUILDING MORE HOUSING THAT'S
MORE AC UNITS MORE LECTERNS
IT'S GETTING HOTTER EVERY YEAR
A LOT HOTTER THAT'S MORE AC
MORE ELECTRONS WE'RE GOING TO
CLOUD COMPUTING FIVE G.
THAT'S MORE ELECTRONS WE'RE
GOING TO SEE A REVOLUTION
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THAT'S A
LOT MORE ELECTRONS ALL THIS
IS HAPPENING OVER THE NEXT
DECADE WE'RE PRETENDING THIS
IS A STATIC EQUATION NOT
DEMANDS GOING UP GOING UP
A LOT WE'RE LOSING SUPPLY
WIND AND SOLAR GREAT THEY'RE
FANTASTIC THEY'RE ALSO
INTERMITTENT SOARED PRODUCES
ZERO IN A STARK WIND GOES UP
AND DOWN SO YOU GOT A PAIR
THAT WITH STORAGE AS SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE POINTED OUT
WIDESCALE WIDESPREAD PUMPED
STORAGE BATTERY STORES DOESN'T
WORK THERE ISN'T ENOUGH WITH
WITH THEM IN THE WORLD TO DO IT
THAT WAY THESE ARE FACTS FOLKS
THESE ARE FACTS THIS IS SCIENCE
WE NEED A PLAN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ME AND SENATOR MONNING WITH
A LOT OF HELP FROM PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM PASSED THE BILL SB
TO NINETY TO MITIGATE SOME
OF THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
DIABLO CANYON CLOSURE AND IN
THAT BILL IT REQUIRED A PLAN
FOR THE PC TO REPLACE THE NINE
PERCENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
LOSE FROM DIABLO WHEN IS THE
COMMISSION TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WITH GHG EMISSION FREE ENERGY
PRODUCTION WE SEE NOTHING ELSE
TWO YEARS AGO WE SEE NOTHING
I'VE BEEN TRYING FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF OR TWO YEARS TO
GET A TARGET SET BY THE QC FOR
OFFSHORE WIND PRODUCTION BEEN
BEATING MY HEAD INTO THE WALL
MOSTLY FOR YEARS THE PC'S BEEN
SAYING WE'RE GONNA GET TO THAT
WE'VE GOT SOMETHING COMING
OUT HAVEN'T SEEN A THING OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE SOLVING PROBLEMS
PORTUGAL IRELAND VIRGINIA RHODE
ISLAND STATES ON THE EAST COAST
OFFSHORE WIND YOU COULD DO
TWO GIGAWATTS HE SAID ENOUGH
OFFER WHEN WHAT'S OUR PLAN
WE'RE GONNA NEED MORE POWER
IN THE FUTURE THAT WE HAVE
NOW BY A LOT WE'RE RETIRING
ASSETS YEAR OVER YEAR IT'S
GETTING HOTTER WE'RE BUILDING
MORE HOUSING SO WHAT I'D LIKE
TO ASK YOU TO COMMENT ON IS
WHAT ARE THE PLANS FOR THOSE
SPECIFIC THINGS THE APPLE
CANYON LOS OF NUCLEAR POWER
OFFSHORE WIND PRODUCTION AND
FINALLY WIDESPREAD PUMP STORAGE
IS THERE A PUMPED STORAGE
PROJECT THAT CAN COME ONLINE IN
THE STATE ANYTIME IN THE NEXT
FIVE TO TEN YEARS I APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWERS THOSE QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SIR I CAN TAKE THAT
THANK YOU -- AS I MENTIONED
IN MY PRISON TATIAN AND IN OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE A PLAN FOR ON THE NINE
PERCENT THAT'S FALLING OFF FROM
THE DIABLO CANYON GENERATING
STATION -- WE HAD IN THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCEEDING WE ENSURE THAT ALL
THE LOAD SERVING ENTITIES ARE
ON TRACK TO PROCURE THEIR SHARE
OF THE REPLACEMENT POWER --
OF THE RETIRING DIAVEL CANYON
THEY HAVE SUBMITTED THOSE
PLANS AS OF SEPTEMBER ONE WERE
ANALYZING THEM NOW TO ENSURE
THAT INDEED THEY ARE MEETING
THE REQUIREMENTS TO REPLACE --
THE LOAD SO THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
NOT ONLY IS IT A PLAN IT IS
PLANNED IT'S IN THE PAST TENSE
WE'VE DONE IT ON AND I WANT
TO ENSURE ASSURE YOU OF THAT
-- AND IN TERMS OF THE PUMP
STORAGE THERE ARE WE DO HAVE
ON STORAGE AND THERE WILL THERE
ARE OTHER PLANS FOR FOR FUTURE
PUMP STORAGE IT IS DEFINITELY
IN OUR PLANNING -- AND IN OUR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY -- PROCEEDING
THANK YOU SEVEN MINUTES TO TO
BUILD ON PRESENT BADGERS ARE
KIND OF PRESET YOU RAISING
OFFER WHEN YOU'RE NOT DONE
SOME SITE VISITS TOGETHER
DOWN THERE AND I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT -- THIS YEAR WITH
THE FIRST FUNDING FOR RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT RELATED
TO OFFSHORE WIND I AM VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT TECHNOLOGY HAS
A FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
ALREADY IN PLACE IN THE EAST
COAST -- OFFERED ISLAND AND
THERE'S -- -- NOW DEPLOYMENT'S
GOING UP AND IN NEW YORK IN
NEW JERSEY THE U.
K. HAS THIRTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
OFFSHORE WIND PROJECTS IN
PLACE SOME OF THEM ARE SIXTY
MILES OFFSHORE WHERE THEY
CAN'T BE SEEN -- THE ENTIRE
IS GOING TO A TWELVE MEGAWATT
PLATFORM ON LAND IN CALIFORNIA
LET'S SEE SEE YOU KNOW ONE
HALF TO TWO MEGAWATTS OF THE
THE SCALE FOR THE RESOURCE THE
WIND RESOURCE IS SUBSTANTIALLY
BETTER OFF SHORE IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S APPROACHING SIXTY PERCENT
CAPACITY FACTORS OF THE
TURBINES ARE SPENDING SIXTY
PERCENT THE HOURS OF THE DAY
IN WAYS THAT COMPLEMENT SOLAR
BEAUTIFULLY THERE UP IN THE
MORNING DOWN THE MIDDLE OF
THE DAY AND THEN THEY GO UP IN
THE AFTERNOON AND EVENING --
AS COMPARED TO WIND ON LANDS
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
CAPACITY FACTOR SO WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT WE DO NEED TO
BE ABLE TO COOPERATE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THIS
AND -- THAT'S THAT HAS BEEN
A AN ONGOING -- CHALLENGE BUT
I'M HOPEFUL -- WILL BE ABLE
TO MAKE SOME REAL PROGRESS
ON THAT IN THE YEARS AT AND
I AGREE VERY MUCH WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE NEED FOR
LAND AND HOW IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO COURT COORDINATOR
AND WORK WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON A DEPARTMENT
OF NAVY IN PARTICULAR IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE OFFER
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE
ALONG THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA
MISTER AT
FIRST I CAN HEAR ME FIRST I
WANT TO THANK PRESIDENT BACK
I WILL AGREE THAT AS YOU'VE
BEEN THERE I HAVE SEEN THINGS
START TO MOVE BETTER AND YOU'VE
BEEN ACCESSIBLE AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT OF COURSE
BEFORE I MAKE MY NEXT SET OF
-- YOU KNOW I THINK WE'RE I
THINK THERE'S A GENERAL FUND
OPERATION WITH THIS KIND OF
TERM EXTREME WEATHER EVENT
AND I HEAR YOU SAYING YOU KNOW
WE ACCEPT THAT THERE'S GLOBAL
WARMING AND ALL OF THESE THINGS
BUT I THINK THAT A SINGLE ONE
IT'S A ONE IN THIRTY FIVE YEAR
EVENT I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
THAT WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT ONE
THIRTY FIVE IS NOW ONE IN FIVE
OR ONE INTO HOWEVER I FEAR
HOW YOU'VE BEEN PLANNING AND
IT'S EVERY TWO EVEN PLANNING
BASED ON EVERY TWO YEARS AND I
THINK THAT THERE'S SOME CONCERN
THAT THAT IT'S NOT GONNA WORK
ANYMORE AND THAT THE FACT THAT
GLOBAL WARMING IS GLOBAL AND
LIKE THAT WAS JUST SAID THAT
WE HAD A WEST COAST EVENT
OBVIOUSLY THAT OCCURRED AND WE
LOST IN THE FIGHT FOR ELECTRONS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LOSS
BECAUSE WE HAVE RELIED ON THE
IMPORT OF THAT YOU KNOW I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN RESPECT
OUR GOALS I RESPECT WE CAN BE
THOUGHT FOR THE TRANSITION I
JUST I'M NOT SURE THAT WE BEEN
HONEST OF WHAT THAT TRANSITION
ACTUALLY NEEDS TO LOOK LIKE AND
I WILL SAY THAT THAT IS PARTLY
NOT JUST I THINK WE'RE PUTTING
A LOT OF IT ON YOU AND CAL I
STILL BUT I DO THINK IT'S PART
THE LEGISLATURE FOR POSSIBILITY
AS WELL AND IN SAYING THAT
I I JUST BECAUSE THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE HAVE
BEEN HONEST WITH SOME OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTALISTS PARTNERS I
THINK WE'VE TOLD THEM THAT WE
HAVE THESE LOFTY GOALS AND I
THINK WE CAN REACH AND I THINK
WE CAN BE A GOOD EXAMPLE BUT
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
HONEST ABOUT WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN
BETWEEN HERE AND THERE AND I
KEEP HEARING A LOT OF WORDS
AND I THINK LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
MENTIONED LIKE PLANNING AND
IN THE FUTURE TECHNOLOGY AND
WE ARE PLANNING FOR THESE
THINGS BUT IF WE HAD AN ANOTHER
EVENT TOMORROW FOR THE NEXT
WEEK WE WOULD FAIL AGAIN AND
I HAVEN'T REALLY HEARD HOW
WE WOULDN'T FAIL AGAIN SO I
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS AS SOMEONE
WHO'S WILLING TO TAKE AND TAKE
ON THE RESPONSIBILITY WITH
MY COLLEAGUES IS ACCEPTING
THAT PART OF THIS IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY ONE IS IN YOUR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PLANS THAT
YOU ARE MAKING ADJUSTMENTS WERE
BECAUSE PEAK IS NOT THE SAME
I MEAN I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
WHERE IT AT TWELVE O'CLOCK
IT'S THE HOTTEST OF DOUBT
THAT I WORK IN SACRAMENTO I'VE
LEARNED THAT FOUR O'CLOCK IT'S
A HUNDRED AND FOUR DEGREES
OUTSIDE IN MY LA HOME I
DON'T HAVE AIR CONDITIONING I
DON'T NEED IT UP HERE CENTRAL
VALLEY ALL THIS AND I'VE WORN
THESE THINGS THAT I DIDN'T
KNOW BEFORE AND I'M CURIOUS
I KNOW YOU'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF ADJUSTING THAT RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROCESS AND PLAN IN
THE MARGINS MY QUESTION FIRST
QUESTION WOULD BE ONE DO WE
NEED TO LEGISLATE TO PUT A
DEADLINE ON THAT PROCESS IS
THAT WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
MAKE SWORE THAT THAT IS DONE
IN A TIMELY FASHION I KNOW
YOU'RE IN THE PROCESS OF IT BUT
I'M CURIOUS IS THAT NECESSARY
AND THEN MY SECOND QUESTION
IS BATTERY STORAGE OBVIOUSLY
LITHIUM BATTERIES AREN'T
LONG ENOUGH OBVIOUSLY WE NEED
SEASONAL STORAGE BUT THAT IS
NOT INTO TALLADEGA NOT IN THE
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS IS THAT A
TOTAL PLAN I THINK WE'VE ALL
AGREED -- WE ALL UNDERSTAND NOW
THE BATTERY STORAGE ISN'T THE
GOLDEN EGG THAT WE HAD HOPED
IT WAS GOING TO BE YOU KNOW
WHERE DO MICRO GRADES FALL INTO
THAT I KNOW THAT YOU'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF PROCEEDING DO WE
NEED TO LEGISLATORS TO WIN THAT
OR WE ALREADY HAVE LEGISLATORS
TO WIN AT THAT PROCEEDING
SHOULD BE DONE I APPRECIATE
AGAIN PRESIDENT BADGER THAT
THAT HAS MOVED FASTER SINCE
YOU'VE BEEN THERE BUT HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THESE THINGS AS A
LEGISLATURE HOW DO WE WILL LINE
COMMUNICATE HONESTLY WHAT THE
TRANSITION REALLY DOES GONNA
IS GONNA LOOK LIKE AND WHAT DO
YOU NEED FROM US TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR TO PEOPLE AND TO GIVE
YOU THE TOOLS YOU NEED TO MAKE
THIS GREAT TRANSITION TO THIS
CARBON FREE ENVIRONMENT AND
TO DOES IT HELP YOU OR DO WE
NEED TO LEGISLATE ON WHAT THOSE
DEADLINE LOOK LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THEY ARE RECEIVED BECAUSE TO ME
I WILL SAY I WAS NOT SURPRISED
AT WHAT HAPPENED BECAUSE CAO
AYE SO CAME TO ME A YEAR AGO
AND SAID THIS IS ON IT'S ON THE
HORIZON SO I KNOW I'M PRETTY
LOW ON THE TOTEM POLE IF I IF
SOMEONE CAME TO ME THEY CAME
TO EVERYBODY ELSE LONG BEFORE
THEY CAME TO ME SO I FIND IT
FRUSTRATING THAT WE HIT THAT
WE HIT THAT FEW DAYS BECAUSE
IF I KNEW IT WAS ON THE HORIZON
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS
ROOM INCLUDING YOU GUYS KNEW
AND WERE ALL RESPONSIBLE I'M
WILLING TO TAKE ON PART OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY BUT I NEED TO
KNOW WHAT IT NEEDS TO LOOK LIKE
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE --
WE ARE WE WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
AND WE TAKE THAT FULLY I
-- THE I DON'T BELIEVE WE
NEED TIME FRAMES WE ARE OUR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY NOT WHAT
THE DECISION IS ON GOING OUR
OUR ON EXPEDITED -- PROCEEDING
-- IS UNDER WAY AS I SAID
RESEARCH ADVOCACY DECISIONS
THIS THIS PHASE THIS ROUND
WILL BE DONE IN BY JUNE AND
ON IT REAL QUICK SO WILL THAT
INCLUDE THE TRADITIONAL PEAKER
THAT WILL INCLUDE AN EXTENDED
NO WE WILL BE LOOKING AT THE
NEXT WEEK -- THAT -- CALISTO
IS A HAS -- WELL TODAY YES
GOSH I LOST MY TRAIN OF
THOUGHT WHAT MY SECOND POINT
IS -- YOUR SECOND QUESTION I'M
SORRY REYES WERE PART OF THE
OVERALL PICTURE WHAT NEEDED TO
HOW DO WE NEED TO LEGISLATIVE
OR WE'VE ALREADY LEGISLATED
ON WHEN THAT SHOULD BE DONE
BUT WHAT IS NOT LOOKING LIKE
ARE WE WE WE -- EXPEDITED
THAT PROCEEDING -- MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONER COMMISSIONER
SURE ROMA STARTED PHASE --
ONE OF THAT AND WE SCULPTED
ACTUALLY IN DECEMBER AND IT WAS
FINALIZED IN JUNE -- FOR THIS
YEAR FOR THIS COMING YEAR AND
SHE IS NOW UNDERTAKING PHASE
TWO WHICH WILL BE FINALIZED ME
BEFORE -- THE END OF THE YEAR
BY DECEMBER ON MICHAEL IT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US THE PHASE ONE
OF THE MICROGRID WAS FOR THIS
COMING IT PERIOD OF TIME SOME
OF THE MIX WHICH WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER WAS FRANKLY DIESEL THAT
WAS PUT INTO THE MY COULD GET
THAT WHERE WERE -- WORKING HARD
WITH THE LSE'S AND OTHERS TO
ENSURE THAT THAT IS REPLACED
BY -- CLEAN ENERGY AND -- IT
WAS A TIME FACTOR UNFORTUNATELY
THIS YEAR BUT THOSE BOTH THOSE
PROCEEDINGS WERE EXPEDITED
DONE WITHIN A SIX MONTH PERIOD
AND THAT WILL CONTINUE TO TO
COMPLETION RIGHT YES YES --
AND THEN MY LAST QUESTION IS
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE THESE
RESOURCES COMING ONLINE --
I IT THOSE SEEM LIKE ENOUGH
FOR NEXT YEAR I JUST WHAT I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS HOW
I KNOW YOU SAID THAT THERE'S
PLANNING TO GO TO TWO AND FIVE
YEARS TWO AND FIVE YEAR OUT
BUT THAT WAS BASED ON I BELIEVE
WITH THE JOHN THE MINISTER SAID
WAS A ON THIS TRADITION OF OF
REVIEWING THE LAST TWO YEARS
-- I GREW UP WHAT WE WOULD NEED
SO LOOKING FORWARD IS THERE
A TOTALITY THE TOTALITARIAN
SOMEWHERE LOOK AT ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM MENTIONED
THAT WE HAVE YOU KNOW LIKE
THE CARS COMING ONLINE THAT WE
HAVE THESE LARGE OBVIOUSLY WILL
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS WHICH I
THINK ARE JUST NEW WHETHER NEW
SUMMERS EARLIER LONGER SUMMERS
-- HOW WHAT DOES IT ACTUALLY
LOOK LIKE HOW DOES THAT PROCESS
WHAT DOES THAT PROCESS LOOK
LIKE DIFFERENT THAN IT WILL
LOOK LIKE BEFORE THAT PLANNING
PROCESS BECAUSE I'M LISTENING
TO WHAT THE GENTLEMAN SAID
AND SOUNDED LIKE THEY WERE
CONTINUING TO DO WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN DOING IN THE FORECASTING
YES -- DO YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT DAY YES SO WHEN WE WE DO
THE WE DO A ONE INTO FORECAST
ONE OF FIVE FORECAST ONE TEN
FOR THOSE ARE ALREADY ON GOING
THAT THE CHOICE WHICH TO USE
IS NOT IS NOT ARE WE I THINK
THAT THE THE -- YOU'RE RIGHT
THAT WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS THE
CLIMATE IS CHANGING WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE YOU KNOW THE EVENTS
THAT USED TO BE ONE THIRTY FIVE
THAT ARE MORE FREQUENT I THINK
THAT'S YOUR ALL CALIBER THAT
BUT WE'RE ALSO -- STEVEN WONDER
IF YOU COULD COMMENT ON THE
HIGH ELECTRIFICATION FORECAST
BECAUSE WE ARE WE HAVE A
SCENARIO WE RUN WHERE WE'RE YOU
KNOW WHICH INCLUDES ALL OF THE
THINGS AS SOMEONE CUNNINGHAM
WAS MENTIONING INCLUDING RECTOR
KEUCHEL'S SILVA COULD YOU JUST
COMMENT ON THAT YEAH -- THANK
YOU CHAIR -- THE -- SPECIFIC
IN THAT THE -- CHICO SHIELD
IS TALKING ABOUT IS AND THE
THIRD PLANNING HORIZON WE HAVE
WHICH IS THE SB ONE HUNDRED
WHICH IS THE TWENTY FORTY FIVE
-- WORK THAT THE T.
AGENCIES ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
ON -- INCLUDING THAT EIGHT
RESOURCES BOARD I'M TO THE
DEMAND SCENARIOS THAT WE
CURRENTLY -- USE TO PLAN
THE GOOD FOR TWENTY FORTY
FIVE I JUST CALLED THE HIGH
ELECTRIFICATION SCENARIO
AND WITHIN THAT SCENARIO
-- WE ACTUALLY ASSUME THAT
A HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES WILL BE
ELECTRIC BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE THAT WAS PRIOR TO THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS SIGNED
I'M SO SO THAT'S KIND OF
IN LINE WITH -- WITH WHAT
SOME OF THE AT THE GUINNESS
AND IN THAT PROJECTION IS A
PROJECTING -- AS IF WE ALL
GO BACK TO LIKE I I'LL HOW DO
YOU PROJECT FOR LIKE ALL THESE
LIFE CHANGES RIGHT LIKE NOW
WE HAVE COLLUDED WILL STAY AT
HOME I ASSUME THAT HAS SOME
ISSUE SOME BALANCE ON WHY WE
LOST ELECTRICITY EVERYONE'S
IN THEIR HOUSE AND IT YOU KNOW
WITH THEIR CONDITIONING ON ON
THEIR OFFICE BUILDINGS HOW DID
THOSE PROJECTIONS WORK FOR THAN
FOR A AND ARE THERE TO LEVELS
OF PROJECTIONS ONE FOUR IF
WORKING LIFE IS CHANGING PEOPLE
ARE CHARGING ELECTRIC VEHICLES
AT HOME VERSUS IF THERE AND
YOU KNOW HAVING TO CHARGE
AN OFFICER OR AT DIFFERENT
TIMES A DAY AS OPPOSED TO
BEING WHERE WE USED TO ALL BE
IN THE OFFICE DURING THE DAY
ALL DAY LONG NOW MAYBE THAT
MOVING ALONG JUST AS P.
BECAUSE CHANGED HOW DO YOU
ADJUST FOR THE PEAK CHANGING
ON WHAT THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING REQUIREMENTS WILL
BE AND THEN I HAVE A RELEASED
RANDOM STUPID QUESTION BECAUSE
I ACTUALLY DID AT ONE POINT
SINCE I HAVE YOU I'M AS A
MASCOT -- I DID THINK ABOUT
BUYING ELECTRIC CAR NOT TOO
LONG AGO AND THEN THESE POWER
OUTAGES WHEN OUT SO WHAT
HAPPENS TO ME OF MY ELECTRIC
CAR AND THE POWER GOES OUT
FOR TWO DAYS WHAT WHAT WAS
MY CAR I DON'T CHARGE MY CAR
I GOT A BICYCLE
SO I BELIEVE I CAN RESPOND
THAT THE NAVY SILVA WOULD YOU
RESPOND HER FIRST QUESTION
FIRST AND I'LL TAKE THAT SECOND
YEAH ABSOLUTELY -- I THANK YOU
FOR THOSE QUESTIONS I THINK
THOSE ARE -- REALLY INSIGHTFUL
QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY ON
THE IMPACT OF THAT COLLUDED
-- UP ON SOME OF THE LOWER
CHIPS SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE I I KIND OF PUT THIS OUT
THERE IN TERMS OF HOW WE DO
A DIFFERENT KIND OF THAT TIME
HORIZON SO WE HAVE T.
TIME HORIZONS THAT WE PLANNED
FOR SO ONE IS THAT HE TO
HAD A TIME HORIZON WHICH IS
SPECIFICALLY USED FOR THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROCESS AND
WE WE HAVE A TEN YEAR TIME
FRAME WHICH IS USED FOR THE
TRANSMISSION PLANNING AND THE
IRP PROCESS SEES AND THEN WE
HAVE THE TWENTY FIVE HORIZON
PLANNING WHICH IS THE SB ONE
HUNDRED PLANNING SO ALL THREE
OF THEM HAVE TO BEGIN TO
HARMONIZE I THINK THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT MOVING FORWARD
EACH OF THEM THAT THINGS ARE
CHANGING VERY RAPIDLY BOTH ON
THE SUPPLY AND THE DEMAND SIDE
IN TERMS OF ELECTRIFICATION THE
TYPE OF LOS INSURED OBSERVING
SO THAT THE HARMONIZATION OF
THOSE THE HORIZONS IS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I I THINK IT'S
VERY WELL OBSERVED AS FAR AS --
THE SPECIFIC -- LOW CHIPS ARE
CONCERNED IN TERMS OF COLLUDED
RPGS WE -- HAVE -- THAT I AM
THE DATA AT THE INTERVAL METER
DATA THAT'S GOING TO BE COMING
INTO A CC -- IN THE NEXT MONTH
OR SO -- WE'VE PASSED AND THE
DATA REGULATIONS LAST YEAR WE
WE GET THE TOP FIVE -- CALYCES
AND METER DATA AND THAT NEITHER
DATA WILL BE USED TO UNDERSTAND
THE CHANGING PATTERNS AND
THE LOAD SHAPES AND AND THOSE
WILL BE USED AT THE TWO ACTIVE
MERGED WITH THE DEMAND FORECAST
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE LOTUS
CHANGING AN EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTY LEVEL THAT EXACT -- TO
-- THE COSBY IMPACT SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE HERE
REALLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AND
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO -- TAKE
IT OUT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF HISTORY ARE WE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST FIVE SIX MONTHS
AND WE GET A PLANE BAKED INTO
THE FORECAST -- THAT THAT'S
GONNA THAT TO ME MEETING WITH
ENGINEERED A SURGE OF POWER AND
THEN ONE LAST QUESTION SUPPORT
I JUST NEED TO RECORD YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT -- CHARGE WHICH
IS I'VE BEEN DRIVING LIKE TO
COVER THREE AND HALF YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA GOT A LOT I'VE NEVER
ONCE NOT BEEN ABLE TO CHARGE
BECAUSE AGREED HOURS ARE JUST
YOU KNOW POINT OUT WE ARE HERE
TODAY TALKING ABOUT -- ALL THIS
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
AUGUST BUT THAT WAS TWO AND A
HALF HOURS ON THE FOURTEENTH
AN HOUR AND A HALF ON THE
FIFTEENTH AND WE'RE -- YOU KNOW
GENERALLY SPEAKING IN THE GRID
-- ACTUALLY I BRISTLED WOULD
BE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD AND HAVE ALL THESE
COMPANIES COME LOOK AT HERE IF
THAT WERE THE CASE THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL REDUNDANCIES BEING
POLLUTED BY NUMBER THE V.
CHARGING COMPANIES INCLUDING
ONSITE STORAGE -- AND AND SOLAR
ONSITE WHICH YOU'RE SEEING
WE'VE ACTUALLY -- SOME COPIES
OF THE STANDALONE SOLAR BATTERY
STORAGE CHARGING STATIONS THAT
THE NEW COMPANY THAT'S BEEN
BUILT AND SO THAT ADDITIONAL
REDUNDANCIES IS -- GOING TO
PLACES WELL IN WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT I YOU MOSTLY MEET SOME
PEOPLE MAY HAVE HAD TWO OR
THREE HOURS BUT I HAVE FAMILY I
HAVE FRIENDS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
THAT HAD TO WIN THREE TWO DAYS
WITHOUT POWER WHO HAD ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WHO ARE OLDER AND I
I KNOW THAT FOR A FACT I DID A
BILL ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO OR
WE TRY TO PUT CHARGING WHERE WE
PUT CHARGING STATIONS SIGN PUT
CHARGING STATE ASK FOR CERTAIN
STATIONS IN AT PARKS AND
SCHOOL WE TRY TO GET SCHOOLS
COULDN'T GET SCHOOLS PARKS AND
BEACHES AND THOSE START THERE
SO THOSE REDUNDANCIES AREN'T
THERE YET IN ALL DUE RESPECT
AND THESE ARE OLDER INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE AN ELECTRIC CAR WHO
HAD NO POWER FOR TWO DAYS SO
THAT MAYBE YOUR REALITY AND
I'LL TELL YOU FOR SURE IF I
WAS IN MY COMMUNITY BY WERE
IN MY COMMUNITY THE REALITY IS
THERE WOULD BE NO REDUNDANCIES
NOT AT LEAST FOR AN HOUR AWAY
AND AS A MEMBER WHO'S BEEN
DRIVING BACK AND FORTH THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILES FROM
LA TO SACRAMENTO BECAUSE OF
KOBE I HAVE LEARNED THAT THINGS
CHANGE AND THINGS ARE DRASTIC
AND DIFFERENT NOW THAN THEY
HAVE BEEN OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS SO THAT'S JUST WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT AND THEN JUST ONE
MORE QUESTION -- SO FOR YOUR
PLANNING PROCESS HE'S I'M
JUST CURIOUS IS THERE ANYWAY
-- WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY KIND OF NEW
FORMULATION OF WHAT THAT'S
GOING THAT PROGRAM A LOOK
LIKE DO WE NEED TO CREATE SOME
FLEXIBILITY AS TO WHAT PEAK
IS BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE JUST AYE
IT SOUNDS LIKE PEOPLE IT JUST
DEPENDING ON WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN THE WORLD AND IN LIFE AND
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO GO BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD EVERY
TIME TO LOOK AT THAT PROGRAM
IS THERE A WAY TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT USED TO BE IN
THE MAIL TODAY THAT PEAK IS
NOW THREE TO NINE OR WHATEVER
IT IS AND THEN NOT ME I JUST
EXPAND OR WHATEVER IS THERE
IS THAT ON THE HORIZON IN THAT
PROGRAM GOING TO BE INTEGRATED
INTO THAT PROGRAM THAT'S MY
LAST QUESTION I'M AYE I THINK
IF I MAY I THINK THAT THE NET
PEAK IS FAIRLY DEFINED AT THIS
TIME I DON'T KNOW OTHER THAN ON
THE MARGINS WHERE THINGS WILL
ADJUST -- DEFINITELY CODED AS
YOU OF REMARKED AND CHANGED
SOME OF THE USAGE AND TIME
OF USAGE AND DEMAND UN WHERE
SOME OF THE LARGE COMMERCIAL
WENT DOWN HIGHER AND HIGHER
DEMAND WHAT HAPPENED SOME OF
THE RESIDENTIAL TIMES PLACES
AND TIME PERIODS -- BUT THE
THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY AYE AYE
AYE WE HAVE WE HAVE FLEXIBILITY
AND WE WE HOW WE MANAGE OUR
PROCEEDING IS IS THAT AND AND
WE CAN OBVIOUSLY BE CRITICIZED
AND HAVE BEEN AND WE CAN
CORRECT -- BUT I I THINK WE
HAVE THE THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
WE WE NEED AND WE CERTAINLY
AND IN WITH OUR SISTER EIGHT
WITH OUR SISTER AGENCIES --
WITH THE ADJUSTING THAT WILL
BE DONE WHEN FORECASTING SOME
OF THE MARKET -- REVIEW THAT
WILL TAKE PLACE I THINK WE WILL
HAVE A A MUCH BETTER -- OVERALL
VIEW AND UNDERSTANDING I THINK
SIVA JUST MENTIONED -- THAT WE
WILL BE GETTING THE METER DATA
INFORMATION SOON THAT WILL TELL
US EXACTLY -- WHAT OCCURRED
WITH DEMAND RESPONSE THAT WILL
BE VERY VERY IMPORTANT WE ALSO
NEED TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT RESOURCES DID SHOW UP --
UNDER THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PROGRAM WHO WHO BID IN AND WHO
DIDN'T THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
AS YOU KNOW THIS WAS THERE
ARE IN INTERMENT PORCH TO THE
GOVERNOR WE HAVE A FINAL REPORT
THAT WILL DO THAT WILL HAVE
MUCH MORE DATA AND AND FURTHER
ANALYSIS THAT WILL EACH ONE
OF US AND COLLECTIVELY WE WILL
WE WILL BE DOING THANK YOU
SOMERS THIRTY
I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM INGLEWOOD'S
A QUESTION ABOUT THE ELECTRIC
CAR YOU KNOW MY MY WIFE JUST
RECENTLY -- STARTED LEASING
-- A TESLA MODEL THREE --
BUT I KEEP MY TWENTY YEAR OLD
TOYOTA GAS CAR BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I I HAD SOME OF THE SAME
QUESTIONS WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
WHEN THE ELECTRICITY GOES OUT
IT AND SO I I I THINK YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THERE BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE ARE GOING TO STOP
SELLING -- GAS POWERED CARS
A GOES TO -- MR CUNNINGHAM'S
COMMENT ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW
THAT'S GONNA BRING ON THAT
WHOLE NEW -- CHARGING GRADE
AND SO I I THINK I I SUSPECT
THAT MIGHT BE ONE OF THE LAST
QUESTIONS BUT -- QUESTIONERS
BUT -- I WANT TO BRING IT BACK
TO YOU KNOW A THEME THAT I
HEARD MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
TALKED ABOUT THE SENSE OF
URGENCY THEY WERE FEELING YOU
KNOW WHAT THE WILD FIRES IT
WITH THE AIR POLLUTION THAT
CAME FROM THE WILDFIRES THAT
THAT THAT YOU KNOW HAS HAD THE
IMPACT ON OUR MOST VULNERABLE
OUR OUR CHILDREN IN OUR ELDERLY
SO -- YOU KNOW ALONG THE LINES
OF A OF A -- FEELING THAT THE
SENSE OF URGENCY I HAD A CHANCE
TO TALK WITH THE -- I I CLIMB
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE IS NOW
THE FIFTH LARGEST LOAD SERVING
ENTITY IN CALIFORNIA AND THERE
IS SOME -- SOME COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS THAT WERE WITH ME IN
PREPARATION FOR TODAY'S HEARING
ONE OF THEM IS THAT -- YOUR
REPORT RECOMMENDS THAT -- WE
INSURE THAT THEY GENERATION
AND STORAGE PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION
ARE COMPLETED BY THEIR TARGETED
ONLINE DATES BUT THEY'RE
EMPHASIZING THAT -- -- THAT
MANY LSE'S -- ARE -- READY
AND DEVELOPMENT FOR PROJECTS
BEYOND THOSE UNDER CONSTRUCTION
AND SO THEY'RE THEY'RE RAISING
THE CONCERN ABOUT HOW THE
AGENCIES WILL WORK TO GET
PROJECTS MOVING FASTER FOR
THE MOMENT THEIR SIGN NOT JUST
ONCE CONSTRUCTION BEGINS AND
SPECIFICALLY HOW WITH THE STE
HOW WILL THE STATE AND AND HOW
CAN THE THE LEGISLATURE HELP
IN EXPEDITING THE PERMITTING
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORTS REPORT PROCESS TO GET
THESE GENERATION AND STORAGE
PROJECTS -- BUILT UP WITH
THAT URGENCY THAT WE'RE ALL
FEELING AS AS I SAID SIR THANK
YOU AS I SAID AND WE HAVE ALL
AGREED WE DO SHARE AND FEEL
VERY RESPONSIBLE FOR AND THAT
URGENCY AND AS I MENTIONED IN
MY REMARKS -- WE HAVE TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED MEGAWATTS THAT ARE
COMING ON LINE BETWEEN NOW AND
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
-- WE ARE ALL RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING THAT -- THOSE PROJECTS
ARE COMPLETED WE WILL BE -- WE
ARE CURRENTLY AND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE WORKING WITH THE LSE'S TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ABSOLUTELY DO
IN TERMS OF THE PERMITTING --
THAT YOU MENTIONED MUCH OF THAT
AND I BELIEVE -- MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED THIS EARLIER SOME OF
THAT -- MOST OF IT IS A IS A
LOCAL ISSUE AND -- WE ARE --
WE ARE THE PC IS MONITORING ALL
OF THOSE ACTIVITIES EXTREMELY
CLOSELY AND AND WILL CONTINUE
SO IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT
IS CURRENT YOU KNOW THAT WE
REALIZE IS IS GOING TO --
SLOW A PROJECT IN TERMS OF
ITS DEVELOPMENT AND OUTCOME IN
THE TIME FRAMES THAT WE HAVE
SCHEDULED IT -- WE WILL --
INDEED BE WORKING WITH LOCAL
OFFICIALS -- TO ENSURE THAT
WHATEVER ROADBLOCKS EXISTS
-- THAT WE DO ALL WE CAN TO
-- MOVE THEM AND READ READ
THIS PROCESS OF THEM WE'RE
VERY AWARE OF THE CONCERNS
IS THERE A NEED FOR ANY
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO -- HELP
WITH EXPEDITING THE PERMITTING
AND THE I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
NOW CERTAINLY I THINK THAT
WOULD BE DIFFICULT FOR --
YOU'LL HAVE TO TALK TO SOME OF
YOUR LOCAL CAN HE'S BUT NO I
DON'T BELIEVE SO SIR OKAY --
MY COLLEAGUE -- FROM SAMBAR
DINO -- MENTIONED EARLIER
THE THE -- CONCERN ABOUT THE
EXPEDITING THE INTERCONNECTION
-- THE CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE
ALSO RAISES CONCERN WITH ME
WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT HOW --
THE THE -- THEY WANTED TO ASK
-- HOW CUTS CHI SO AND THE
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
DISTRIBUTION PROVIDERS --
CAN EXPEDITE INTERCONNECTION
AND AVOID THE INTERCONNECTION
DELAYS WHICH CAN SLOW DOWN
PROJECTS BY MONTHS OR MORE I I
I KNOW THAT THE QUESTION WAS --
RIGHT AND I'M GOING TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AROUND INTERCONNECTION -- I
KNOW WE'VE WORKED HARD ON THAT
AND I DO HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF
IN INFORMATION BEFORE ME SO I
WANT TO BE SPENT ON SPECIFIC
AND FACTUAL AND I WILL GET BACK
TO YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUE ON
THE INTERCONNECTION AND THE
TIME FRAME THAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW AND -- WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IN THE MOST RECENT --
PASSED TO ADDRESS THEM ALL
RIGHT LAST TO IN IN MY DISTRICT
-- IN THE SOUTH BAY AREA OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I HAVE ONE OF
THE NATURAL GAS PEAKER PLANTS
IN REDONDO BEACH AND -- YOU
KNOW WILD AGAIN -- MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER CUNNINGHAM REYES TO
POINT ABOUT HOW NOT ONLY ARE
WE CREATING NEW DEMANDS ON
ELECTRICITY GENERATION BUT
THAT WE ARE ALSO TAKING --
GENERATORS OFFLINE -- I KNOW
THAT THIS IS -- IN A PART OF
A THE PLAN THE STATEWIDE PLAN
THAT -- THAT ALL OF YOU ALL
ARE WORKING SO HARD BUT -- YOU
KNOW A FROM MY COMMITTEE SICK
I MEAN I I I WILL BE DOING MY
JOB IF I DIDN'T RAISE THE THE
CONCERN ABOUT HOW IN REDONDO
BEACH IN A WEEK WE HAD BEEN
PLANNING FOR TEN YEARS TO TAKE
THAT -- NATURAL GAS POWER PLANT
-- OFFLINE AND AND NOW -- THERE
THERE WAS A ONE YEAR EXTENSION
I BELIEVE THAT WAS EXTENDED FOR
THE REDONDO BEACH POWER PLANTS
YES HOW -- HOW RELIABLE IS
THAT ONE YEAR POWER PLANT HOW
TO HOW DO WE KNOW THAT TO THAT
IS NOT GOING TO BE EXTENDED
TO -- FOR MORE DOWN THE LINE
WELL YOU KNOW THAT THE -- THE
THREE OF US -- ASK FOR THAT
EXTENSION THAT WAS APPROVED
BY THE WATER BOARD -- AND IN
THAT IN WE WERE ASKED THAT
QUESTION AND WE SAID THAT --
WE FELT THAT THE ONE YEAR WAS
WAS ADEQUATE -- AND AGAIN IT'S
SOMETHING WILL HAVE TO MONITOR
BUT -- WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
COME BACK AND ASK ANOTHER TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WANTED
TO TO SORT OF RAISE A QUICK
QUESTION THAT I WOULD POST --
TO EACH OF YOU AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO TURN TO OUR OUR PUBLIC
FOR THEIR COMMENT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO I INTRODUCED A BILL
THAT ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF
REGIONAL LIES IN THE GROUND
AND ALLOWING FOR THE FOURTEEN
WESTERN STATES TO PARTICIPATE
IN A MORE EFFICIENT WAY AND
WHERE WE ARE IN A POSITION
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED WHEN THE
WIND IS NOT BLOWING HERE IT
MAY BE BLOWING IN OTHER STATES
AND WE CAN HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT -- POWER THAT'S PRODUCED
FROM WIND -- AND OTHER OTHER
STATES WHEN WE HAVE PRODUCED
IN EXCESS OF SOLAR THEN WE
BECOME AN EXPORTER AND WE
HAVE GREATER EFFICIENCIES THAT
WOULD BE DERIVED FROM THAT
AND ULTIMATELY COST REDUCTION
WHICH WE DON'T HEAR VERY
OFTEN IN TERMS OF IMPACT ON
RATEPAYERS JUST WANTED TO GET
YOU GET YOUR SENSE OF THINGS
BECAUSE AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PLANNING A LOT OF OUR PLANNING
AND CONCEPTS OF PLANNING IS
WITHIN OUR FOUR WALLS IF YOU
WILL -- TOUR EXPAND AND TO
HAVE AN INTERCONNECTED GRID
WITH FOURTEEN WESTERN STATES
PLANNING ON A LARGER -- BASIS
CREATES EVEN I WOULD IMAGINE
GREATER OPPORTUNITIES WHAT
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS AND ARE
WE FINDING OURSELVES GETTING
CLOSER TO A POINT IN TIME
WE'RE HAVING AN EXPANDED RATE
REGIONAL READ MAKES MORE SENSE
STEVE DO YOU WANT TO BEGIN
-- ALL ALL LEAN INTO THAT --
GIVEN MY MY HISTORY ON THIS
TOPIC AND THEN TURNED OVER TO
MY SUCCESSOR MISTER MAYNES OR
-- -- I BELIEVE -- REGIONAL
COLLABORATION -- IS CRITICAL TO
HOLDING DOWN COSTS AND IT CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY -- CONTRIBUTE TO
RELIABILITY IT TAKES FRICTION
OUT OF THE SYSTEM YOU'RE NOT NO
YOU'RE NO LONGER COMPETING WITH
ELECTRONS WITH OTHER BALANCING
AREAS AND OTHER STATES AND
-- IT ALSO GIVES YOU -- THE
ABILITY TO HAVE A PORTFOLIO
FACT VERTICAL WITH RENEWABLES
WHICH IS VERY POWERFUL AND
ALL NOTES -- PREVIOUSLY I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONCERN THAT
THE OTHER STATES ARE OUT OF
ALIGNMENT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
POLICY OBJECTIVES BUT PRETTY
MUCH MOST OF THE POPULATION IS
IN THE WEST KNOWS AND STATES
THAT ARE VERY ALIGNED WITH
CALIFORNIA'S DOING SO -- I
THINK THAT COLLABORATION IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD KNOW IS
I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME --
SEEING IT WITH THE EUROPEANS
ARE DOING THEY WERE ON A
EUROPEAN WIDE DAY AHEAD MARKET
-- TO DO EXACTLY WHAT I JUST
SAID IN ADDITION TO THAT THEY
COLLABORATE VERY WELL WITH
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS AS AN
EXAMPLE GERMANY HAS CONNECTED
WITH NORWAY TO USE OUR HYDRO
FLEET TO HELP INTERPRET
THE RULES THAT'S AN EXAMPLE
OF THE REGIONAL IMPACT THE
COLLABORATION AND I'M GONNA
LEAVE IT AT THAT AND AND
-- TURNED OVER BECAUSE THIS
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD ABOUT
IT WILL BE WITH MY SUCCESSOR
WELL THANK THANK YOU STEPHEN
AND CAROL I APPRECIATE YOU
ASKING THE QUESTION OBVIOUSLY
IS THE NEWCOMER HERE I HAVE
A LOTS OF LISTENING TO MUCH
OF LEARNING TO DO ON THIS
TOPIC -- PARTICULARS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'VE FIRST
BEEN OPERATING IN THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST FOR LAST SEVERAL
YEARS SINCE IT'S AN ISSUE
OF TRACK CAREFULLY CLOSELY I
THINK FOR ME FOR PURPOSES OF
CONVERSATION TODAY -- I THINK
THERE CERTAINLY ARE ARE LOTS OF
OF OF APPEALING OPPORTUNITIES
IN WIDE AREA COORDINATION
WHETHER IT'S IN THE STATE'S
SUBREGION REGIONAL CENTER
AND I THINK THE PHYSICS AND
THE ECONOMICS OF POWER SYSTEM
CERTAINLY LEND THEMSELVES TO
WIDER AREA SOLUTIONS BUT I
THINK IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION TODAY I THINK
YOU HEARD ME IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS SAY THAT THAT YOU KNOW
ACROSS THE WEST PARTICULARLY
IN CALIFORNIA IN OTHER IS IT'S
THE SAME CONVERSATION HAPPEN
THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST YOU'RE
GETTING RESOURCE ADEQUACY
AND INTEGRATED PLANNING AND
MARKET OPERATIONS WORKING
REALLY WELL IT'S JUST IT'S
JUST FOUNDATIONAL AND I THINK
THERE IS THIS THIS IS A MOMENT
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY AN INFLECTION POINT
FOR CALIFORNIA ON THE PATH TO
DO RELIABLY DECARBONISING ITS
GRID I AM GOING TO TAKE AWAY
FROM THIS CONVERSATION STAY
AT THE GENERAL SENTIMENT THERE
ISN'T THERE THERE'S INTEREST
THERE'S A SENSE OF URGENCY A
WILLINGNESS TO HELP A SENSE
OF SHARED ACCOUNTABILITY I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AND WE NOW HAVE THAT SENSE
OF URGENCY TO LEAN IN AND
GET THESE FOUNDATIONAL ISSUES
REALLY SORTED OUT BECAUSE
AS WE'VE SEEN THE WEST IS AN
INTERDEPENDENT MARKET TODAY WE
YOU KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT IMPORTS
AND EXPORTS BUT IN ORDER TO
BUILD THAT LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE
TOWARDS BROADER EXPANSION OF
OUR MARKETS WHETHER IT'S JUST
INSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WERE CHASING WE DO NEED TO
GET THESE ISSUES RIGHT AND I'M
VERY VERY PLEASED TO BE JOINING
THE TEAM HERE -- IN CALIFORNIA
WONDERFUL GROUP OF COLLEAGUES
TO WORK WITH ENGAGE LEGISLATORS
I THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THE CITIZENRY WHO CLEARLY CARES
DEEPLY ABOUT THESE ISSUES I
THINK THIS YEAR -- GOING INTO
NEXT SUMMER'S A REAL TEST FOR
ALL OF US IS YOU KNOW CAN WE
REALLY BRING THAT NEXT SET
OF SOLUTIONS TO THE TABLE
BUILD ON THE PROGRESS WE'VE
ESTABLISHED ALREADY CREATE
THAT SENSE OF URGENCY AND BE
SITTING HERE A YEAR FROM NOW
SAYING YOU KNOW WE REALLY DID
LEARN FROM THE EVENTS OF AUGUST
FOURTEENTH AND FIFTEENTH AND
RESULTED IN SOME SIGNIFICANT
STEP UP IN OUR ACTIVITIES AND
A LOT OF REALLY INTELLIGENT
CAPABLE AND COMMITTED PEOPLE
WITHOUT THE STATE WITH WITHIN
THE STATE CONTRIBUTING TO
THE SOLUTION SO WE GET THOSE
THINGS RIGHT AND I THINK WE CAN
REALLY TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
SOME OF THE BROADER QUESTIONS
ABOUT REGIONALIZATION I KNOW
THAT OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA --
FOLKS ARE WATCHING CAREFULLY
BOTH IN THEIR OWN IT SERVICE
TERRITORIES AND IN THEIR DAY TO
DAY INTERACTION WITH US AND I
THINK THEY'RE HOPEFUL THAT THIS
WILL BE A GOOD MOMENT WHERE
LESSONS ARE LEARNED AND WE
CAN WE CAN JUST TAKE POSITIVE
STEPS FORWARD SO CREATE THE
QUESTION MISTER CHAIRMAN YES
THANK YOU AND AND I AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS THAT -- THAT MY
COLLEAGUES FROM AYE SO HAVE
JUST MADE -- I I PERSONALLY
HAVE EVERY SUPPORTIVE OF
REGIONALIZATION BUT I SHOULDN'T
TALK ABOUT MY PERSONAL --
-- OPINIONS HOWEVER I THINK
THAT I'M SORRY RESIDENTS OKAY
-- I AGREE WITH WHAT L.
IT JUST SAID IN TERMS OF
GETTING ARE A WHICH REALLY
IS A SHORT TERM PLANNING
TOOL THAT WE HAVE AND THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
RIGHT -- BUT IT ONLY MAKES
LOGICAL SENSE TO ME THAT --
REGIONALIZATION IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
LOOK AT VERY CLOSELY AND
BECAME VERY CONSIDERATE OF --
HELLO ELECTRONS FLOW RATHER
FREE IN SOME SENSE -- ACROSS
OUR OUR STATE LINES AND I
THINK THAT -- CAL I SYSTEM A
LOT OF GOOD WORK IN THE LAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS AROUND
REGIONALIZATION AND IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE SOME OF THAT WORK
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD TO
THAT IS THAT THE TREND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN TOWARDS
REGIONALIZATION SO THE QUESTION
ISN'T WHETHER LEGALIZATION WILL
HAPPEN IN THE WEST IT'S WHETHER
CALIFORNIA WILL PARTICIPATE
IN THAT AND FOR THE REASONS
YOU MENTIONED -- WITH RESPECT
TO TO REDUCING RATES AND --
INSURING GREATER RELIABILITY
IN CONNECTION I THINK THERE
IS A REAL NEED TO EXAMINE
THANK YOU CONVERSATION
CONTINUES -- WE'RE GOING TO
TURN TO THE PUBLIC FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME -- I'M
LOOKING AROUND I DON'T THINK
THAT THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WHO IS HERE FROM THE
PUBLIC IF SO THAT WOULD BE THE
TIME SAYING NONE OF LET'S GO TO
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
IS THERE ANYONE AT ONE OF
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
THERE ARE NONE OTHER PHONE
LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT OUR PHONE MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE
LINE THAT WISHES TO COMMENT
YES SIR WE DO THINK YOU AND I
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCHTONE KEYPAD AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH A LIKE
NUMBER AND FURTHER ASSIST YOU
WELL OPEN MY NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE NUMBER IS NOW OPEN
FIND THE RETIREMENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY WE APPRECIATE
THE DEEP DIVE THE AGENCY THE
COMMITTEE UNDERTAKEN PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SHARE WITH
OUR ALLIES IN CALIFORNIA IN
THEIR BUSINESSES AND WE DO WANT
TO AMPLIFY THE AGENCIES IN THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD TAKE ACTION
TO ENSURE THE APPROPRIATE
NEXT TO REPURPOSE FEDERAL
TEAM WALLACE NO PROCUREMENT
ON THEIR WAY THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU
TO OPEN MY NUMBER THIRTY LINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
EIGHT THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN HELLO I'M SORRY MARK
COUNTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TURNS
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK WE --
AT HER APPRECIATE THE REPORT
THAT HAD COME OUT -- BECAUSE
THE NARRATIVE OF THE ROLLING
BLACKOUTS AND IN THE MEANTIME
WE THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT ARE UNANSWERED
AND WE HAVE ASKED THE STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO DO WITH
THE PHONE INVESTIGATION BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS THE
NEED FOR AN INDEPENDENT THIRD
PARTY TO ALL OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN ANSWERED
ONE OF THEM IS IN PARTICULAR
TO WHAT EXTENT DID MARKET
MANIPULATION I ENERGY TRADER
CONTRIBUTE TO THE SHORTAGE
OF GENERATION REPORT AND WITH
THE YOU KNOW FROM WHAT WE'VE
SEEN THE -- ELECTRICITY MARKET
PRICES SURGED IN SOME PLACES
TO ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER MEGAWATT HOUR ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED TIMES THE TYPICAL CLOCK
INDEED COP AND THAT BE PASSED
ALONG TO UTILITY CUSTOMERS
WE THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A THAT ALLOW WALL STREET
TRADER POPPED OFF THE BACK OF
CALIFORNIA RATEPAYERS IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CRISIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- MORE OF A
STATEMENT I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYONE WANTED TO PUT A FINER
POINT ON ANYTHING THAT YOU SAID
EARLIER THREE NINE -- PHONE
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
TO ADDRESSES FROM PUBLIC ON
THE QUITE A FEW STEPS TO
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI THIS IS PATRICK WELCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISSERTATION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT -- ELECTRICAL
LIABILITY OR KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON IT IS REALLY QUITE
IMPORTANT TO CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES -- THEY ARE
LOCALLY OWNED AND SERVE ABOUT
A QUARTER OF THE STATE AND
IT JUST WORKED MATCHING THAT
ABOUT A HALF OF THE STATE YOUR
USE ARE IN THE I.
F. SO COUNTING THE THIRTY AREA
NIKKEI'S GRANT UPPER OUTPUT
BUT STILL THE DESPITE THE GREAT
YEP TO SIMULTANEOUSLY WORK
TO REDUCE CUSTOMER USAGE BY
THE GREATEST DIVINE IN A WAY
THAT REQUIRES MUTUAL ACTION
AND ACCESSIBLE PEER USE WERE
DIRECTED TO SHUT OFF POWER ON
CUSTOMER THE OTHER PEER YOU'D
MISTAKE BUT ELECTRIC SERVICE
IN SEPARATE UNION BALCONY
THIRTY AND ONE HUNDRED YEARS
FROM NOW JUST NINETY UNIT DID
NOT HAVE TO RESORT TO CUTTING
OUT POWER I REALLY JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT GIVES A COPY
STRIKING THREE RELIABILITY PER
CUSTOMER OWNERS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND AT THE STATE LEVEL IT
IS CLEAR IN THIS HEARING ISSUES
ARE COMPLEX AND THE SOLUTIONS
WILL BE DEEPLY COMPLEX WE
AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENT THAT
DIDN'T EXPRESSED BY SEVERAL
THAT THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET
SOLUTION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING TOGETHER ON ACTIONS
TO ENSURE RELIABILITY AT THE
SAME TIME WE CONTINUE TO PURSUE
THE STATE'S NATION LEADING
CLINICAL AND REALLY PRESERVING
AFFORDABILITY WE THINK THAT
IS THE KEY ISSUE HERE DOWNTURN
ALL THESE DIFFERENT GOALS WITH
KEEPING ELECTRIC RATES ELECTRIC
BILLS AFFORDABLE AND AGAIN
THINK YOU'RE KIND OF PUTTING
THE HEARING TODAY THANK YOU
OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK YOU KAREN HOLDEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS JULIA PARK NEXT
AND I AM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LONG DURATION ENERGY
THIRTY THIRTY FOR CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING A DIVERSE MIX
OF LONG DURATION STORAGE
TECHNOLOGY AND PROJECT WE
BELIEVE THAT LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE IS CRITICAL TO
THE STATE BUILDING CAN MAINTAIN
LIABILITY AS WE WORK TO ACHIEVE
OUR NATION'S LEADING CLINICAL
WELL WE ARE ENCOURAGED BETTER
APART RECOMMEND IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO ENSURE NEW TARGET
SOURCES ONLINE BY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE MIGHT BE MORE THAT
INCLUDES BACKTRACKING STORAGE
PROJECT THAT WILL MEET OUR
NEEDS BEYOND NEXT YEAR AT OUR
SUPPLY CHALLENGES WILL ONLY GET
WORSE CONSIDER FOR EXAMPLE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAD RETIRED THOUSAND
TO MAKE A LOT OF NATURAL GAS
PRODUCTION AT THE PLANT CARE
THE DOUBLE CANYON NUCLEAR PLANT
THE LITTLE REPLACEMENT BUT I
CAPACITY THIS IS AT THE SAME
TIME THE GOVERNOR'S THEM HAS
DIRECTED MORE CORRECTIVE ACTION
TO ELECTRIFY TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM WHICH WILL SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE OUR TECHNIQUES TO
PREVENT FUTURE BLACKOUT AND
WE ARE CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
WE NEED NEW LOCAL AND SYSTEM
WIDE LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE SOLUTION SECOND
GOING TO BAT LARGE AMOUNTS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY BACK TO THE
GRID WHEN THE SUN GOES DOWN
OR THE WIND ISN'T BLOWING WE
ARE STATE AGENCIES AS THEY
WORK TO FINALIZE THE REPORT
TO PRIORITIZE A GREAT GAL
LONG DURATION STORAGE NEEDED
TO PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS
THERE TO PROBABLY PLAN AND
ACT NOW WILL BE BUT ONCE
AGAIN WITHOUT THE RESOURCES
WE NEED TO KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER TO HELP SOLVE THE
CRISIS THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU
AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
NINETY SIX ONE NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS NORA SHARE AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION OR
CREEK AT THE PRELIMINARY
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS REPORT
CONTAINING ERROR THAT LEAD TO
A MISREPRESENTATION OF DEMAND
RESPONSE AND PERFORMANCE
ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH AND
FIFTEENTH PARTICULARLY THE
BASE INTRACTABLE PROGRAM AND
RELIABILITY DEMAND RESPONSE
RESOURCES THE FIFTY STATES
RESOURCE ADEQUACY WEBPAGE HAVE
A SPREADSHEET THAT LISTS THE
REPORT ADEQUATELY CAPACITY
FOR THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS FOR
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY AND IT
SHOWS ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MEGAWATT YET THE
PRELIMINARY CARDINALITIES
REPORT LISTS THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITY DEMAND RESPONSE
PROGRAM AS ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN MEGAWATTS A
HIGHER NUMBER THE PRELIMINARY
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS REPORT AND
CONCLUDED THAT THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITY DEMAND RESPONSE
PROGRAM ONLY PERFORMED AT
ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF THEIR
RESEARCH ADEQUATELY CAPACITY
BAKER BELIEVES THAT THIS IS
MISLEADING AND WRONG AND --
PROPHETICALLY INVESTIGATED
AND CORRECTED AS NECESSARY
IN THE FINAL REPORT DEMAND
RESPONSE PERFORMANCE MEASURED
AT THE CUSTOMER LEADER AND
IT SHOULD BE BENCHMARKED AT
THE CUSTOMER METER THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND NEXT ALL WITH
MY APOLOGIES TO OPEN MY NUMBER
NINETY THREE EXCUSE ME --
MODERATOR PHONE BATTERY IF YOU
COULD JUST PAUSE FOR A MOMENT
I THINK WE'D LIKE TO WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT OF PC MAKE A COMMENT
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND -- THANK YOU REPRESENTATIVE
FROM CLICK A -- I WILL I'M A
FAMILIAR WITH THE NUMBERS THAT
YOU JUST GAVE ON THE MAKE A
LOTS THAT THAT -- FROM THE I.
O. USE I WILL LOOK INTO THAT
GET BACK TO YOU AND WE ARE
WAITING FOR SOME OF THE WHICH
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER -- BY
THE CDC WE ARE WAITING FOR SOME
OF THE METER DATA INFORMATION
SO WE CAN BETTER ANALYZE THE
DEMAND RESPONSE RESPONSE AND
I'M HAPPY TO AND LARA FIGHT
AND CORRECT IF NEEDED IN THE
FINAL REPORT AS YOU HAVE JUST
SUGGESTED AND WILL BE HAPPY TO
GET BACK TO YOU DIRECTLY BURGER
FOR MODERATOR PLEASE CONTINUE
THE THIRD NEXT OPEN
MY NUMBER NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI ALLI THE TRIO WITH REIMAGINE
POWER AND THE MICROGRID
RHETORICAL COALITION WHEN YOU
THINK BURKE THANK YOU TO THE
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT AGENCIES
FOR ALL YOUR WORK YOU'RE DOING
TO ATTRACT THE BLACKOUT ON
AND RESILIENCY IN CALIFORNIA I
KNOW THIS IS A VERY CHALLENGING
PROBLEM FOOTBALL -- I JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT SOMETHING
THAT I THINK WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE DIED EARLIER WHICH
IS THAT MY PROGRAM ACTUALLY
NEED TO RESTART MY PROGRAMS
THAT LEVERAGE FULL RENEWABLES
AND CLEAN FUEL CAN PROVIDE
LONG DURATION RESILIENCY
AND RELIABILITY CALIFORNIANS
MICROGRID CAN REDUCE THE
OVERALL DEMAND DOWN THE
CREDIT BROUGH LOAD MODIFYING
STRATEGIES THAT DEMAND RESPONSE
AND LIKE THE STRATEGIES THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTED WITH THE PORT
OF LONG BEACH AND THE MIRAMAR
MICROGRID GUARANTEED DIEGO --
BUT MICROGRID CAN ALSO PROVIDE
DISPATCHABLE CAPACITY WHEN
CALLED UPON IF THE RIGHT MARKET
MECHANISMS ARE IN PLACE SO IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR THE P.
YOU NEED TO FOCUS CREATING A
CUSTOMER MICROGRID CHARACTER
AND ALSO MODIFYING THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROGRAMS ALLOWED
TO BEHIND THE METER RESOURCE
WHICH PROVIDES THE PATH TO
BE ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE CONTACT WITH SHORTFALL
NOW AND THAT ARE EXPECTED IN
THE FUTURE GET BEEN CREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO REALLY EXAMINE
YOU PROGRAMS AND ACTIVATE YOUR
HOLLOW CUSTOMER REPORT THAT
AND PROVIDE GREATER RESILIENCY
RELIABILITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT FABIO THANK YOU
-- I'VE MISSED YOU CHAIRED
BY MAN YES I CAN RESPOND TO
PART OF THE COLORS -- COMMENT
AND THAT IS THE CURRENT THE
CUSTOMER CARE IF IT WILL BE
LOOK LOOK THAT IN PHASE TWO
OF THE MICROGRID -- PROCEEDING
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER SHIRANE IS
-- HEADING AND THAT DECISION
WILL BE COMPLETED BY THE END
OF THE YEAR AND I BELIEVE
THAT THEY YEAH THE PARTIES CAN
CERTAINLY -- PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROCEEDINGS VERY GOOD THANK
YOU THAT'S A GOOD INFORMATION
FOR THEM TO TAKE BACK WITH THEM
ONE MODERATOR PLEASE CONTINUE
Q. NEXT ALTHOUGH MY
NUMBER NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EVEN AFTER WITH
ARNOLD AND PORTER ON BEHALF
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POWER ABILITY CAPITAL BY
STREET CLEANING FINANCING
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION OF
TRANSMISSION AND GENERATION
PROJECT FOR ELEVEN MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES AND ONE YEAR TEACHING
DISTRICT CAPA MEMBERS WHICH
INCLUDE LADWP PASADENA BURNING
ANAHEIM AND OTHER THIRD MORE
THAN FIVE MILLION CUSTOMERS
ACROSS SEVEN THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES FIRST YOU'D LIKE TO
LEARN ARE COMMON WITH THOSE
MADE BY PATRICK WELCH FROM
YOU ANYWAY IN ADDITION WOULD
LIKE TO REITERATE OUR STRONG
BELIEF THAT CONSISTENT WITH THE
CHAIR'S REMARKS MADE PRIOR TO
HEARING ANY PROPOSED SOLUTION
BE DELAYED TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS IDENTIFIED IN THE
GROUP BECAUSE ABOUT THIS GOT
HIS NUMBER UTILITIES RANGING
BY THE NEED VERY GREATLY WHICH
IS WHY WE HAVE WORKED HARD
THAT INDEPENDENTLY ENTRIES
AFFECT YOUR ENERGY IN A WAY
THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE FOR
THEIR RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES
FOR THIS REASON CATHOLIC BOARD
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
OTHERS TO ENSURE RELIABILITY
IN A WAY THAT PRESERVES THE
ABILITY OF FUTURE ON THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES NEED
WHILE ALSO PROTECTING AGAINST
UNNECESSARY RATE INCREASES
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS MANY OF
WHOM ARE STILL STRUGGLING
TO PAY THEIR BILLS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK YOU AT THE AFTERNOON
AT THE JEFFERSONVILLE FROM
THE POWER AND TEMPLETON
COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE YOUR
BILL HOLDEN HEARING ON GIVING
UP THE CHANCE HE WAY IN DEMAND
RESPONSE AGGREGATOR ACTIVE
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND I WAS PLEASED
TO HEAR ABOUT SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION AROUND COMMANDED BY
THE DAY I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF DEMAND RESPONSE AVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN AND QUITE
LIKELY NOT FULLY HARNESS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE TECHNOLOGY AND
THE WILLINGNESS AMONG CUSTOMERS
OF ALL SIZES SACRAMENTO
AIRLINES EXAM WITHIN THE STATE
AND WE THINK THAT THAT HURDLE
AND BE SMART AND THEY ARE ON
THE ON THE REGULATORY SIDE
AND A LOT OF BEHIND THE METER
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
RESEARCH ADEQUATE THE MARKET
POWER OF EACH OF THE GRANT AND
ARE GOING TO THE ARMY PROGRAM
WE'VE SEEN EMAIL HARD TO
PRACTICE THE QUALIFYING COUNTY
THREE FORCES AND HAPPENED
THESE RESOURCES PARTICIPATIONS
RIGHT AT THE TIME BUT I THINK
IT BECOME VERY CRITICAL THAT
WE HAVE LETTING GAVE THE HELP
FILE THEM AND DEFINING THE
STATE MORE THAN IT IS TODAY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING
IN AN OPERATING AND KEPT AN
EXPANDED THREE POINT AND AND
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S RELIABLE
AND THAT BEING SAID WE DO THINK
THAT THERE ARE THINGS THAT CAN
BE DONE QUICKLY IN TERMS OF
PROCUREMENT AND STREAMLINING
RULES WE WANT IT TO BE VERY
RELIABLE REFI I THANK YOU
HAPPENED BEARD HOWEVER THAT
THE STATIC ON THE PHILIPPINES
RESOURCES IN THE STATE HI
BLACK WANTING PERFECTION BE
THE ENEMY THE AT THE GLADE IN
TERMS OF THEIR PROLIFERATION
AND TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH EVERYONE K.
INTERMEDIARY SECTOR
GOING FORWARD AND THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME TODAY
THANK YOU
OPEN MY NUMBER SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CISCO
TO REFUND THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANY --
CONNECT FLEXIBLE DEMAND AND
DEMAND RESPONSE -- REALLY
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
RESPONDING TO THE UNPRECEDENTED
HEAT STORMS DURING AND THE
GREAT CRISIS -- THAT TOOK PLACE
THIS SUMMER BOTH IN AUGUST
AND THEN SEPTEMBER THAT YOU
HEARD FROM -- JIM HELP SHIELD
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAME HOME
CONNECTED THE COMPANY WITH
VERY ACTIVE -- FOR EXAMPLE
DURING AUGUST BUCKLER TO ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA HOME CONNECT
CUSTOMERS VOLUNTARILY REDUCE
THEIR ENERGY USE BY A COMBINED
ONE GIGAWATT HOUR -- AND THEN
WE WERE ABLE TO TURN AROUND
AND PAY THOSE CUSTOMERS ONE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THEIR ENERGY REDUCTION WE
THINK THE KIND OF CONNECTION
BETWEEN -- ACTION AN INCENTIVE
IS CRITICAL AND WE SUBMITTED
COMMENTS WITH DETAIL THAT THE
NATIONAL POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
IN WRITING I APPRECIATE THE
TO BE HONEST CRISIS LEADERS
AND STUFF ALL THREE OF THE
ENERGY AGENCIES HAVE BEEN VERY
ACTIVELY ENGAGED AND HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE THE REGULATORY AND
POLICY HURDLES THAT HAVE BEEN
IN THE WAY OF DEMAND RESPONSE
FLEXIBLE DEMAND -- GROPED
AND WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD
TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY IN TIME FOR THE NEXT
SUMMER NOW WE HOPE TO BE PART
OF THE SUCCESS STORY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE -- AND APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT AND TIME THAT
GOING INTO MAKING THAT HAPPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DOUG SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION C.
MTA REPRESENTS MANUFACTURERS
OF ALL SIZES EVERYONE OF
WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT
CONSUMER OF ENERGY INCLUDING
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS
THE MANUFACTURING SECTOR PLAYS
A KEY ROLE IN THE STATE'S
ENERGY SYSTEM THAT RELIES
HEAVILY ON AFFORDABLE AND
RELIABLE ENERGY DURING THE
ROTATING OUTAGES IN AUGUST I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO CUMBER
CHAMPION AMBER STEPPED UP
INVOLUNTARILY AND PROACTIVELY
REDUCE LOAD PARTICIPATE IN
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORTED THE GRID USING ONSITE
GENERATION WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE DISCUSSING THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES TODAY WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING THE PRELIMINARY
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IN DETAIL
BUT WANTED TO BRIEFLY SHARE
THREE POINTS WE ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE AND REGULATORS
TO FOCUS ON THE NEED TO
ENSURE LITERACY FOR ALL BREAK
THEIR CLASSES INCLUDING THE
INDUSTRIAL CLASS IS RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE ELECTRICITY
IS A SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR
INDUSTRIAL RATEPAYERS AND
IT IS IMPERATIVE WITH FOCUS
ON AFFORDABILITY TO MAINTAIN
MANUFACTURING COMPETITIVENESS
WE ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
AND REGULATORS TO FOCUS ON
POLICIES TO SUPPORT A DIVERSE
SUITE OF RESOURCES INCLUDING
NATURAL GAS POWER GENERATION
THAT ARE PORTABLE AND RELIABLE
THROUGHOUT ALL HOURS OF THE
DAY WE WANT TO COMMITTEE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO -- WE WANT
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO ON EFFORTS
TO ENSURE THE DEMAND RESPONSE
PROGRAMS ARE FISHING WORKABLE
FOR INDUSTRIAL USERS ENSURE
THAT INDUSTRIAL USERS THAT
GENERATE POWER ON SECOND LET
ALONE WITH THE LIABILITY AND
WORK TO ENSURE THE INDUSTRIAL
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS
ARE REFORM SO THAT THEY ARE
AVAILABLE TO MANUFACTURERS
OF ALL SIZES WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
ADMINISTRATION AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THAT POLICIES ARE
DESIGNED TO BE AFFORDABLE
AND RELIABLE WHILE REACHING
THE STATE SCHOOLS THANK YOU
THANK YOU
ALTHOUGH MY NUMBER ONE OH THREE
ONE ONE A THREE YEAR LINE IS
NOW OPEN MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THERE ANYMORE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL
NOT DEMAND MANAGEMENT PROVIDED
A LEGAL WANT THE POWER DURING
THE RECENT AUGUST CRISIS AND
I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD TODAY
ABOUT THE -- CONNECTED TO
POWER EXAMPLE -- HE BELIEVES
THAT THE MANAGEMENT HAS HAD
NOT ONLY DEMONSTRATED QUALIFY
THE QUANTIFIABLE ABILITY --
TO WOULD BE BORROWED -- BUT
THAT IT HAS THAT SAME TYPE
OF POTENTIAL AND TO WE COULD
JUST QUICKLY RECOMMENDED FOR
ACTIONS BE TAKEN IN THE NEAR
TERM -- CAN MAKE IT MORE
AFFORDABLE AND EASILY ALIVE BY
COMING OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
FIRST WOULD BE A CLEAR DEMAND
TARGET WE WOULD RECOMMEND
FIVE PERCENT THE SECOND WOULD
BE TO ELIMINATE THE CURRENT
PROCUREMENT CAP ON THE RESOURCE
THE THIRD WOULD BE TO RESTORE
THAT DEMAND RESPONSE OPTION
MECHANISM BUDGET AND THEN THE
FOURTH WOULD BE -- TO OVERHAUL
SENATORS WHO ARE AT THE PC FOR
VERIFYING -- AND QUANTIFYING
THE RESOURCE THANK TOO MUCH
THE HEARING TODAY THANK YOU
THAT COULD ALTER MY
NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
DANIEL A CORNELL ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT TODAY I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION IN THE COMMITTEE
UNDERSCORING THE NEED FOR A
PLAN FOR A RELIABLE EQUITABLE
DECARBONISATION BUT WE ARE
HELPING YOU KNOW WORK WITH
GLOBAL LEADERS IN UTILITY
SCALE WIND BOTH LAND BASED
AND OFFSHORE AS WELL AS
DEVELOPERS OF SOLAR STORAGE
AND TRANSMISSION ALONG WITH
OTHER CLEAN ENERGY EKELER --
WE HAVE BEEN SOUNDING THE ALARM
OF THE CURRENT PLANNING AND
PROCUREMENT REGIME FOR SEVERAL
YEARS -- AND SHAREHOLDING
IF YOU'LL RECALL IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
YOU AUTHORED TWO BILLS
THAT WOULD HAVE EXPEDITED
PROCUREMENT OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
OPTIMIZED THE AVAILABILITY
OF FEDERAL TAX CREDIT AND TO
BRING RESOURCES ONLINE THE
THIRD CALIFORNIA'S INCREASING
APPETITE FOR CLEAN ENERGY AT
THE TIME IT WAS CONSIDERED
EARLY PROCUREMENT AND WITH MATT
WITH CONCERNS FROM THE AGENCY
ABOUT THE RISK THAT IT COULD
LEAD TO OVER PROCUREMENT BUT
PERHAPS TIMELY WOULD HAVE BEEN
A BETTER WORD -- HERE HOLDING
WE APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO ADVANCE THE DISCUSSION ON
REGIONAL COORDINATION AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO MORE DISCUSSION
OF REGIONAL COLLABORATION TO
ENSURE AND ENHANCE RELIABILITY
ADVANCED THE CARBONIZATION AND
MINIMIZE RATE FOR CALIFORNIANS
-- AND WE SHARE THE DESIRE
TO BE THE JOINT AGENCY
PLAN FOR RELIABLE EQUITABLE
DECARBONISATION I WANT TO
INTRODUCE THE COMMERCIAL
ELEMENT THE CONVERSATION
NOW THE STATE MUST BUILD
COMMERCIAL REALITIES AND TIME
LINES INTO THE PLAN AND THE
PROCESS AGENCIES NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER AND THE LEGISLATURE
NEED TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
CUTTING CALIFORNIA PERFECT IN
PARTICULAR THE JOINT AGENCIES
AND PAY SO NEED TO CONTEMPLATE
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT AND
LAND FOR PROCUREMENT PERMITTING
FINANCING CONSTRUCTION AND
INTERCONNECTION IN THESE
PROCESSES -- AND ARGUE THE PLAN
NEEDS TO CONSIDER ACTIVATED
PROCUREMENT PERMITTING AND
INTERCONNECTION OF A DIVERSE
SUITE OF SHOVEL READY RENEWABLE
ENERGY PROJECTS THAT CAN COME
ONLINE IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS INCLUDING ZERO
CARBON RENEWABLE CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED POWER IN
THE EVENING HOURS WE DON'T
NEED TO LOOK AT INTERAGENCY
COORDINATION OF PROCUREMENT
TO ELIMINATE ANY REMAINING
UNCERTAINTY IN THE MARKET AND
START TO MOVE FORWARD ON THE
PACE THAT'S NECESSARY AND PLAN
FOR TRANSMISSION AND LONG LEAD
TIME BY THANK RESOURCES LIKE
OFFSHORE WIND TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE GETS OUT OF THE NEED
TO BRING YOUR NOBLE CAPACITY
ONLINE AND SEND A CLEAR
MARKET SIGNALS AND ATTRACTING
INVESTMENT EIGHT THANK YOU
ALL AGAIN FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO RELIABILITY CLEAN ENERGY
AND EQUITY WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU ON
THE DEVELOPMENT AND EXECUTION
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY PLAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ENACT OPEN LINE NUMBER
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THE NEW NUMBER ONE MY
NAME IN THE MONEY MARKET
DEVELOPMENT OUR EIGHT METERS
IN CALIFORNIA MADE CLEAN
ENERGY INNOVATOR INTERMISSION
INTEGRATING NEXT GENERATION
AND THE KIND OF MARKET A GREAT
PRACTICE AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE BEST WAY TO GET TO THE
BILLION YEAR CARBON FUTURE
QUICKLY INTERNATIONAL YOU
KNOW LIKE THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN NINE POINT THREE PERCENT
ACTUALLY IF YOU WAIT FOR
OTHERS TO COME ONLINE THEY
ARE VERY ACTIVE DURING THE
HURRICANE HEAT IN THAT OR
DELIVERY TECHNICIAN LEAD AND
A NUMBER OF OTHER COMPANIES
THAT YOU HEARD A CRUCIAL
ROAD WELL IN KEEPING A LIKE
TO ENSURE THAT YOUR CONTINUE
TO GROW AND HELP OUR STATE
LEADERS TO TAKE INCREASE YOUR
BUDGET BERMAN WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH EVERYONE CAN
INCREASE THE FLEXIBILITY AND
BILLION CALIFORNIA'S GREAT
THANK YOU
WELCOME MY NUMBER ONE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
YES MY NAME IS CHUCK LOS ALAMOS
RESIDENT OF OAKLAND IN THE WAKE
I WANTED TO CALL IN TO TO POINT
OUT THAT DURING THE RECENT
BLACKOUT WELL CCA'S CURRENTLY
SUPPLY FORTY FIVE PERCENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOAD -- THEY
HAD A PROBLEM THERE PROJECTIONS
THAT I BELIEVE WHAT THE REPORT
DEMONSTRATES IS THAT THE UNDER
REPORTED ABOUT SEVENTY PERCENT
WHICH INDEED POTENTIALLY COSTLY
SUBMISSIONS WITH RESPECT TO
THE RESPONSE THE PRIMARY REASON
FOR THAT IS GOOD THAT THE CCH
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE ACCESS
TO THE REAL TIME DATA THAT
THEY NEEDED ONE WHICH IS ALSO
REQUIRED THE UTILITIES PROVIDER
BUT I WANTED TO ASK YOU THAT
WILL KEEP YOU SEE INSURE THAT
THE SITUATION GETS RECTIFIED
SO THAT IN THE FUTURE IF
SHE'S HERE TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF PROTECTING THEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU I WILL I WILL
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT
QUESTION AND WILL CLARIFY
IN THE FUTURE BURGER
FROM MODERATOR THE
NEXT -- COMMENT
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION VERY APPRECIATIVE
WHO CARE AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
FOR THE HEARING AND WANTED TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT WE HAVE
AN EXISTING REPORT THAT IS
NOT CURRENTLY BEING USED THAT
COULD HELP THE STATE -- AVOID
THE KIND OF PROBLEMS THAT
WE HAD IN AUGUST AND THAT IS
BATTERIES BETTER IN PEOPLE'S
HOMES AND BUSINESSES WHO HAVE
EXISTING SOLAR PANELS AND
THE BATTERIES CAN BE HARD IT
WOULD BE USED NOT JUST FOR
THE OWNER OF THAT BATTERY BUT
ON CERTAIN DAYS BUT IF THE
OWNER AGREED TO HELP OTHER
I REPEAT OUR EYES OF AUGUST
OF THE YEAR WE IN CALIFORNIA
HAD OVER A THOUSAND MEGAWATT
HOURS BEHIND THE METER ENERGY
TOWARD THEM RIGHT BETWEEN NOW
AND NEXT SUMMER THE INDUSTRY
OF ON FACING INSTALLING OTHER
FIVE HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND
MEGAWATT HOURS NOW WITH THE
FAVOR TO PRIORITIZE REMIND
PERMITTING AVOID ANY SNACKS
WITH ACTIVE PROGRAMS AND
A HUNDRED THE POWER OF THE
BATTERIES WERE VIRTUAL POWER
PLANT POLICY IF AND IF IF THEY
WERE TO SIGNAL A COMMITMENT
TO AND CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
BEHIND THE METER ENERGY BURDEN
YOUNG HUNDRED TWENTY ONE YOU
COULD NOT ONLY ENSURE THAT
WE BUILD A DIFFERENT CAPACITY
BUT WE COULD ALSO INCREASE OUR
ACTIVITY AND HELP THE STATE
COMPARE DR FOR SUMMER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT FOR THE COMING
DECADE WE URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
I BELIEVE IF YOU GO FORWARD AND
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR THE
HEARING ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AS A REMINDER IF YOU LIKE
TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCHTONE KEYPAD
IN AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LIGHT NUMBER
NEXT OPEN LIKE NUMBER ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HELLO THIS IS GREG HONOR ON
BEHALF OF SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC
NORTH AMERICA I JUST WANT
TO AND NOTE WE ARE MENTIONED
WITH DURING THE HEARING THAT
MICROGRID NEED A DIVERSE SET OF
ENERGY INPUT INCLUDING HYDROGEN
AND BIOGAS IF THE RIGHT RULES
WERE IN PLACE OVER THE LAST
YEAR'S BE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
CHEN THAT THAT WERE DEPLOYED
FOR PS PS IN WILDFIRE AND COULD
HAVE BEEN MICROGRID THIS MEANS
THAT YOU NEED TO ADDRESS RIGHT
AWAY DEPARTING LOW CHARGES
AND HAIR APOSTOLIC GRADING
THE DEPLOYMENT OF MIRAMAR
AND MICROGRID KEEP IN MIND IT
BEING PENALIZED BY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR DEPARTING THOSE
CHARGES WERE FOR MICROGRID
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT THE ENTIRE
CREATED IN REAL TIME HE ROLLED
NEED NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
PROPERLY AND QUICKLY IF WE'RE
GOING TO MEET OUR NEEDS NEXT
SUMMER AND FOR THE FUTURE
THANK YOU CRESCENTA
BOTHERING HER
YES WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
OF OPPORTUNITIES IN LINE
TO ASK A QUESTION PROVIDE
A PUBLIC COMMENTATOR
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
PHONE MODERATOR BIPOD
I'D BE DO YOU HAVE TO HOW
MANY OTHER HOW MANY MORE
PUBLIC COMMENT SPEAKERS
DO YOU HAVE IN THE QUEUE
CURRENTLY TO OKAY SO
WE'LL TAKE THEM NOW
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THAT'S OPEN MY NUMBER
ONE -- FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN YEAH HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS SCOTT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION UTILITY EMPLOYEES THE
STATE ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL IN THE WEST
UC'S COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS WE FOUND IT REALLY
THERE'S NOTHING IDENTIFIED IN
THE ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS THAT
HAS NOT BEEN KNOWN FOR YEARS
WELCOME IT'S POOR PLANNING AND
FORECASTING AND THE FACT THAT
THERE IS NO SINGLE ENTITY IN
CHARGE OF RELIABILITY THE STATE
IN ARGUE IS IN REAL TROUBLE AND
THERE'S NO SHORT TERM SOLUTION
THE ONLY WAY OUT IS ADDRESSING
OUR LONG TERM RELIABILITY AND
BUILDING OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
PROBLEM THROUGH INCREASED
CAPACITY BUT THAT WILL TAKE
LARGEST BEST INVESTMENT THAT
MUST START IMMEDIATELY WHAT
I'VE HEARD TODAY IS THAT
THERE'S TOOLS UNDER DEVELOPMENT
PLANS ARE BEING PLANNED IN
WORKSHOPS ARE BEING SCHEDULED
AND THAT NOW WE HAVE A SENSE
OF URGENCY THE FACT IS WE
NEED TO INVEST IMMEDIATELY IN
PROJECTS LIKE PUMP STORAGE THEY
CAN PROVIDE A LARGE AMOUNT OF
ENERGY WITHIN SECONDS TO MEET
SYSTEM CONDITIONS THERE IS NO
SCENARIO WOULD PUMP STORAGE
ISN'T THE RIGHT SOLUTION TO
THE PROBLEMS IDENTIFIED IN
THE ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS GET
THE STATE ACTED NOW THE EAGLE
MOUNTAIN PUMPED STORAGE PLANT
COULD BE ONLINE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TO COINCIDE
WITH THE DECOMMISSIONING OF
THE APPLE CANYON PROVIDING
THIRTEEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
MUCH NEEDED INERGY RELIABILITY
FOR CALIFORNIANS WE WOULD
URGE ALL THREE OF THE CITY'S
TO REDOUBLE THEIR EFFORTS
GIVEBACK RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
FOR PROCUREMENT -- IF NOT IN
THIS CALENDAR YEAR IN THE FIRST
QUARTER OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- HERE
TO SAY THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS DID NOT
PUT ITS FINGER ON THE SCALE AND
ANYONE PARTICULAR SECUREMENT
ROGER -- THERE WAS CERTAINLY
TODAY A LOT OF EXCUSE ME A LOT
OF QUESTIONS AROUND PARTICULAR
PROJECTS OR PARTICULAR TYPES
OF PROJECTS AND CERTAINLY
PUMP STORAGE IS COME UP A
NUMBER OF TIMES AND I THINK
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A REALLY
CLEAR CLEARLY ESTABLISHED BY
CERTAINLY PRESIDENT OF CBC AND
OTHERS THAT THAT IS IN THE MIX
IT'S PART OF THE THE PLANNING
AND PART OF THE -- THE THOUGHT
PROCESS YES -- ENOUGH YES YES
SIR THAT'S RIGHT I MENTIONED
THAT EARLIER THAT IS ONE OF
THE ELEMENTS IN OUR IN OUR
-- RESOURCE ADEQUACY PLANS
YES PUMP STORAGE OUR PHONE
MODERATOR OUR LAST SPEAKER
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU SHARE
HOLDEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS NANCY
KIRSHNER RODRIGUEZ ON THE
WESTERN DIRECTOR FOR THE
BUSINESS NETWORK FOR OFFSHORE
WIND WE ARE A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD BEEN
WORKING ON THE OFFSHORE WIND
ISSUE FOR A DECADE NOW AND WE
ARE WORKING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE WESTERN STATES
IN COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND I JUST I'M
I WOULD BE GLAD TO HEAR THE
COMMENTS TODAY ABOUT POPULAR
WIND AND I THINK I JUST WANT
TO QUICKLY EMPHASIZED THAT
WOULD BE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO HAVE A ROBOT BOB IRWIN
NETWORK WHICH COULD PROVIDE
UTILITY SCALE POWER -- IN THIS
STATE THERE NEEDS TO BE LONG
TERM PLANNING AND IN FACT THAT
AND I CAN'T URGE YOU ENOUGH
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS RIGHT
NOW AND WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
ALL OF US TO IDENTIFY WAYS
FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE A LEADER
IN GLOBAL OPS OR WIN WE ARE
VERY BEHIND ON RIGHT NOW ON
THE OPPORTUNITY AND FLOATING
OFFSHORE WIND IS THE NEW FOCUS
FOR MANY EUROPEAN AND ASIAN
NATION AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
AFFLUENT WOMEN THAT COULD TRULY
-- PROVIDE THAT WITH A WAY TO
SECURE OUR -- RELIABILITY IN
THE FUTURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR MODERATOR OF WAS THAT
OUR OUR LAST PUBLIC COMMENT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO MOURN CUTER
OKAY OKAY MY NUMBER AND WE
WILL CUT IT OFF AFTER THESE TWO
THANK YOU SIR THE NEXT OPEN
MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AT THE
TELLING POINT WITH OFFSHORE
WIND CALIFORNIA -- JUST WANTED
TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH FIRE
COMMENT ON -- THE NEED TO
INCLUDE OPTIONAL NGUYEN IN LONG
TERM PLANNING BUT STRESSED THAT
A LOT OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY
IS THAT WE NEED -- A RESILIENT
A WELL BALANCED GOD CREATED
THE RESILIENT WRITTEN WELL
DOLLARS RESOURCES WILL HELP
REDUCE COSTS ON TO CUSTOMERS
AND WILL SUPPORT THE LIABILITY
-- WE NEED NEW TRANSLATION
WE NEED TO DO BETTER LONG
TERM PLANNING FOR RESOURCES
BUDGET OFFICE FOR NGUYEN --
AND -- PEOPLE BALLOT WELL
WITH DISTRIBUTED GENERATION
WITH STORAGE -- WITH ALL
THESE OTHER RESOURCES TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA MUCH MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENT AT THE SAME TIME
WHICH SHOULD BE A CONSIDERATION
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
RETORTED THAT ARE GOING TO
AID WITH CLIMATE RESILIENT
AS IT BECOMES INCREASINGLY A
FACTOR THAT IMPACTS RELIABILITY
AND WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD
THAT THINGS LIKE HYDROGEN
STORAGE -- WELL PREPARED
RECOLLECTED LIKE OPTIONAL WIND
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND OUR LAST LINE WILL
COME FROM LINE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HELLO THANK YOU THIS IS DANIEL
GOLDIN PRESIDENT OF COMMUNITY
CHOICE PARTNERS -- THE
PRELIMINARY REPORT CORRECTLY
IDENTIFIED THE PROBLEM THAT
THE UNDER SCHEDULING OF LOAD
BY SCHEDULING COORDINATORS YOU
CAN UTILITIES AND DIRECT ACCESS
CENTER AT THE DETRIMENTAL
EFFECT NOT THE NOT THE
ENERGY MARKET APPROPRIATELY
REFLECT THE ACTUAL NEED ON
THE SYSTEM AND SUBSEQUENTLY
SIGNALING THAT MORE EXPORTS
WERE ULTIMATELY THE PORTABLE
FROM INTERNAL RESOURCES
UNFORTUNATELY THE PRELIMINARY
REPORT DOESN'T DETAIL WHY
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES IN
CALIFORNIA COLLECTIVELY FAILED
TO ACCURATELY FORECAST YOUR
RETAIL CUSTOMERS ELECTRICITY
USAGE BUT I THINK I CAN OFFER
DEEPER INSIGHT ON THAT SUBJECT
I'M GOING TO ECHO WHAT CALPERS
DEL HAD EARLIER ALMOST EVERY
RETAIL CUSTOMER IN CALIFORNIA
HAS THE SMART METER YOUR RECORD
HOW MUCH ELECTRICITY BEING
USED ON AN HOUR EARLIER IN THE
DEBATE THAT DATA IS EXTREMELY
VALUABLE IN TERMS OF ENHANCING
THE ACCURACY OF SHORT TERM
LOCAL FORECAST THAT'S WHY
THE UTILITIES COLLECT AND USE
THAT DATA TO REFRESH THEIR OWN
FORECAST OF THE ELECTRICIAN
THE DEMAND PATTERNS THREE OR
FOUR TIMES EVERY DAY HOWEVER
THE UTILITIES DO NOT PROVIDE
ACCESS TO THIS DATA IN A
TIMELY FASHION FOR COMMUNITY
TOWARD AGGREGATORS USE IN
THEIR TYPES OF DEBT MARKET
GLOBAL FORECAST TO CONSEQUENTLY
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATORS
THEIR FORECASTS ARE BEING
SYSTEMATICALLY DISADVANTAGED
INTEGRATED IN TERMS OF ACCURACY
THIS IS CONTRARY TO LAW AB --
SB SEVEN NINETY WITH WOULD BE
REQUIRED UTILITIES TO PURGE
THIS DATA BUT THEY JUST HAVEN'T
BEEN DOING THE COMMISSION AT
HALF TO ENSURE THAT THE AID AT
THE DATA NECESSARY TO PRODUCE
ACCURATE SHORT TERM LOAN
FORECAST IN OTHER WORDS THEY
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WE START
ACTUALLY USING OUR SMART METERS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE INTENDED
SO IN CONCLUSION I THINK
THIS MIGHT THIS ASPECT OF THE
PROBLEM MIGHT BE ONE OF THOSE
RARE SITUATIONS IN WHICH A
COMPLEX PROBLEM HAS A VERY EASY
SOLUTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
I I THINK THAT THE THE POINT
-- WE WE RECEIVE THAT AND WILL
LOOK TO SEE IF YOU SEE TO --
REVIEW ALL OF THE COMMENTS NOT
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF THOSE WHO
HAVE GIVEN THEIR COMMENTS TODAY
TO THE PUBLIC -- VEHICLE AND
AND CERTAINLY PHONE MODERATOR
THANK YOU -- YOU CAN CLOSE THE
LINE WE WILL TAKE ALL OF THOSE
COMMENTS AND AND MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE ARE CHANNELED TO EVERYONE
WHO HAS THE JURISDICTION
OVER AN ANSWER AND IF I COULD
I'D LIKE TO ALSO ADD IN THE
COMMITTEE REPORT THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
-- SOME OF THEM WERE TOUCHED
ON TODAY AND SOME WERE NOT
SO IF WE CAN ENTRUST YOU WITH
THE QUESTIONS AND IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE SOME ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS OVERHEARD A TIME WE
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT -- THANK
YOU THIS RACE FOR HANG IN THERE
WITH ME ALL THE WAY TO THE
END -- I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE COME OUT
TODAY THIS IS YOU KNOW WITHOUT
DOUBT -- VERY DIFFICULT SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE ALL HAD
TO DEAL WITH AND BACK IN AUGUST
WHEN IT WAS ALL HAPPENING REAL
TIME IT WAS A LOT OF PRESSURE
ON ALL OF US TO RESPOND TO OUR
COLLEAGUES IN TERMS OF WHAT
WAS HAPPENING OF THIS COMMITTEE
OBVIOUSLY HAVING JURISDICTION
OVER THESE TYPES OF ISSUES AND
SO -- WITH EVERYTHING SORT OF
EVOLVING IN A IN A WAY THAT
WE WERE STILL TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO NOT TO CONTROL OR
DIZZINESS FROM HOW QUICKLY
WERE SPENDING -- WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
TIME ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S DIRECTION TO
HAVE THIS ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS
ESTABLISHED -- IT WOULD GIVE
US AT LEAST OF -- A FOUNDATION
TO HAVE A HEARING LIKE THIS AND
SO WE WOULD NOT WE WOULD WOULD
BE A LITTLE MORE ORGANIZED
AND THOUGHTFUL IN TERMS AND
MORE STRATEGIC IN TERMS OF
ARE QUESTIONING SO I HOPE IT'S
BEEN HELPFUL TO ALL OF YOU --
TO TO HEAR FROM OUR COMMITTEE
I'D LIKE TO THINK OF PRESIDENT
BADGERS -- ALSO SURE HARSHAL
-- PRESIDENT OF MEN'S HERE
AND WELCOME AGAIN AND FORMER
PRESIDENT RIVER -- FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY AND
CERTAINLY STEVE CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR -- YOUR RETIREMENT OR
YOUR TRANSITION I'M RETIRED
CHOICE WELL THANK YOU SIR YEAH
WE WE -- APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH YOU AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE DOING
NEXT THANK YOU -- WITH AT THIS
HEARING IS CONCLUDED THANK YOU